MORNING EVERYBODY- WELCOME TO
OUR HEARING TODAY ON
CALIFORNIA'S RECYCLING MARKETS
AND THE COVE IN NINETEEN
IMPACTS THIS IS A JOINT HEARING
OF THE ASSEMBLY NATURAL
RESOURCES COMMITTEE CHAIRED BY
ASSEMBLYWOMAN- FRIEDMAN AS WELL
AS THE SELECT COMMITTEE ON
WASTE REDUCTION WHICH I CHAIR-
SO THIS OF COURSE ISN'T ALWAYS
AN IMPORTANT TOPIC IN
CALIFORNIA. AND EVEN MORE SO
WITH THE COVER NINETEEN IMPACTS
WHICH ARE GOING TO TALK ABOUT
IN GREAT LENGTH TODAY- JUST
SOME HOUSEKEEPING BEFORE YOU
GET IT STARTED- BECAUSE THE
COVER NINETEEN WE HAVE SOME-
UNIQUE- HEARING RESTRICTIONS
THAT EVERYONE'S WELL AWARE OF
SELF SOME HERE SOME OF THE
HEARING PROTOCOL INFORMATION.
THAT DO THEY CONTINUE STAY HOME
ORDER WE ARE PRACTICING
PHYSICAL DISTANCING IN THERE
FOR ONLY A LIMITED NUMBER OF
PEOPLE. MAY WATCH AND
PARTICIPATE IN PERSON FOR
TODAY'S HEARING. OUR
REQUIREMENT MASKEY WARREN AND
PHYSICAL DISTANCING BE
MAINTAINED WEATHER HERE IN THE
ROOM OR AT OUR STATE VIDEO
CONFERENCING LOCATIONS. IF YOU
DO NOT HAVE A MASS WE WILL
CERTAINLY PROVIDE ONE FOR YOU.
FOR ANYBODY WHO'S IN THE ROOM-
WHO WANTS TO PARTICIPATE- WE
ASK THAT YOU- DO YOU PRACTICE
PHYSICAL DISTANCING AND
APPROACH THE MIKE ONE PERSON
THAT TIME. AND REMAIN
DISTANCING AS YOU MOVE AROUND
THE ROOM. AND WE ASK THE PUBLIC
TO NOT TOUCH THE MICROPHONE.
LET'S SEE. FOR WITNESSES BURKE
VIDEO CONFERENCING REMOTE
TESTIMONY WILL HAVE PANELISTS
MAKING USE ONE OF OUR VIDEO
CONFERENCING ROOMS HERE IN THE
CAPITAL AND A REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATIONS LOCATED THROUGHOUT THE
STATE THOSE WITNESSES WILL
APPEAR ON THE SCREEN SO MEMBERS
CAN WATCH THEIR TEST MY LIFE
FROM OUTSIDE AND ALSO ASK THEM
QUESTIONS FOR DIALING WITNESSES
WERE USING A MODERATE TELEPHONE
SERVICE FOR PUBLIC COMMENTS.
YOU CAN FIND THE INFORMATION ON
THE AGENDA FOR TODAY'S HEARING
AND I READ IT AS NOW AS WELL
THE CALLING NUMBER FOR THIS
HEARING IS. 877-692-8957 AGAIN
THE CALL NUMBERS. 877-692-8957
THE ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE
ONE FIVE FOUR TWO A TWO AGAIN
ONE FIVE FOUR TWO A TWO. AGAIN
YOU CAN ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER
ON THE ASSEMBLY WEBSITE AND ON
YOUR SCREEN THE OPERATOR WILL
GIVE YOU INSTRUCTIONS HOW TO BE
PLACED IN THE QUEUE TO PROVIDE
YOUR PUBLIC COMMENTS IF YOU'RE
CALLING IN PLEASE ELIMINATES
ALL BACKGROUND NOISE THANK THIS
INCLUDES MEETING YOUR
LIVESTREAM BROADCAST AND YOUR
SMART DEVICES TO REDUCE THIS UP
THE DISTORTION- WE'VE I SAID
SOCIAL DISTORTION NOT FOUND
DISTORTION ADVOCATE BANTERING
YES I'VE ASKED ALL OUR SPEAKERS
TO LIMIT THEIR PLAN REMARKS TO
SIX MINUTES EACH. SO GO ALLOW
FOR ROBUST CONVERSATION WITH
OUR MEMBERS WILL ALSO HOLD OUR
QUESTIONS FOR ALL. THE SPEAKERS
UNTIL THE END OF EACH PANEL-
THANK YOU FOR YOUR- AND WILL
NOW- PROCEED WITH WITH THE
HEARING. AGAIN AS I SAID
EARLIER A NUMBER OF. HELLO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EGGMAN AS WELL-
WE NOW- HAVE A COVERT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC IT'S IMPACTING ALL
ASPECTS OF CALIFORNIA.
CERTAINLY OUR RECYCLING MARKETS
AND OUR PRACTICES HAVE BEEN
ADJUSTED AS WELL- THIS IS HAD A
RIPPLE EFFECT ON BEHAVIOR WITH
MODIFICATIONS TO WASTE
COLLECTION. AND MANAGEMENT THAT
HAVE REALLY IMPACTED RECYCLING
YEAH FOR THIS WE'VE HAD-
POLICIES ACROSS THE GLOBE.
IMPACTING THE ECONOMIC
VIABILITY OF RECYCLING SO THIS
IS EVEN MORE IMPORTANT TOPIC AS
WE SPEAK TODAY. ON MONDAY WE
HAD A BIG DISCUSSION ABOUT
PLASTIC PLASTIC WASTE. AND THIS
IS A FOLLOW UP WITH THE
OVERALL- WAY STREAMING
CALIFORNIA WE KNOW THAT THIS IS
AN ISSUE WE HAVE. LEGISLATION
IN TWENTY TWENTY AND AGAIN IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TO TRY TO AND
INTERESTED MAKE RIGHT OUR
RECYCLING IN CALIFORNIA. SO
TODAY WE HAVE AN OVERVIEW FOR
MARK CAL RECYCLED- CHIEF. WE
HAVE A SECTION ON THE IMPACTS
TO COLLECTION AND MANAGEMENT.
IN A SECTION ON IMPACTS TO
MARKETS AND THEN PUBLIC
COMMENTS SO- BEFORE IT BEGAN I
WANT TO ASK OUR CULTURE TODAY.
ASSEMBLYWOMAN LAURA FRIEDMAN IF
YOU LIKE TO SAY ANYTHING. THANK.
FIVE RT- FOR HOLDING THIS
HEARING ALL OF THE MEMBERS WHO
ARE REMOTELY ASSIST EGGMAN THIS
AND I KNOW THAT WE OTHERS TO
ONE PASS- THIS IS A VERY FOR
TOPIC I HEAR PASTA POLLUTION
FROM I CAN SEE I ALMOST AS MUCH
AS ANY ISSUE IN CERTAIN ANYONE
WHO'S GOT A YOUNG CHILD IN
THEIR HOME- GETS TO HEAR FROM
THEM CONSTANTLY ABOUT THE
IMPACT THAT THEY SEE IN ARE
BEING TAUGHT. AND YOU KNOW THEY
ALSO QUESTIONS WHAT WAS IT LIKE
BEFORE THERE WAS POLLUTION
EVERYWHERE BEFORE ANIMALS FROM
DYING IN THE OCEAN- FROM
PLASTIC AND SO WE HAVE GOT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE GET A HANDLE
ON THIS UNFORTUNATELY BECAUSE
OF PROBATIVE PARTS WE'VE BEEN
GOING IN THE OPPOSITE DIRECTION
IN CALIFORNIA. WOULD INCREASE-
PRIORITY. BUT AND I'M NOT.
RIGHT START OVER TO MY ON NOW
YEAH SORRY ALL RIGHT WELL I
CAN'T POSSIBLY THAT OPEN ON I
JUST WANTED TO THANK YOU FOR
HOLDING THE HEARING AND FIRST
SUSAN EGGMAN IN THE OTHER
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS WHO ARE
JOINING US AS WELL AS THE OTHER
PANELISTS- WE HAVE BEEN GOING
IN A TERRIBLE DIRECTION WHEN IT
COMES TO PLASTIC POLLUTION IN
CALIFORNIA FOR A NUMBER OF
YEARS AND IN THE ENTIRE- WORLD
AND THIS IS DEFINITELY CAUGHT
THE ATTENTION OF THE PUBLIC EYE
HERE ABOUT PLASTIC POLLUTION
FROM MY CONSTITUENTS CONSTANTLY
I HEAR ABOUT IT FROM MY OWN
DAUGHTER. I SEE THE EFFECTS OF
PLASTIC POLLUTION ARE FARMING
AND WE LEARNED TWO DAYS AGO
ABOUT THE IMPACT ON OUR ON OUR
HEALTH AND HUMAN HEALTH ANIMAL
HELP ON ECO SYSTEMS AND HOW
EVEN IF WE WERE TO STOP
PRODUCING PLASTIC TOMORROW WE'D
STILL HAVE LINGERING AFFECTS
FROM MICROPLASTICS AND FROM.
THE ENVIRONMENTAL DAMAGE THAT
WE'VE ALREADY DONE SO FOR US TO
NOT TAKE DRASTIC STEPS TO STOP
THE CONTINUATION OF THAT OF
THAT ECOLOGICAL DISASTER WOULD
BE REALLY LEGISLATIVE
MALFEASANCE WE'VE GOT TO ACT
WE'VE GOT ACT THIS YEAR AND
COBOTS MAKE IT A LOT MORE
CHALLENGING AS PEOPLE ARE
TAKING MORE MORE TAKEOUT ITEMS
ARE GETTING MORE AND MORE
PRODUCTS DELIVERED TO THEIR
HOME IN NON RECYCLABLE
PLASTICS. AND SO WE HAVE GOT TO
REALLY COME TOGETHER AS A
LEGISLATURE TO FIGURE OUT
SOLUTIONS THAT THE REST OF THE
COUNTRY AND THE REST OF THE
WORLD CAN CAN FOLLOW- OR JOIN
WITH US ON I'M REALLY LOOKING
FORWARD TO HEARING THE
TESTIMONY TODAY AND HOPEFULLY
IT WILL LEAD TO THOUGHT AND
LEGISLATION ACTION. FROM FROM
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I. KNOW THAT WE HAVE TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS JOINING US
REMOTELY. WE HAVE ASSEMBLY
WOMAN CRISTINA GARCIA AND
ASSEMBLYWOMAN SUSAN EGGMAN
JOINING US FROM THEIR
DISTRICTS. IT WOULD EITHER OF
YOU LIKE TO SAY ANYTHING BEFORE
WE PROCEED. I WILL. I JUST LIKE
TO SAY THANK YOU TO THE- TO THE
CHAIRS FOR CONVENING US- I KNOW
YOU HAVE ALL BEEN ATTENDING TO
ISSUES AROUND RECYCLING FOR
YEARS NOW. IN THE PANDEMIC HAS
JUST YEAH YEAH IN MY OWN LIFE
AND IN MY OWN COMMUNITY I SEE
THE EFFECTS OF OVER THE
PANDEMIC IS DONE- ON OUR SINGLE
USE ITEMS ON OUR WIPES ON
EVERYTHING THAT WE WORK SO HARD
TO GET AWAY FROM THAT WERE NOW.
RETURNING TO SO I'M I'M
INTERESTED POWER STATION AND-
I'M REALLY. LOOKING FOR SOME
CONCRETE THINGS THAT THAT WE
CAN DO TO HELP US CLIMB OUT OF
THIS- LAST WEEK MOUNTAIN THAT
WE'RE LIVING IN. THANK YOU.
OKAY ASSEMBLYWOMAN CRISTINA
GARCIA I KNOW YOU'RE THERE I'M
NOT SURE IF YOU LIKE TO SAY
ANYTHING BEFORE AGAIN. I DON'T
HEAR ANYTHING. SO LET'S BEGIN
WITH THE OVERVIEW. FROM OUR
DEPUTY DIRECTOR AT CAL RECYCLE-
ZOE HELLER. EIGHT GOOD MORNING
IS MY- SLIDE SHOW EUROPE YES.
ALL RIGHT LOOK GOOD MORNING AND
THANK YOU FOR HOLDING THIS
IMPORTANT HEARING TODAY VERY
HAPPY TO BE HERE ON YOU'LL
RECOGNIZE MUCH OF THE
INFORMATION THAT I'M SHARING
FROM MONDAY'S PLASTIC HEARING
WHAT I'M GONNA DO IS FRAME IT
IN CODE IMPACTS ON THE
RECYCLING AND SOLID WASTE
SYSTEM. ALL RIGHT NEXT SLIDE.
SO THE DATA THAT I'M GOING TO
SHARE IS AN ALL FROM TWENTY
TWENTY- BUT WHAT IT
DEMONSTRATES IS THAT MANY OF
THE CHALLENGES THAT WE'RE
FACING TODAY. TODAY AS A RESULT
OF COVERAGE- HAVE BEEN GOING ON
FOR MANY YEARS NOW AND WHAT
CODE IS DONE IS IT'S FURTHER
EXACERBATED THESE CHALLENGES
RECYCLING HAS BEEN DECREASING
STATEWIDE SINCE TWENTY FOURTEEN
WERE WITH ANOTHER ALL TIME HIGH
OF 50% IN TWENTY NINETEEN WE
RECYCLE 37% OF WHAT WE
GENERATED IN CALIFORNIA. ALONG
WITH DECLINING RECYCLING RATES
THERE'S BEEN A CORRESPONDING
INCREASE IN GENERATION OF
MATERIAL AND DISPOSAL. WE
HAVEN'T SEEN TWENTY TWENTY
RECYCLING AND DISPOSAL DATA YET
BUT WE KNOW WE WON'T WON'T MEET
AB THREE FORTY ONE SCHOOL OF
75% RECYCLING BY TWENTY TWENTY.
NEXT SLIDE. SO WHAT'S ENDING UP
IN THE WASTE STREAM THIS PIE
CHART OF THE FAMILIAR FROM
MONDAY. BUT WHAT YOU CAN SEE
HERE IS THAT THE AMOUNT OF
PACKAGING AND PACKAGING RELATED
MATERIAL IN THE WASTE STREAM
HAS INCREASED SIGNIFICANTLY
SINCE TWENTY FOURTEEN. BOTH AS
A PROPORTION OF ALL MATERIALS
AND ALSO IS TOTAL TONNAGE. THE
INCREASE IN BOTH PLASTIC AND
PAPER PACKAGING. IS SIGNIFICANT
BECAUSE IT'S DEMONSTRATING.
THAT THE GENERATION OF THESE
MATERIALS IS SURPASSING A
RECYCLING SYSTEMS ABILITY TO
MANAGE THESE MATERIALS. WILL
HAVE ANOTHER WASTE
CHARACTERIZATION BEGINNING IN
THE TWENTY ONE. WILL HAVE A
BETTER SENSE OF HOW COLD IT IS
IMPACTED DISPOSAL. WE'RE ALSO
ADDING NEW MATERIAL TYPES LIKE
PERSONAL PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT.
TO GET A BETTER SENSE OF HOW
MUCH WE'RE DISPOSING. AS WE'VE
ALL WITNESSED AN INCREASE IN PP
AND DISPOSAL CORRESPONDS WITH
AN INCREASE IN PTP VETERAN TO
OUR ENVIRONMENT. WE'VE ALSO
SEEN THIS WITH THE INCREASE IN
SINGLE USE PACKAGING AND
PRODUCTS. ON WHAT IS SHIFTED
HOW WE RECEIVE AND UTILIZE
GOODS AND SERVICES WHICH IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR THIS INCREASING
GENERATION OKAY NEXT SLIDE. IN
CALIFORNIA WE COUNT EXPORTED
RECYCLABLES IS RECYCLED WE
EXPORTED FRACTION OF OUR
VOICESTREAM HISTORICALLY
ACCOUNTED FOR UP TO A THIRD OF
ALL MATERIALS RECYCLED IN
CALIFORNIA. AS YOU CAN SEE FROM
THIS CHART. THE AMOUNT THAT
WE'VE BEEN EXPORTING HAS
DECREASED SIGNIFICANTLY. AND
ALTHOUGH THIS DECREASE HAS
IMPACTED OUR OVERALL RECYCLING
RATES IT'S A GOOD THING. MUCH
OF WHICH WE ARE EXPORTING TO
FOREIGN COUNTRIES WHERE
MATERIALS THAT DID NOT HAVE TO
MASTER MARKETS HERE WE HAVE NO
WAY OF TRACKING WHEN WE EXPORT
THOSE MATERIALS IF THEY'RE
ACTUALLY GETTING RECYCLED
ANOTHER. SO WE DON'T KNOW IF
THEY'RE CONTRIBUTING TO THE
ENVIRONMENTAL AND SOCIAL
CHALLENGES IN THESE OTHER
COUNTRIES. BACKSLIDE. SO ONCE
AGAIN WE'RE GENERATING MORE
MORE STUFF AND THESE CUTS IN
OTHER COUNTRIES ARE NO LONGER
ACCEPTING STUFF. CHINA HAS A
PENDING FOLLOW BASEBAND
FOLLOWING THE NUMBER OF
RESTRICTIVE POLICIES THAT THEY
PUT FORWARD I'M ACCEPTING
RECYCLABLE MATERIAL SINCE ABOUT
TWENTY FOURTEEN. SOUTHEAST ASIA
ALSO HAS A NUMBER OF
RESTRICTIONS IN PLACE AND THE
TWO MAIN MATERIALS THAT ARE
IMPACTED BY THESE RESTRICTIONS
ARE MIXED PLASTICS AND MIXED
PAPER WHICH DON'T HAVE STRONG
DOMESTIC MARKETS. THE BATTLE
CONVENTION IS ADDING ON JANUARY
FIRST TWENTY ONE RIGHT AROUND
THE CORNER MIXED PLASTICS WHICH
WILL IMPACT OUR ABILITY TO
TRADE MIXED PLASTICS TO ANY
OTHER COUNTRIES ESPECIALLY
SINCE U. S. IS NOT A MEMBER OF
THE BASIL CONVENTION. AND THEN
COATED IN HAS COULD HAVE
IMPACTED OUR ABILITY TO MOVE
MATERIALS TO SHIPPING LINES
HAVE BEEN DISTRACTED AND MOST
OF THE CHALLENGES THAT WE'VE
SEEN HERE IN THE US FOR
RECYCLING AND DISPOSAL ARE ALSO
HAPPENING IN OTHER COUNTRIES.
AROUND THE GLOBE. NEXT SLIDE.
SO WHAT HAVE BEEN SOME OF THE
MAJOR FACTOR CODE THAT WE'RE
SEEING WELL THE GOVERNOR SIGNED
AN EXECUTIVE ORDER IN APRIL TWO
ADDRESSED ON THE RECYCLING
CHALLENGES RESULTING FROM
COVERAGE ZERO WAS INTRODUCED TO
A LOT OF BEVERAGE CONTAINER
RECYCLING CENTERS TO
TEMPORARILY SUSPEND THEIR
SIERRA BEAVER DAM SHOPPER
OPERATIONS OR REDUCE OPERATING.
HOURS IN ADDITION IT'LL TO AND
RETAILERS TO TEMPER SO THEIR
BEVERAGE CONTAINER BACK THE- OR
ORDER. IT HALTED A OF USE OF
THIS USE DISPOSABLE BAG BAN
MANY GROCERS RETAILERS COULD.
OFF OR SINGLE USE JUST BAG. AND
AS A RESULT WE SEE INCREASE OF
THOSE BOTH OUR ENVIRONMENT
BEING TO. IN ALSO CONTAIN OUR-
STREAM. THE IARC'S FIRED. BUT
WE'RE STILL SOME OF IMPACT OF.
THE RESTRICTIONS FROM. THE L.
ON THE YEAR WAS ISSUE FROM ON
NO ABOUT THE NINETEEN IT HOW
TRANSIT. SINCE THE CAL OSHA HAS
THE GUIDANCE FOR NON OF INTO.
IN GROW STORES AND- INFORMATION
ON REASON BACKS BE SAFE USED
AND HAVE. CAN COULD BE SAFER.
SOME RECYCLABLE FACILITIES
TEMPORARY CLOSE DUE TO CAN
ABOUT STATE. THAT'S ABOUT IF
PEOPLE COULD NOT PRACTICALLY DO
IN THOSE THIS. DURING THAT TIME
SUMMERS. WENT TO WIN. WE DON'T
KNOW EXACTLY HOW MUCH BUT WE
SHOULD GET A BETTER SENSE WHEN
WE RECEIVE OUR DATA FROM TWENTY
TWENTY RECYCLING AND DISPOSAL
REPORTING SYSTEM. IT'S OUR
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE MAJORITY
OF THESE FACILITIES THAT HAD
INITIALLY SHUT DOWN HAVE RE
OPENED. WE'VE ALSO SEEN A
REDUCTION IN COMMERCIAL
RECYCLABLE COLLECTION IN AN
INCREASE IN RESIDENTIAL
RECYCLABLE COLLECTION WHICH IS
A SURPRISE GIVING THE STATE
HOME ORDER. AND THE CLOSURE OF
BUSINESSES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. SURE THERE'S BEEN
ACROSS THE BOARD DECREASE AND
RECYCLE. AND WITH THE TIGHT
SUPPLY OF RECYCLED PAPER AND ON
CARDBOARD THE PRICE OF
RECOVERED PAPER INCREASED
DRAMATICALLY OVER THE SPAN OF A
FEW MONTHS. THE OPPOSITE IS
HAPPENING FOR PLASTICS GLOBAL
OIL PRICES HAVE DROPPED CAUSING
THE PRICE THE VIRGIN PLASTICS
TO DROP INCENTIVIZING THE USE
OF VIRGIN PLASTIC OVER RECYCLED
CONTENT. NEXT SLIDE. WE'VE SEEN
AN IMPACT TO THE BEVERAGE
CONTAINER RECYCLING PROGRAM WE
INITIALLY SAW A SIGNIFICANT
DROP IN RECYCLING VOLUME
HOWEVER THE VOLUME HAS SLOWLY
STARTED TO GO UP AS THE STATE
HAS REOPENED. IN JANUARY OF
TWENTY WE HAD ABOUT 80%
RECYCLING RATE THIS ROPPED TO
ABOUT 47% IN MARCH. AND IS NOW
BACK UP TO THE LOW SEVENTIES
ONCE AGAIN THIS IS PRELIMINARY
DATA THIS DATA ISN'T MATURE BUT
THESE ARE THE TRENDS THAT WE'RE
SEEING. THE SALES INCREASE
COULD HAVE BEEN DUE TO A
VARIETY OF FACTORS BECAUSE OF
COVERAGE OR EATING AND DRINKING
OUT LAST AND INITIALLY PEOPLE
WERE STOCKING UP ON GROCERIES
AND BEVERAGES. TO HAVE AN
ADEQUATE SUPPLY AT HOME. THE
DECREASE IN RETURNS COULD BE
DUE TO THE EXECUTIVE ORDER WITH
THE TEMPORARY CLOSURES OF
RECYCLING CENTERS IN THE
SUBURBS THE SPEND A DEALER TAKE
BACK REQUIREMENTS. SUMMERSIDE
CENTERS DID NOT RE OPENED TO
ECONOMIC OR STAFFING REASONS OR
SAFETY CONCERNS. THERE'S ALSO
VARIATION ACROSS THE STATE AND
HOW GROCERS ARE ARE ON
RESPONSIBLE FOR. REDEEMING
BOTTLES AND CANS SOME GROCERS
CAN OPT TO PAY A FEE TO THE
DEPARMENT INSTEAD OF TAKING
BACK CONTAINERS. HELLO RECYCLE
RELEASED AB FIFTY FOUR REPORT
TO PROVIDE OPTIONS TO ADDRESS
BEVERAGE CONTAINER RECYCLING
CHALLENGES. SOME OF THESE
OPTIONS INCLUDED MORE
FLEXIBILITY FOR REDUCTION ON
THESE ACTIONS IN THE REPORT
COULD HELP ADDRESS SOME OF THE
COVERT IMPACTS THAT WE'RE
SEEING TODAY. EIGHTY SEVEN
NINETY THREE REQUIRING MINIMUM
RECYCLED CONTENT IS A TIMELY
AND IMPORTANT OPPORTUNITY TO
INCREASE RECYCLED CONTENT- AND
DRIVE DEMAND FOR THE CLEAN
MATERIALS THAT THE BEVERAGE
CONTAINER RECYCLING PROGRAM.
PRODUCES NEXT SLIDE. I MENTION
THIS THIS CHART ON- ON MONDAY
AND- IT'S REALLY INTERESTING
BECAUSE IT GIVES US A SENSE OF
WHAT THE LONGER TERM IMPACTS
COULD BE. LOOKING TOWARDS
CALIFORNIA'S FUTURE DISPOSAL
RECYCLING RATES IT'S WORTH
LOOKING AT THIS CHART SHOWING
THE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
DISPOSAL AND CHANGING JUST IN
CALIFORNIA. AS YOU CAN SEE THEY
ARE VERY VERY CLOSELY TIED.
ECONOMIC GROWTH THE GENERALLY
MEANS INCREASED DISPOSAL THIS
IS NOT THE ONLY FACTOR BUT IT
PLAYS A ROLE. AS WE CONSIDER
THE LONGER TERM IMPACTS TO COPE
WITH NINETEEN CRISIS AND THE
RECESSION WE'LL SEE IF THIS
TREND CONTINUES AND IF DISPOSAL
DECREASES CORRESPONDINGLY. NEXT
SLIDE. SO THIS PART WILL ALSO
LOOK FAMILIAR HOW DO WE ADDRESS
THE CHALLENGES WE'RE FACING
TODAY COVERT RELATED AND
OTHERWISE. AND I THINK THIS
MODEL- STAYS RELEVANT FOR THIS
CONVERSATION AS WELL. THE FIRST
IS TO REDUCE WASTE. THE SECOND
IS TO INCREASE YOUR USE COVERED
NINETEEN HAS IMPACTED THE
ABILITY- TO USE REASONABLE
ALTERNATIVES TO DISPOSABLE
PRODUCTS AND PACKAGING
STATEWIDE. WE'RE SLOWLY SEEING
THIS TREND REVERSES PUBLIC
HEALTH DATA IS SHOWING THAT
RESEMBLES CAN BE AFELY USED.
WE NEED TO OPTIMIZE EXPAND
INFRASTRUCTURE IN ORDER TO
MANAGE OVER STILL GENERATING.
WE NEED ON TOP THEM AS OUR
CURRENT INFRASTRUCTURE. AND
EXPAND APPROPRIATE STRUCTURE.
RECYCLABLES ARE LOOKS. WE NEED
TO DO A RESPONSE. AND
SUPPORTIVE POLICIES ALSO PLAY A
SIGNIFICANT ROLE HERE- I
MENTIONED THE IMPORTANCE OF
MINERAL CONTENT RISK
LEGISLATION POLICIES THAT
SUPPORT SOURCE REDUCTION. MORE
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE MANY
FACTORS THAT ARE BRINGING THESE
MATERIALS INTO THE STATE THESE
CAN HELP ALLEVIATE THE BURDEN
ON THE REPAIRS AND THE
JURISDICTIONS OUT THIS
INCREASED GENERATION IS
OVERWHELMING RECYCLING AND
SOLID WASTE. ALSO POLICIES THAT
SUPPORT ENSURING THAT WE'RE
GENERATING IS COMPATIBLE WITH
THE AVAILABLE INFRASTRUCTURE
COULD HELP US SEE A REDUCTION
IMPACTS FROM KOBE. AND THE
OVERALL SOLID WASTE AND
RECYCLING CHALLENGES. NOW MY
FINAL SLIDE. ON SOME OF WHAT'S
AHEAD WILL HELP US ADDRESS THE
CHALLENGES ASSOCIATED COVER.
THE RECYCLING AND DISPOSAL
REPORTING SYSTEM WILL GIVE US A
BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF
RECYCLABLE MATERIAL FLOW AND
DISPOSAL THAT WE CAN BETTER
MANAGE AND TRACK THE IMPACT THE
CODED. ORGANICS DIVERSION TO
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE IS
IMPORTANT TO NOTE WILL HELP US
REACH UR RECYCLING GOALS WHILE
REDUCING SHORT LIVED CLIMATE
POLLUTANTS BUT WHERE IT'S MOST
RELEVANT TO. COVER NINETEEN
IMPACTS THERE'S A FEDERAL FOOD
RESCUE COMPONENT THIRTEEN
EIGHTY THREE IS HUNGER
ESCALATING STATEWIDE THIRTEEN
EIGHTY THREE REQUIRES US TO
RESCUE EDIBLE FOOD TO HELP
PROVIDE MEALS FOR THE ONE IN
FOUR CALIFORNIANS THAT ARE FOOD
INSECURE. SB THIRTEEN THIRTY
FIVE RIGHTS WILL BE FINALIZED
BY THE END OF THIS YEAR AND
THEY WILL DEFINE RECYCLABLE
REUSABLE AND COMPOSTABLE.
FOODSERVICE PACKAGING IN STATE
FACILITIES AND ALL REQUIRE THAT
THESE MATERIALS ARE ACTUALLY
RECYCLED REUSED OR COMPOSTED.
THESE DEFINITIONS COULD HAVE
BROADER APPLICABILITY IF WE SEE
COMPREHENSIVE PACKAGING
REQUIRED IN CALIFORNIA. SO IN
CLOSING OVERCOMING THE
CHALLENGES THAT CODE HAS
BROUGHT TO THE SOLID WASTE
RECYCLING SYSTEM WILL TAKE A
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH ONE THAT
ADDRESSES ALL COMPONENTS OF THE
RECYCLING AND SOLID WASTE
SYSTEM. REDUCING WASTE
INCREASING MANUFACTURER SPONSOR
BILITY SUPPORTING
INFRASTRUCTURE TO PROCESS WE'RE
STILL GENERATING THESE ARE ALL
CRITICAL TO MEETING OUR
ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS AND
PROGRESSING TOWARDS. A MORE
CIRCULAR ECONOMY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THE
PRESENT. I KNOW WE'LL HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS FOR FROM YOU- AND
COUNTY CYCLE IT GO. AND IF YOU
BELONG. TO FURTHER OKAY I KNOW
YOU TALKED A BIT ABOUT- WHAT'S
HAPPENING ACROSS THE GLOBE
SPECIFICALLY IN ASIA AND OF
COURSE THE LAST YEAR'S ALL THAT
KIND OF. THE OTHER SOUTHEAST
ASIAN COUNTRIES- AND- THAT HAVE
AN IMPACT AS WELL I JUST WANTED
TO ASK TWO QUESTIONS ON WHERE
AT THE RECYCLING AND PUT IT
NINETEEN. AS FAR AS THE
INTERNATIONAL AGREEMENTS ON
RECYCLING EXPORTS. WHAT
SPECIFICALLY HAS COVERED
NINETEEN DONE TO IMPACT THOSE-
SO I DON'T THINK HOPE IT'S
ACTUALLY IMPACTED THE
INTERNATIONAL AGREEMENTS I
THINK WHAT IT'S DONE IS IT'S-
REALLY MAGNIFIED THE CHALLENGES
ASSOCIATED WITH MOVING HARD TO
RECYCLE MATERIAL AS A RESULT OF
THE INCREASED GENERATION THAT
WE'RE SEEING. OF MATERIALS THAT
WE TRADITIONALLY EXPORTED SO
FOR EXAMPLE SINCE THERE AREN'T
MANY DOMESTIC MARKETS FOR
PLASTICS THREE THROUGH SEVENTH
WHICH MAKE UP A LOT OF OUR OUR
ON PACKAGING IN SINGLE USE
DISPOSABLE PRODUCTS WE'RE NOT
ABLE TO MOVE THOSE PRODUCT
THOSE ON RECYCLABLES TO OTHER
COUNTRIES WHICH MEANS WERE. E
HAVE A CHALLENGE TO HAVE TO
FIGURE OUT EITHER HOW TO MANAGE
THEM HERE WHERE WE DON'T HAVE
TO MESS TO CONCUR STRUCTURE OR
REDUCE THE GENERATION OF THOSE
MATERIALS SO THAT THEY DON'T
CREATE CHALLENGES IN OUR
RECYCLING SYSTEM. OKAY AND THEN
SECONDLY WHAT DO YOU THINK ARE
THE LONG TERM. IMPACTS AS FAR
AS KOBE NINETEEN AND A
RECYCLING SYSTEM. OR WILL JUST
GET BACK TO WHERE WE WORK WHICH
FRANKLY WASN'T GOOD IN THE
FIRST PLACE AS WILL GET AS ALL
GET ONTO BUT- HOW MUCH MORE. OF
A CHALLENGES ARE RECYCLING
GONNA BE AFTER THIS CALL THE
NINETEEN AREAS IS COMPLETED
BECAUSE OF COVER NINETEEN. IT'S
REALLY GOING TO DEPEND ON A LOT
OF FACTORS ON THE FIRST IS WHAT
HAPPENS WITH GENERATION.
OVERALL IS A RESULT OF COVERT
ARE WE GOING TO DECREASE
GENERATION IN CALIFORNIA AND WE
JUST DON'T KNOW BECAUSE WE
DON'T HAVE PREVIOUS DATA. TO
SHOW WHAT HAPPENS WITH A GLOBAL
PANDEMIC- SO IT'S HARD TO SAY
BUT WE DO KNOW THAT THE CHANGE
IN BEHAVIOR THE INCREASED AND
ON THE RESIDENTIAL RECYCLING
STREAM. AND THE CHANGE OF
BEHAVIOR MEANING THAT-
INCREASED AND GENERATION OF THE
SINGLE USE DISPOSABLE PRODUCTS
AND PACKAGING. IS REALLY
STRAINING OUR SYSTEM ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES WITH ON THE
RESIDENTIAL- RECYCLING STREAM
IS IT'S NOT AS CLEAN AS THE
COMMERCIAL RECYCLING STREAM
WHICH MEANS THAT PUTS A LOT OF
PRESSURE ON OUR SYSTEM. TO HAVE
TO SEPARATE OUT THOSE MATERIALS
TO CREATE CLEAN BELLS THAT ARE
ACTUALLY MARKETABLE. SO WHAT
WE'LL SEE IS MORE OF THAT
MATERIAL GOING TO DISPOSAL
BECAUSE OF CONTAMINATION IN THE
SYSTEM. SO THE CHALLENGES ARE
GOING TO BE PROBABLY LESS
ABILITY TO RECYCLE MATERIALS
AND REALLY CHALLENGE US TO
THINK FROM A POLICY
PERSPECTIVE. HOW TO GET A
HANDLE ON ON WHAT WE'RE
GENERATING AND HAVE A REALLY A
LINE THAT WITH THE EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE. AND THE
ADDITIONAL INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
WE WANT TO STAY IN THE STATE.
OKAY THANK YOU. BILL. SO IF I
KNOW WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
HOW TO HOW TO REDUCE WASTE AND
SO MANY DIFFERENT FRONTS
WHETHER IT'S INDIVIDUAL
PLASTICS AS WELL AS YOU HAVE
PACKAGING- WHAT ARE SOME OF
YOUR- YOU KNOW THOUGHTS
RECOMMENDATIONS ABOUT HOW WE
COULD. HELP HOW WE REALLY
SHOULD BE- MANAGING THAT
CONVERSATION OBISPO SORT OF
PUSHING THE ENVELOPE ON THOSE
ISSUES. YEAH THAT'S A GOOD
QUESTION AND- YOU KNOW. WE
REALLY THINK MINIMUM CONTENT IS
A GREAT START BECAUSE IT HELPS
ENSURE THAT THAT MATERIALS
ACTUALLY STAY IN THE SYSTEM AND
THAT WERE UTILIZING. THE
RECYCLABLE MATERIAL THAT WERE
THAT WERE GENERATING BUT BUT
YOU ASKED ALSO SPECIFICALLY
ABOUT SOURCE REDUCTION AND HOW
WE ENCOURAGE MORE MORE SOURCE
REDUCTION IN THE SYSTEM AND
THAT'S A CHALLENGE BECAUSE A
LOT OF THAT. IT'S DEPENDENT ON
TWO THINGS ONE IS- IS OVERALL
BEHAVIOR CHANGE OF THE CONSUMER
HOW CAN WE HAVE MORE OPTIONS
THAT THAT ENCOURAGE SOURCE
REDUCTION THAT ENCOURAGE LESS
USING LESS MATERIALS. AND THE
OTHER IS ON MANUFACTURE
RESPONSIBILITY ENSURING THAT
MANUFACTURERS ARE ARE DESIGNING
ON PRODUCTS AND PACKAGING THAT
THAT ARE REUSABLE THAT- ALIGNED
WITH THE SYSTEM BETTER BUT-
REDUCING GENERATION IS REALLY
IMPORTANT AND THEN ENSURING
THAT WHAT WE'RE GENERATING.
REUSING RECYCLED CONTENT AND
THAT- IT ACTUALLY IS RECYCLABLE
COMPOSTABLE OR REUSABLE SO THAT
IT DOESN'T HELP THE OVERALL
GREENHOUSE GAS AND
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS THAT
WE'RE SEEING THESE PRODUCTS
HAVE. YOU MAJORED. POSSIBILITY
I THINK IS AN EXCELLENT POINT
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW. IF YOU TALK
TO CONSUMERS. CONSUMERS WILL
ALWAYS TAKE CONVENIENCE AND
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE SEEING IT'S
IN EVERYTHING IS DRIVEN TO. BE
MORE CONVENIENT FOR CONSUMERS
WHICH IS UNDERSTANDABLE THAT'S
SORT OF ONE OF A COMPANY'S JOB
IS TO DO. BUT WHAT'S HAPPENING
RIGHT NOW IS THE PRICE OF THE
CONVENIENCE IN TERMS OF THE
IMPACT ON THE ENVIRONMENT IS
NOT REALLY BEING FACTORED IN.
SO HAVE WE SEEN OTHER COUNTRIES
ARE THERE ARE. OTHER PLACES
THAT HAVE BEEN ABLE TO. START
TO FACTOR THAT PRICE OF
ENVIRONMENTAL DEGRADATION INTO
THAT CONVENIENCE. YEAH IN END-
THERE'S MANY DIFFERENT WAYS TO
GET IT THAT THERE'S ADVANCED
DISPOSAL FEES ON THEIR SHREW ON
EXTENDED PRODUCER
RESPONSIBILITY PROGRAMS WHERE-
THE MANUFACTURERS ARE ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE END OF LIFE
MANAGEMENT AND RECYCLING OF
THOSE PRODUCTS- THERE'S A
NUMBER OF MODELS THAT HAVE VERY
SUCCESS ON DEPENDING ON ON THE
UNIVERSAL PRODUCTS AND
PACKAGING THAT THAT THEY
ADDRESSED AND HOW THOSE ON HOW
THOSE MODELS ARE ARE
IMPLEMENTED SO. FOR EXAMPLE
HERE IN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE THE
BIG BEVERAGE CONTAINER
RECYCLING PROGRAM WHICH HAS ITS
CHALLENGES BUT IS ALSO- YOU
KNOW HAS BEEN SUCCESSFUL AS FAR
AS KEEPING A RELATIVELY HIGH
RECYCLING RATE AND DELIVERING
THAT THAT CLEAN MATERIAL THAT
CAN BE. RE MANUFACTURED INTO
OTHER BOTTLES AND CANS OR OTHER
PRODUCTS SO- IN THERE'S ALSO
ARE I DO WANNA MENTION THERE
ARE A NUMBER OF INDUSTRY
INITIATIVES RIGHT NOW- THE
ELLEN MACARTHUR ON A GLOBAL
PLASTICS PACT FOR EXAMPLE IS
ONE WHERE THERE IS ALSO A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
INVESTMENT FROM INDUSTRY TO
INCREASE RECYCLING RATES TO
REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF MATERIAL
THAT THEY'RE USING TO INCREASE
RECYCLED CONTENT BUT WE JUST
DON'T KNOW IF THOSE. IF THE ON
OUTCOMES OF THOSE- INITIATIVES
WILL DELIVER WHAT. WE NEED TO
GET A BETTER HANDLE ON THIS
ISSUE. ARE THERE STATE SIR OR
COUNTRIES YOU FEEL LIKE HEY
SHOULD REALLY. TAKE A CLOSER
LOOK AT WHAT WHAT THEY'RE DOING
IN TERMS OF- YOUR TICKET TO GET
IDEAS FOR US. DEFINITELY AND
IT'S KIND OF DEPENDENT ON ON
WHERE YOU WANT TO LOOK YOU KNOW
FOR BOTTLE BILL FOR EXAMPLE ON
THERE'S A REASON WHICH ORG AND
ON. YOU KNOW OTHER COUNTRIES
ARE IMPLEMENTING THEIR PROGRAMS
WHERE THEY'RE SEEING SUCCESS
THERE BUT THEY'RE VERY
DIFFERENT IN CALIFORNIA BUT I
STILL THINK THAT THERE'S ON
ELEMENTS OF THOSE PROBLEMS
PROGRAMS THAT COULD BE
SIGNIFICANT FOR. SURE THINKING
ABOUT WAYS IN WHICH WE CAN
PROVE BOTTLE BILL AND SOME OF
THOSE ARE- INVITED IN ALREADY
FIFTY FOUR REPORT AND IN THE
ACKNOWLEDGE WHERE WE SEE THOSE
STRENGTHS IN OTHER COUNTRIES
WHEN IT COMES TO PACKAGING. ON
THIS IS A MERGING YOU KNOW
THERE'S THAT EUROPEAN UNION IS
ON IS IMPLEMENTING- ARE YOU
KNOW. REDUCTION ALL PRODUCTS
ARE- BRISK. HAS EXTENDED
PRODUCER RESPONSIBILITY PROGRAM
AND THERE'S ELEMENTS OF ALL OF
THOSE MODELS THAT THAT. COULD
HAVE COULD BE SUCCESSFUL HERE
IT'S JUST. WOULD HAVE TO DESIGN
THEM FOR HOW THINGS WORK IN
CALIFORNIA YOU KNOW FOR EXAMPLE
IN CALIFORNIA THERE'S A LOT OF
LOCAL CONTROL OF ON THE
RECYCLING COLLECTION SYSTEMS
WHICH HAS WORKED IN CALIFORNIA
SO HOW DO WE ALIGN THESE
MODELS. THAT HAVE BEEN
SUCCESSFUL IN OTHER COUNTRIES
WITH THE EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE IN CALIFORNIA TO
OPTIMIZE THAT INFRASTRUCTURE
AND TO HELP US TAKE ON MORE
AGGRESSIVELY SOME OF THESE
ISSUES THAT THAT WE'VE SEEN
STATEWIDE. THANK YOU. THANKS
FOR MENTIONING MINIMUM CONTENT
AND IN THE BONNEVILLE- IT'S
FELT LIKE WE WERE LONG OVERDUE
FROM DOING. BOTTLE BILL REFORM
AND I JUST WANTED TO GET A
SENSE FROM THE DEPARTMENT'S
POINT OF VIEW- WHAT YOUR HEAD
IS AROUND POTENTIAL REFORM OF.
BOTTLE BILL BECAUSE IT SEEMS
LIKE. EVERY YEAR WEEK SORT OF
TEETER ON THE BRINK OF DISASTER
WHEN THE RECYCLING RATES GET
WELL. GET GET. TOTAL SO. JUST
CURIOUS WHERE THE WHERE THE
DEPARTMENT'S THINKING ABOUT
BOTTLE BILL AND- WHAT KINDS OF
REFORMS WE SHOULD BE
CONSIDERING. SURE THANK YOU FOR
THAT QUESTION SO WE'RE WE'RE
REALLY EXCITED ABOUT THE ON AB
FIFTY FOUR PILOT PROJECTS THAT
WE'VE AWARDED. THAT ARE ON
JURISDICTIONS ARE ARE
PARTNERING WITH RECYCLERS TO.
PROVIDE MORE FLEXIBLE OPTIONS
FOR CONVENIENCE AND WE'RE
EXCITED ABOUT THE BROADER
APPLICATION THAT THOSE CAN HAVE
WHEN THEY DEMONSTRATE SUCCESS
AND I KNOW IT'S A LITTLE BIT
LIKE A BROKEN RECORD HERE BUT
THE AB FIFTY FOUR PORT WE FEEL
VERY STRONGLY THAT THE
RECOMMENDATIONS IN THERE.
PARTICULARLY AROUND
FLEXIBILITY- FOR- REDEMPTION
OPTIONS ARE CRITICAL FOR
CONVENIENCE STATEWIDE TO ENSURE
THAT CALIFORNIANS CAN GET THEIR
NICKELS AND DIMES BACK IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES SO VERY EXCITED
ABOUT HOW THESE PILOT PROJECTS
WILL WILL- UNFOLD AND THEN WITH
THAT. HOW THAT COULD HAVE
BROADER APPLICABILITY STATEWIDE
AS AS WE PUT FORTY MAYBE FIFTY
FOUR REPORT PERFECT AND THEN
THE MONEY WINDSOR PUTS A REPORT
COMING OUT AGAIN I FORGOT I
MUST'VE MISSED NOT HER THAT
SACRIFICE- THE QUARTERLY. YES
REPORT OF THE COMMITTEE- YEAH
AND THERE WAS A LARGE I'M
FORGETTING THE BILL NUMBER LAST
SESSION THAT HAS TO CHANGE THAT
TO ON BIANNUAL BUT WHAT WE'VE
DONE IS- ON OUR WEBSITE WE'RE
NOW RELEASING MONTHLY REPORTS
THAT ARE NOT MATURE DATA SO YOU
KNOW AS YOU KNOW THAT ITS
PRELIMINARY DATA BUT WHAT IT
DOES HELP US SEE AS TRENDS IN
THE STOMACH SO IT SHOWS. YOU
KNOW RETURNS ON AND SALES TO
HELP US GET A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF HOW CODES
IMPACTING THE SYSTEM IN A MORE-
UP TO DATE SNAPSHOT OF WHERE WE
ARE IN THE PROGRAM PERFECT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
IT. SIX THANK YOU. SOME A
MEMBER FOR FRIEDMAN THANK YOU
FOR JOINING US AGAIN TODAY- FOR
SECOND OF THESE TWO HEARINGS I
HAVE A TECHNICAL QUESTION WHICH
IS IF YOU HAVE A ARM BOTTLE OR
A CLAM SHELL OR ANY OTHER- BIT
OF PLASTIC- PACKAGING THAT IS
BEEN RECYCLED SO LET'S SAY IT'S
MADE OUT OF A 100% RECYCLED
CONTENT. CAN THAT. CAN I
PACKAGE BE RECYCLED YET AGAIN
HOW MANY TIMES CAN PLASTIC TO.
BE RECYCLED. YOU KNOW- I DON'T
KNOW THE EXACT ANSWER I DO KNOW
THAT- YOU KNOW P. T. NH DA ARE
ABLE TO BE RECYCLED MANY TIMES
BUT I COULDN'T TELL YOU THE
EXACT AMOUNT OF TIME- WITH
PAPER IT'S MORE CHALLENGING
BECAUSE EACH TIME PAPERS
RECYCLED THE FIBERS GET A
LITTLE BIT SHORTER. SO THEIR
ABILITY TO BE TURNED INTO ON
ANOTHER PAPER PRODUCT EMISSIONS
WITH EACH TIME THAT THEIR
RECYCLED BUT WITH THAT SAID YOU
KNOW THEY STILL THE ON FOR
EXAMPLE COPY PAPER ON COULD BE
RECYCLED BACK INTO COPY PAPER A
NUMBER OF TIMES BEFORE WOULD
HAVE TO BE. YOU KNOW DOWNGRADED
TO ON A LOWER GRADE PAPER SO
IT'S REALLY DEPENDENT ON THE
MATERIAL TYPE AND I CAN GET
BACK TO YOU WITH- WITH MORE
DETAILS ON PLASTICS YEAH I'D
LIKE SOME SOME INFORMATION
BECAUSE I'VE SEEN CONFLICTING
INFORMATION ABOUT THAT ABOUT
WHAT IT CAN BE RECYCLED INTO
AND HOW MANY TIMES- THAT YOU
KNOW SO BE GOOD TO GET SOME
CLARITY. FROM FROM CAL RECYCLE
ABOUT SOME OF THOSE TECHNICAL-
DIFFICULTIES OR CHALLENGES- YOU
KNOW IT SEEMS TO ME AND I DON'T
KNOW THAT THIS IS REALLY A
QUESTION BUT IT SEEMS TO ME
THAT. FOR MANY YEARS- INDUSTRY
HAS BEEN. REALLY PUSHING
RECYCLING AS AS YOU WOULD WANT
TO CERTAINLY AND- THEN
PROMOTING THE IDEA THAT WHEN
PLASTIC GETS INTO THE
ENVIRONMENT IT'S BECAUSE IT'S
THE FAULT OF THE CONSUMERS THAT
THEY DON'T BEAR THE
RESPONSIBILITY THAT'S BECAUSE
PEOPLE AREN'T BEHAVING WELL.
AND WE KNOW THAT THAT'S THAT'S
NOT TRUE BECAUSE EVEN WHEN
PEOPLE PROPERLY DISPOSE OF
RECYCLED PRODUCTS MANY TIMES
THEY'RE NOT RECYCLE BECAUSE
THERE'S NO MARKET FOR THEM OR
IT'S TOO EXPENSIVE AND THE VERY
SAME INDUSTRIES. THAT COMPLAIN
ABOUT THE LITTER BLAME THE
LETTER. I FOR THE LACK OF RE.
OR THE ONES THEMSELVES WHO ARE
NOT WILLING TO PAY EXTRA MONEY.
TO USE THE RECYCLED CONTENT SO
IT SEEMS TO ME TO BE EXTREMELY
DISINGENUOUS. TO SAY THAT IT'S
CONSUMERS. OR A LACK OF
INVESTMENT FROM GOVERNMENT
THAT'S CREATING THE PROBLEM BUT
WE OURSELVES DON'T WANT TO BE
ANY PART OF THE SOLUTION WE
DON'T WANNA PAY A COUPLE EXTRA
SENSE. FOR MORE EXPENSIVE
BOTTLE OR BOTTLE THAT LOOKS
DIFFERENT- SO- I FIND THAT VERY
INTERESTING- AND- YOU KNOW I
WOULD SAY THAT. YOU LOOKING AT
YOUR GRAPH ABOUT THINGS BEING
RECYCLED. WE HAVE BEEN TELLING
CONSUMERS FOR YEARS THAT ALL
THESE PRODUCTS ARE RECYCLABLE
IN THAT MESSAGE TO CONSUMERS AS
EVERY SINGLE PIECE OF PLASTIC
CAN BE RECYCLED ME MY HUSBAND.
WE WILL TAKE THE RAPPER OF
SOMETHING LIKE THIS AND PUT IT
IN THE RECYCLE BIN IS THIS
RECYCLABLE. RIGHT NOW YEAH OKAY
BUT HE THINKS IT IS BECAUSE WE
TELL PEOPLE THAT THIS IS ALL
RECYCLABLE THEN THEY
CONTAMINATE THE WAY STREAMING
MAKE IT EVEN MORE DIFFICULT SO
WE TALK ABOUT WHAT CONSUMERS
WANT CONSUMERS DON'T KNOW THAT
THE THINGS THAT THEY THINK ARE
BEING RECYCLED ARE NOT BEING
RECYCLED AND I THINK WERE
VASTLY UNDERESTIMATING. THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC AND THEIR
DESIRE TO HAVE A CLEAN
ENVIRONMENT TO BE GOOD STEWARDS
OF THE LAND TO BE SOCIALLY
RESPONSIBLE BECAUSE WE'RE
TELLING THEM THESE PRODUCTS ARE
AND WILL YOU HAVE A BLUE BIN
AND ALL YOU HAVE TO DO IS THROW
THIS STUFF IN THE BLUE BIN AND
YOU'VE DONE YOUR PART. SO THIS
IS THIS FICTION THAT'S BEEN
CREATED. BY INDUSTRY AND BY US.
AND IT THE RESULT IS MOUNTAINS
OF. PLASTIC AND ARE FILLING UP
OUR LANDFILLS PEOPLE WANT TO
LANDFILLS NEAR THEM CLOSED THEY
DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY. THEY'RE
DOING ALL THIS RECYCLING
WEISS'S LANDFILL STILL FILLING
UP. THEY DON'T UNDERSTAND THAT
BECAUSE WE'RE NOT TELLING THE
TRUTH. I WAS ABSOLUTELY. YEAH
YES AND- MEANWHILE INDUSTRY
COMPLAINS THAT PEOPLE WILL HAVE
TO PAY MORE IF THEY SWITCH TO
DIFFERENT TYPES OF PACKAGING
WHERE IF THEY USE MORE
PACKAGING IF IT'S CLASSES HAVE
YEAR TO COST MORE THE PRODUCTS.
BUT WE'RE ALSO NOT CLEARLY
TELLING THE PUBLIC THAT THEY
ARE PAYING THE COST OF NOT JUST
THE PLASTIC POLLUTION BUT
THEY'RE PAYING THE COST OF
DIVERSION THAT'S VERY VERY
DIFFICULT BECAUSE IT'S
REFLECTED IN THEIR UTILITY BILL
IN THEIR SWER FEE AND THEIR
LANDFILL FEES AND EVERYTHING
ELSE THAT MUNICIPAL GOVERNMENT
HAS TO PASS ON TO THEM THE RATE
PAYERS. SO EVEN IF YOU BUY NO
PLASTIC EVEN IF YOU'RE SOMEONE
WHO. NEVER ORDERS FROM AN
ONLINE SOURCE WHO GOES OUT OF
THEIR WAY TO BUY GLASS.
PACKAGING YOU'RE STILL PAYING
AS MUCH AS SOMEONE WHO. IS
BUYING TONS AND TONS OF PLASTIC
SO YOU DON'T HAVE ANY CHOICE.
SO IT JUST SEEMS TO ME THAT
WE'VE- PASSED CONTINUE TO
PROMOTE THIS FICTION ABOUT.
THIS MAGIC BLUE BIN OR WHATEVER
COLOR IT IS IN YOUR COMMUNITY
WHERE ALL THE PROBLEMS ARE
SOLVED AND WE HAVE TO STOP
PROMOTING THAT FICTION WE HAVE
TO GET REAL WITH THE WITH THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC. AND I THINK
THAT YOU WOULD SEE- REAL
BACKLASH OF PEOPLE REALLY
UNDERSTOOD WHAT WAS WHAT WAS
HAPPENING HERE SO. I DON'T KNOW
IF YOU HAVE ANYTHING YOU WANT
TO RESPOND TO THAT THAT'S FINE
IF YOU DON'T THAT'S FINE TOO. I
JUST I COMPLETELY AGREE WITH
YOU THERE'S BEEN AN
OVERSIMPLIFICATION. OF OUR
SYSTEM WHERE. YOU YOU PRINTED
IT PERFECTLY WHERE. YOU KNOW WE
DROP SOMETHING IN OUR BLUE BIN
AND WE MAGICALLY EPECT THAT IT
GETS TURNED INTO SOMETHING ELSE
WHEN THERE'S- A COMPLEX PROCESS
THAT HAPPENS AFTER THAT WERE
OFTENTIMES. THESE MATERIALS
THAT PEOPLE ARE HOPING OR
WISHING GET THAT GET RECYCLED
ARE CONTAMINATING THE RECYCLING
THE RECYCLING SYSTEM. SO
THERE'S A COMPONENT
MANUFACTURER RESPONSIBILITY
THAT NEEDS TO BE ASSOCIATED
WITH THAT- JUST WANTED TO GIVE
A QUICK. PLUG FOR ON AN
INITIATIVE THAT COLOR CYCLES
TAKING ON. WE'RE DOING ON A
THREE YEAR ON FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLAR PUBLIC EDUCATION
CAMPAIGN THAT WE JUST RECENTLY
LAUNCHED. AND IT'S GOING TO
FOCUSED ON ON COMMUNITY BASED
SOCIAL MARKETING. IN WORKING
WITH JURISDICTIONS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. TO HELP ON BETTER
UNDERSTAND. WHAT ARE THE
CHALLENGES AS FAR AS ON.
GETTING THE CORRECT ITEMS IN
THE BLUE BAND TO ENSURE THAT.
WERE ONLY PUTTING RECYCLABLES
IN THE BLUE BAND AND WHAT
BEHAVIOR CHANGES NEEDED SO THAT
WE CAN. CLEAN UP THE STRAIN YOU
KNOW. SUCCESSFUL ON A
SUCCESSFUL SYSTEM IS REALLY
BASED ON A NUMBER OF PRINCIPLES
AND- WE TEND TO LOSE SIGHT IN
THESE CONVERSATIONS OF THE
REDUCING REUSING. TO YOUR POINT
THOSE ARE CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
AND TRUST WE NEED TO FOCUS ON
GENERATE STUFF AND WE'RE STILL
GENERATING WE NEED TO ENSURE
THAT IT REALLY ALIGNS WITH THE
SYSTEMS IN CALIFORNIA. SO IT'S
NOT CONTAMINATING SYSTEMS AND
CREATING THIS. ADDITIONAL COST
AN ADDITIONAL BURDEN ON. THE
REPAIR AND ON JURISDICTIONS.
THANK YOU. OKAY THANK YOU- WE
HAVE A NUMBER OF OTHER
PANELISTS WHO WANT TO JOIN US
TODAY SO WILL WILL BE ASKED TO
IS EITHER THE ONLY WOMAN AG MAN
OR GARCIA WE HAVE ANY.
QUESTIONS FOR THESE FOR THIS
PANEL FROM THE CAR RECYCLE I
JUST LIKE TO MAKE A STATEMENT
IF I COULD SURE. YEAH I JUST I
MEAN I APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATION BUT MY SOCIAL WORK
HEART ALSO WANTS US TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE NOT BLAMING
PEOPLE RIGHT NOW WHEN THEY ARE.
WHEN WE ARE WE'RE LIVING IN A
GLOBAL PANDEMIC EVERYBODY'S
TRYING O THEIR BEST TO STAY
SAFE TRY TO THE BEST TO KEEP
YOUR FAMILY SAFE- SO. I JUST
THINK IT THE ONUS IS UPON US-
AND I AND I DID SOME
LEGISLATION LAST YEAR TO
HOPEFULLY TRY TO STREAMLINE THE
CURBSIDE RECYCLING BECAUSE I
THINK. YOU KNOW PEOPLE ARE
TRYING TO DO THEIR BEST AND WE
NEED TO MAKE THE PROCESS A LOT
EASIER FOR PEOPLE TO BE ABLE TO
RECYCLE WHAT GOES INTO WHAT
GOES OUT THAT IT SHOULDN'T BE.
AS COMPLICATED AS IT IS AND I
THINK IT'S INCUMBENT UPON US.
AS POLICY MAKERS AND AS
HOPEFULLY IN A INDUSTRY
LEADERS- ARE ALSO GOING TO BE
ABLE TO. I MEAN WE CANNOT
CONTINUE TO HOLD PEOPLE WHO ARE
STRUGGLING TO KEEP THEIR HOMES
THAT ARE STRUGGLING TO. KEEP
THEIR FAMILY FED- TO ALSO HOLD
THEM ULTIMATELY SHOULD
RESPONSIBLE FOR ALL THE
RECYCLED CONTENT THAT IS NOW
BEING FLOODED INTO OUR SYSTEM
SO I JUST WANT TO BE ON THE ON
THE RECORD FOR SAYING. IT IS
FANTASTIC THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO REDUCE IT AND
I THINK WE MUST BUT I ALSO
REALLY THINK THAT WE NEED TO
PUT THE ONUS ON THE OTHER END
OF THE WE STREAM RIGHT NOW.
THEN ON THE CONSUMER TRYING TO
DO THEIR THEIR VERY BEST. WELL
SAID THANK YOU. OKAY WE'RE
GONNA GO TO THE PANEL NOW ABOUT
THE IMPACTS TO COLLECTION AND
MANAGEMENT. WE'RE GONNA START
WAS SUSAN COLLINS PRESIDENT OF
CONTAINER. RECYCLING INSTITUTE.
HI GOOD MORNING. GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING CHAIRS AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR THE
INTRODUCTION- I WAS ASKED TO
SPEAK ABOUT HOW THE CODE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS AFFECTED
RECYCLING COLLECTION PROGRAMS
IN CALIFORNIA MY EXPERTISE IS
IN CALIFORNIA'S BEVERAGE
CONTAINER RECYCLING LAW SO I'M
GOING TO BE SPEAKING MORE TO
THOSE- COMMODITIES AND THAT
PROGRAM THAN ANYTHING ELSE BUT
I WANT TO GIVE ONE REALLY BIG
OBSERVATION HERE WHICH IS THAT
IN MY THIRTY YEARS BEING IN THE
RECYCLING INDUSTRY THIS HAS
BEEN THE BIGGEST FASTEST
SHIPPED AND MATERIAL TYPES THAT
I'VE EVER SEEN THIS YEAR IN
TWENTY TWENTY- WE'VE BEEN
MONITORING THE CHANGES AROUND
THE COUNTRY AND WE'VE EVEN
DEDICATED- PAGE ON OUR WEBSITE
JUST TO TRACKING THE CHANGES IN
COLLECTION PROGRAMS- FOR
BEVERAGE CONTAINERS. AROUND THE
COUNTRY AND THAT THE WAY THAT
THEY WERE ALL INTERRUPTED
TEMPORARILY I'M ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE'VE SEEN AND THAT
WE'VE ALL SEEN PROBABLY IS THAT
TAKE OUT PACKAGING HAS
INCREASED TREMENDOUSLY AS THE
DINE IN RESTAURANTS HAVE TRIED
TO SHIFT TO TAKE OUT
RESTAURANTS IN ORDER TO
CONTINUE THEIR BUSINESS DURING
THIS PANDEMIC. BUT WE'VE ALSO
SEEN CHANGES AND BEVERAGE
CONTAINERS THAT MOST CONSUMERS
PROBABLY ARE NOT AWARE OF AND
IS- HE SAID KOBE NINETEEN HAS
EXACERBATED PROBLEMS IN THE
RECYCLING INDUSTRY THAT ALREADY
EXISTED WE TOOK A DEEP DIVE
INTO THE DATA TO FIGURE OUT
WHICH CHANGES WERE DUE TO THAT
WERE ALREADY EXISTING AND WE'RE
CONTINUING TRENDS AND WHICH
TRENDS WERE SPECIFICALLY
RELATED TO THE PANDEMIC AND SO
THE LAST TWO SLIDES IN MY
PRESENTATION ARE GONNA LOOK AT
THAT MORE DEEPLY. I TALKED
ABOUT A PERMANENT SHIFT IN
MATERIAL TYPES OR MAYBE SEMI
PERMANENT. ONE EXAMPLE IS THAT
ALUMINUM CANS HAVE SEEN A HUGE
INCREASE MORE PEOPLE ARE
STAYING AT HOME AND WE'RE
WORKING AT HOME. AND ALUMINUM
CANS OF THE MOST POPULAR TYPE
OF CONTAINERS FOR AT HOME USE
PARTLY OWING TO THE EASE OF
STORAGE OF TWELVE PACKS AND SIX
AND TWENTY FOUR PACKS AND
REFRIGERATORS- AND WE'RE ALSO
SEEING THAT BECAUSE PEOPLE
AREN'T IN RESTAURANTS THEY'RE
NOT CONSUMING. DRAFT BEER THAT
COMES OUT OF CAKES THEY'RE NOT
CONSUMING FOUNTAIN DRINKS THAT
THEY WOULD NORMALLY CONSUME IN
RESTAURANTS OR TAKE OUT PLACES.
SO THAT HAS LAGGED
INTERESTINGLY TO A COMPLETE
DISRUPTION OF THE SUPPLY CHAIN
THERE HAS LITERALLY BEEN A
SHORTAGE OF ALUMINUM CANS IN
THE UNITED STATES. THE CRAFT
BEER INDUSTRY WAS UP ENDED
OVERNIGHT WITH CLOSURES OF BARS
AND RESTAURANTS BECAUSE 50% OF
THEIR BUSINESS WAS DRAFT BEER
AND CAKES. THEY LITERALLY HAD
TO THROW OUT BEER AND
COORDINATE WITH MUNICIPAL SEWER
SYSTEMS TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
DIDN'T OVERLOAD SYSTEMS- SO
SOME OF THEIR THEIR DECADE
BUSINESS WAS DOWN NEARLY A 100%
OVERNIGHT WHEN THE PANDEMIC
STARTED IN MARCH. AND SO THE
SHIFTED DRINKING AT HOME
BECAUSE IS MORE NEED FOR
BOTTLES AND CANS. THAT HAS LED
TO WHAT WE THINK IS A 6%
UPTICK. SEMI PERMANENT UPTICK
IN THE USE OF- BOTTLES AND CANS
SALES OF PACKAGED BEVERAGES IN
IT THROUGHOUT THE UNITED
STATES. THERE WAS A FURTHER
DISRUPTION OF THE I'M SORRY
SLIDE TO PLEASE GO TO NEXT
SLIDE THERE WAS A FURTHER
DISRUPTION IN THE RECYCLING
SUPPLY CHAIN AS A RESULT OF THE
SUSPENSION OF THE DEPOSIT
RETENTION PROGRAMS AND ALL TEN
STATES. BUT FIRST I HAVE TO
EXPLAIN WHY THIS IS. NOT MOST
PEOPLE DON'T KNOW THIS KEY FACT
THAT CONTAINERS THAT ARE ON
DEPOSIT DATA TREMENDOUS
INCENTIVE. TO TAKE BACK YOUR
BOTTLES AND CANS LIKE THE C. R.
V. PROGRAM THAT WE HAVE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA BUT THOSE PROGRAMS
ONLY EXIST IN TEN STATES. THIS
CHART SHOWS HOW DRAMATICALLY
HIGHER. THE RECYCLING RATES ARE
FOR BEVERAGE CONTAINERS ON
DEPOSIT THIRTY TWO OR THREE
TIMES SOMETIMES EVEN FOUR TIMES
AS HIGH. AS THE CONTAINERS THAT
ARE NOT ON DEPOSIT NATIONALLY.
AND AS A RESULT OF THAT NEARLY
50% OF ALL BEVERAGE CONTAINER
RECYCLING COMES FROM JUST THE
TEN STATES THAT HAVE A BEVERAGE
CONTAINER DEPOSIT LAW. SO LET'S
LOOK AT THE NEXT SLIDE SLIDE
THREE. SO I SAID THAT I WOULD.
LOOK AT THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
COVERTRELATED ISSUES AND NON
COVERT RELATED. WE HAVE A
FATALLY FLAWED PAYMENT FORMULA
FOR REDEMPTION CENTERS IN
CALIFORNIA. LEADING TO OVER
THIS PERIOD OF TIME- MORE THAN
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS THAT
THEY'VE BEEN UNDERPAID. AS A
RESULT HALF OF THE REDEMPTION
CENTERS IN CALIFORNIA HAVE GONE
OUT OF BUSINESS IN THE LAST
FIVE YEARS. IT'S ALSO RELATED
TO DRAMATICALLY DECLINING
MARKET PRICES. LET'S LOOK AT
THE NEXT SLIDE. AGAIN THESE ARE
PROBLEMS THAT PRE THAT EXISTED
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC STARTED SO
THIS SLIDE SHOWS HOW WE'VE LOST
ALL OF THESE REDEMPTION
CENTERS. AND THAT MEANS THAT
THERE ARE MORE PEOPLE CROWDING
INTO FEWER REDEMPTION CENTERS.
IT ALSO THIS SITE DOESN'T SHOW
IT BUT MORE OF THE REDEMPTION
CENTERS HAVE BEEN LOST IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AND
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. SO LET'S
SEE THE NEXT SLIDE AND SEE WHAT
THAT WITH THAT HAS A COST. THE
BEVERAGE CONTAINERS RETURNED IN
THESE- AND SELECTED SOUTHERN
AND CENTRAL CALIFORNIA. ACT
COMMUNITIES THESE COUNTIES. IS
NOW AT A PER CAPITA RATE OF
FIVE HUNDRED EIGHTY. IN THIS IN
THE SECOND ROW OF DATA IN THE
CHART THE SELECTED NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA COUNTIES THOSE THAT
HAVE RECEIVED AND HAVE SEEN THE
MOST REDEMPTION CENTERS CLOSE.
THEY'RE ONLY ABLE TO COLLECT
THREE HUNDRED TWENTY ONE.
CONTAINERS PER CAPITA EVEN
THOUGH OUR CONSUMPTION IS.
UNIFORM THROUGHOUT THE STATE SO
THE CURBSIDE PROGRAMS OF PICKED
UP A LITTLE BIT OF THAT SLACK
BUT THEY REALLY ONLY PICKED UP
ONE OUT OF EVERY FIVE
CONTAINERS THAT WAS LOST THE
REST OF BEEN LOST TO THE
LANDFILL. SO THESE ARE THE PRE
COBIT IMPACTS THE NEXT SLIDE
ALSO IS PRE CODED. I'M THE
SCRAP VALUES HAVE BEEN TRENDING
DOWN SINCE TWO THOUSAND TWELVE
DOT HAS BEEN ONE OF THE
CONTRIBUTING FACTORS. P. ET
PLASTIC AND ALUMINUM CANS
ESPECIALLY THAT'S WHERE MORE
MOST OF THE REVENUE COMES FROM.
IT WAS SEEING DOWNWARD TREND IN
PRICING FOR MANY YEARS AND THEN
THERE WAS AN ABSOLUTE CRASH
WHEN THE CORONAVIRUS HAPPENED.
ALL OF THE COMMODITY MARKETS
ARE AFFECTED BY DIFFERENT
THINGS. ALUMINUM CANS VERSUS PT
PLASTIC THEY ALL- TRAVEL DOWN
THEIR OWN PATH THEY ALL HAVE
THEIR OWN THINGS THAT THEY
COMPETE WITH THEIR ALL SUBJECT
TO WORLDWIDE TRENDS AS WELL AS-
AT LOCAL AND NATIONAL TRENDS. I
AM SO IN THE WORLDWIDE MARKET
ENERGY PRICES DO YOU IMPACT
COMMODITY PRICES WE ALSO HAVE
AN ISSUE WITH ALUMINUM CANS
WHERE CANNED SHEET
MANUFACTURING- WAS CLOSED DOWN
IN THE UNITED STATES AND- THE
BEGINNING OF TWENTY NINETEEN
AND SHIFTED TO SAUDI ARABIA SO
THAT'S ALL IMPACTING THIS AS
WELL- BUT THESE MATERIAL PRICES
HAVE. HAVE IMPACTED REDEMPTION
CENTERS TREMENDOUSLY IN OF LED
TO THE CLOSURE OF REDEMPTION
CENTERS AS WE TALKED ABOUT. SO
ON THE NEXT SLIDE. AM I JUST
WANT TO EMPHASIZE AGAIN THAT
THE TAX CUTS THE COMMODITIES
THAT WE GENERATE THROUGH
RECYCLING OF OUR BOTTLES AND
CANS THE GLASS OF THE PT
PLASTIC THE ALUMINUM. IS IN
TREMENDOUS DEMANDS AND IS
TREMENDOUSLY NEEDED BY THE
MANUFACTURERS OF THOSE
CONTAINERS BECAUSE THEY ALL USE
SOME AMOUNT OF RECYCLED
CONTENT. THEY MUST HAVE THE
CONTENT IN ORDER TO MAKE NEW
BOTTLES AND CANS AGAIN AND ALL
OF THE MAJOR TRADE ASSOCIATIONS
SPOKE UP THIS YEAR AFTER THE
DISRUPTION THAT OCCURRED
BECAUSE OF THE CORONA VIRUS AND
THEY SAID WE ARE VERY MUCH
DEPENDENT ON THESE DEPOSIT
PROGRAMS THAT EXIST AROUND THE
UNITED STATES. AND WE VERY MUCH
SUPPORT THESE PROGRAMS. SO
NARAL THE ON THE NEXT SLIDE
SLIDE EIGHT WE'LL LOOK AT
WHAT'S HAPPENED HERE IN
CALIFORNIA DUE TO THE
CORONAVIRUS. THE SOLID LINE IS
TWENTY EIGHTEEN SO WE'LL
CONSIDER THAT THE BASELINE OF
PACKAGED BEVERAGE SALES IN
CALIFORNIA. AND THEN THE DOTTED
LINE IS WHAT HAPPENED IN THE
FIRST SEVEN MONTHS OF TWENTY
TWENTY YOU CAN SEE THAT IT'S IN
A RADIC AND JUMP AND THEN
DECLINE WHAT HAPPENS THERE IS
THAT BEVERAGE SALES PEAKED
DRAMATICALLY IN MARCH THAT'S
THAT HUGE SPIKE THAT YOU SEE IN
MARCH WITH THE DOTTED LINE.
THAT'S WHEN EVERYBODY WENT TO
THE STORE AND STOCKED UP ON
BOTTLED WATER AND OTHER
BEVERAGES AND AS THE PANDEMIC
BEGAN THEN YOU SEE A HUGE-
SHIFT DOWNWARD IN APRIL. AS
EVERYONE WAS- STAYING AT HOME
WITH ALL THAT MATERIALS ARE ALL
HAS BEVERAGES THAT THEY HAD
PURCHASED IN MARCH. THEN YOU
SEE IN MAY THAT THE DOTTED LINE
RISES ABOVE THE SOLID LINE
MEANING TWENTY TWENTY SALES ARE
HIGHER. DAN TWENTY NINETEEN
SALES AND WE'RE SEEING THAT
AROUND THE NATION SO BASICALLY
THIS SHIFT TO ADD HOME SHIFTED
AWAY FROM- FOUNTAIN DRINKS AND
CAKE DRINKS. MEANS THAT MORE
PEOPLE ARE BUYING PACKAGE
BEVERAGES AND THAT'S A SEMI
PERMANENT CHANGE AS LONG AS
WE'RE ALL STAYING AT HOME AND
OUT OF RESTAURANTS. WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE SLIGHTLY HIGHER
BEVERAGE SALES INTO THE FUTURE
AND SO FAR WE THINK IT'S ABOUT
6% HIGHER THAN USUAL. THE NEXT
SLIDE. IS ACTUALLY THE LAST
SLIDE THIS LOOKS AT- CALIFORNIA
C. R. V. RETURNS. SO WHAT WE
SAW HAPPENING HERE HI I SHARED
THE STORY OF HOW THE REDEMPTION
CENTERS HAVE CLOSED THROUGHOUT
THE STATE THAT HAS LED. OVERALL
TO LAST REDEMPTION. LOWER
NUMBER OF UNITS REDEEMED LOWER
NUMBER OF UNITS RECYCLED.
THAT'S A PERMANENT CHANGE BUT
YOU CAN ALSO SEE ON THE SLIDE
THE TEMPORARY CHANGE THAT
HAPPENED AGAIN IN MARCH AND
APRIL FRONT PREDOMINANTLY WHEN
THINGS CLOSED DOWN AND THE BLUE
DOTTED LINE SHOWS HOW
DRAMATICALLY THE CONTAINER
RETURNS DROP TYPE DURING THAT
JUST WANTED TO ASK YOU SEASON
IN MARCH AND APRIL AND THEN
THEY CAME BACK UP IN MAY
MANJINDER HIGHER. BUT YOU CAN
SEE THAT THE DOTTED LINE IS
STILL BELOW THE SOLID LINES
WERE STILL SEEING LAST AS A
PURPOSE PERMANENT OR SEMI
PERMANENT CHANGE COMPARED TO
BEFORE. AND THAT'S THAT'S THE
LAST OF MY REMARKS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OKAY THANK YOU
PERFECT I WILL COME BACK TO A
FEW QUESTIONS FROM YOU I WAS
REALLY INTRIGUED ABOUT THE
ALUMINUM ISSUE- BUT WE HAVE TO
MORE- SPEAKERS FOR THIS PANEL.
REMINDER SPEAKERS WERE ASKING
YOU TO KEEP YOUR COMMENTS TO.
SIX MINUTES SIX MINUTES SO NEXT
WE HAVE VERONICA PART OF WITH
THE REGULATORY AFFAIRS. FOR THE
RESOURCE RECOVERY COALITION OF
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE IT HI. PARDO NICE
SERVICE THE REGULATORY AFFAIRS
DIRECTOR FOR THE RESOURCE
RECOVERY COALITION OF
CALIFORNIA I'M THANKFUL FOR THE
OPPORTUNIST BE TO YOU ALL ON
THE IMPACTS OF CODE IN NINETEEN
ON THE WASTE AND RECYCLING
INDUSTRY AND WHAT'S NEXT FOR
CALIFORNIA'S AMBITIOUS WASTE
DIVERSION GOALS. AND I ALSO
REALLY LIKE TO TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO THANK OUR
CENTRAL WORKERS- DURING THIS
INCREDIBLY CHALLENGING TIME.
THE RESOURCE RECOVERY COALITION
OF CALIFORNIA IS COMPRISED OF
PREDOMINANTLY SMALL TO MID
SIZED INDEPENDENT SOLID WASTE
AND RECYCLING COMPANIES. MANY
WHO HAVE WORKED ALONGSIDE THEIR
JURISDICTIONS FOR DECADES. I TO
MEET OUR STATE MANDATED
RECYCLING AND DIVERSION
EXPECTATIONS. LIKE MANY
INDUSTRIES- HARMON BIRDS WERE
IMMEDIATELY IMPACTED BY COPE IN
NINETEEN. BUT AS ESSENTIAL
SERVICE PROVIDERS IT WAS
CRITICAL- THAT THEY CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE SERVICES AND PROTECT
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF THEIR
COMMUNITIES- HAD THE START OF
THE PANDEMIC THE SHELTER IN
PLACE ORDERS AND NONESSENTIAL
BUSINESS CLOSURES. CAUSED AN
IMMEDIATE- INJECTOR MATIC
CHANGE IN- SERVICES AND
MATERIAL VOLUMES NAMELY WE SAW
A DECREASE IN TONNAGE AND
SERVICES IN THE COMMERCIAL
SECTOR OBVIOUSLY WITH
RESTAURANT CLOSURES AND
BUSINESS CLOSURES A LOT LESS
MATERIAL WAS COMING FROM. THOSE
BUSINESS. EXCUSE ME THOSE
BUSINESSES- BUT ON THE FLIP
SIDE WE SAW AN INCREASE IN
TONNAGE IN SERVICES IN THE
RESIDENTIAL SECTOR- YOU KNOW
THERE'S BEEN THIS WORD STAYING
AT HOME AND FOLKS ARE CLEANING
OUT THE GARAGES AND YOU KNOW
JUST FOLKS ARE CONSUMING AT
HOME AS AS BEEN DESCRIBED AND
SO YOU'RE SEEING MORE MATERIAL
ACTUALLY FLOW THROUGH THE
RESIDENTIAL SECTOR. NOW AS- SO
DESCRIBED MANAGING WASTE
MATERIAL IS OF COURSE A LOCAL
ISSUE- BUT OUR ASSOCIATION
RELEASED A GUIDANCE DOCUMENT TO
ASSIST OUR MEMBERS AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT TO OFFER POTENTIAL
OPTIONS TO ADJUST SERVICES-
BASED ON NEED AND IMPACT FOR
KOBE NINETEEN SO YOU KNOW JUST
SOME EXAMPLES. WE DID HAVE TO
SLOW SOME WINDS DOWN FOR
PROCESSING AND SOCIALLY
JUSTIN'S WORKERS SO. YOU KNOW
PROCESSING TIMES HAD TO BE
SLOWED DOWN- AND JUST THESE
IMPACTS JUST OF COURSE IMPACTED
PROCESSING MORE GENERALLY. BUT
NOW AS WE CONTINUE TO MOVE
THROUGH THE PANDEMIC AND INTO.
HOPEFULLY A RECOVERY PERIOD-
WE'RE FOCUSED ON HOW TO SUPPORT
CITIES AND RATEPAYERS IN
ADDITION TO SERVICE PROVIDERS.
AND WE'VE IDENTIFIED POLICIES
PROGRAMS AND REAL REGULATIONS
THAT ENCOURAGE INFRASTRUCTURE
DEVELOPMENT AS KEY TO
STIMULATING THE LOCAL COMIC
ECONOMY AND CREATING GREEN JOBS-
THAT IS WHY WERE LOOKING
FORWARD TO IMPLEMENTING THE S.
B. THIRTEEN H. THREE
REGULATIONS WHICH WILL REQUIRE
RECYCLING OF ORGANIC MATERIAL
STATEWIDE BEGINNING JANUARY
ONE. TWENTY TWENTY TWO AND
PROVIDE OPPORTUNITIES TO BUILD
MORE IN STATE INFRASTRUCTURE
AND PROGRAMS TO MANAGE OUR
ORGANIC MATERIAL. I'M A WE ARE
VERY EXCITED- ABOUT THIS
OPPORTUNITY. WE ARE ALSO HYPER
AWARE OF THE ISSUES WE FACE IN
MEETING THIS IMPORTANT METHANE
REDUCTION GOAL AND THE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS UNFUNDED
MANDATE. IT IS ESTIMATED THAT
SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE
ORGANICS RECYCLING WILL
IMPLEMENTATION INFRASTRUCTURE.
DEVELOPMENT WILL COST UPWARDS
OF TEN BILLION BY TWENTY THIRTY
TO ACHIEVE. AND WITH SO MUCH
UNCERTAINTY REGARDING THESE
EXTENDED FISCAL IMPACTS OF KOBE
NINETEEN SOME COMMUNITIES
NATIONALLY ARE NOW MORE
CONSTRAINED IN THEIR ABILITY TO
MEET THIS VERY IMPORTANT GOAL.
SO WE SEE A REALLY CRITICAL
NEED TO HARMONIZE OUR STATE
REGULATORY POLICIES AND
FRAMEWORKS TO INCENTIVIZE AND
ACCELERATE THE DIP DEVELOPMENT
OF SB THIRTEEN THREE PROGRAMS
ORGANIC RECYCLING PROGRAMS.
ESPECIALLY AS WE LOOK TO BUILD
THE FACILITIES NECESSARY TO
MANAGE THIS MATERIAL.
UNFORTUNATELY CALIFORNIA LACKS
THE INFRASTRUCTURE NECESSARY TO
MANAGE THE VOLUME OF ORGANIC
WASTE WE GENERATE. THE TWO
PRIMARY MECHANISMS BY WHICH WE
PLAN TO MANAGE THIS MATERIAL IS
COMPOSTING AND ANAEROBIC
DIGESTION. WHICH EACH PROVIDE
THEIR OWN OPPORTUNITIES AND
LIMITATIONS AND I ENCOURAGE YOU
TO PLEASE TAKE A LOOK AT OUR
WHITE PAPER WHICH GOES INTO
MORE DETAIL. BUT SUFFICE IT TO
SAY THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT
REGULATORY BARRIERS TO BUILDING
THIS INFRASTRUCTURE WHICH
SERVES AS THE ALTERNATIVE
MANAGEMENT TO PUTTING THIS
MATERIAL INTO THE SANITARY
LANDFILL. AND WITH THESE
INCREASE BARRIERS OF COURSE
COME INCREASED COSTS. SO WHAT
ARE WE GOING TO DO HOW CAN WE
HARMONIZE EFFORTS TO RAPIDLY
INCENTIVIZE AND ADVANCE
CALIFORNIA'S GOAL OF DIVERTING
ORGANIC WASTE TO BENEFICIAL USE.
WE SUPPORT A LONG TERM STRATEGY
TO EFFICIENTLY DIVERT ORGANIC
WASTE FROM THE LANDFILL. THAT
ADDRESSES THE COSTS AND
REGIONAL REGIONAL REGULATORY
LIMITATIONS ORGANICS MANAGEMENT
INCLUDING A STRATEGY FOR
RENEWABLE BIOGAS AND COMPOST
USE. WITH CROSS AGENCY
AGREEMENT ON THE IMMEDIATE MID
TERM AND LONG TERM APPROACH TO
MITIGATING AND MANAGING THIS
ORGANIC WASTE. THE STRATEGY
SHOULD INCLUDE GOALS FOR LOCAL
ORGANIC WASTE MANAGEMENT
DEVELOPMENT THE SUPPORT A
CIRCULAR ECONOMY FRAMEWORK
BOLSTERING LOCAL RESILIENCE AND
PUTTING ORGANIC WAYS TO
BENEFICIAL USE WITHIN THE LOCAL
COMMUNITY. WE HAVE TO LINE OR
AGENCY GOALS. FOR EXAMPLE WHILE
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE MOVE TO
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES WE ALSO
NEED REGULATORY CERTAINTY THE
RENEWABLE BIOGAS PRODUCED FROM
ANAEROBIC DIGESTION. CURRENTLY
PROVIDING THE MOST CARBON
REDUCTIONS WHEN USED AS
RENEWABLE TRANSPORTATION FUEL
HAS A HOME IN CALIFORNIA'S
ENERGY FUTURE AND THE
DEVELOPMENT IS ADVANCED. NOT
ABANDONED AS WE TACKLE
CALIFORNIA'S AIR QUALITY GOALS.
AND ISSUES SO ULTIMATELY- OUR
COMMUNITIES NEED SOME KIND OF
FINANCIAL SUPPORT FOR. ORGANIC
RECYCLING IMPLEMENTATION WHICH
COULD BE ADDRESSED A NUMBER OF
WAYS- HISTORICALLY CAL RECYCLE
HAS ON OFFER SEED GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTION GRANT FUND MONEY-
GRANT MONEY. TO SUPPORT
PROJECTS BUT LONG TERM FUNDING
POSSIBLY FROM A COMBINATION OF
SOURCES SUCH AS AN INCREASED-
LANDFILL TIP FEES A BROADER
FACILITY FEE OR SOME OTHER
MECHANISM. COULD HELP DIRECT
FUNDS TO ACCELERATE AND SUSTAIN
ORGANIC WASTE DIVERSION
PROGRAMS. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME I'M HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS AND MY COLLEAGUES
LOWER FRONT IS ON THE PHONE AS
WELL TO HELP ANSWER QUESTIONS.
OKAY THANK YOU ARE OUR LAST-
SPEAKER FOR THIS PANEL WILL BE
RICHARD THAT VICE. PRESIDENT
CEO. TRY CD COMMUNITY RECYCLING.
THE TECHNICIAN CARE- THIS IS
RICHARD BY A OF A PRESIDENT TO.
TRY TO THE ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
CORPORATION BASED IN UNION CITY
CALIFORNIA. WE ARE CALIFORNIA'S
LARGEST NONPROFIT RECYCLING
OPERATION WE HAVE BEEN IN
BUSINESS FOR FORTY YEARS
INCORPORATED IN JANUARY
NINETEEN EIGHTY. AND THAT WE
ARE A NET ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
CORPORATION THAT OWNS FIVE
ACRES IN UNION CITY WHICH IS
BANNED ARCADING GREATS WITH
REGARD TO STAYING IN THE
BUSINESS OF RECYCLING- WE
EMPLOYED SEVEN. FULL TIME
EMPLOYEES. I'M SURE UNION LOCAL
SEVEN OUT OF OKAY CAL. AND THE
IMPACT OF COLD IT ON OUR
BUSINESS HAVE BEEN SIGNIFICANT
WITHIN A CENTRAL WORKERS SINCE
DAY ONE. WE ALSO RUN A FULL
SERVICE RECYCLING BUY BACK
CENTRE. BY LOCAL YOU THE
FORMERLY INCARCERATED AND DOOR
PEOPLE OF THAT HAVE BEEN
ATTACKED BY THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM. TWENTY FIVE OR
EMPLOYEES ARE LOCAL YOU. AND
THEY RANGE IN AGE FROM SIXTEEN
TO TWENTY TWO YEARS OLD- WE
RECYCLE ABOUT A HUNDRED TONS OF
MATERIAL PER DAY- OUR RECYCLING
PROGRAM AND WE SEVEN CITIES OF
HAYWARD. AND UNION CITY OUR OUR
VIDAK: CENTER WILL HOLD ITS
FIRST YEAH IT. WOOD IMPACTED WE
WERE ONLY GETTING ABOUT. FIFTY
TO SEVENTY FIVE CUSTOMERS PER
DAY. ONCE THE INITIAL FEAR OF
HOLE THAT LIFTED A LITTLE BIT
IN OUR AREA THIS WAS LATE
MARCH. EARLY APRIL WE STARTED
TO SEE AN INCREASE THEREBY BACK
RECYCLING SYSTEM- BASE WE ARE
NOW AVERAGING THREE HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY FIVE CUSTOMERS PER DAY.
IN A RECYCLING CENTER WE
RECYCLE PER DAY ABOUT TWO
HUNDRED THIRTY THOUSAND P. E.
T. BOTTLES OR ABOUT TEN TONS OF
PLASTIC P. E. T. BOTTLES ABOUT
TWO AND A HALF TIMES OF
ALUMINUM CANS PER DAY AND ABOUT
FIVE TONS OF BLACKOUTS THESE
ARE ALL OF THE R. V. CALIFORNIA
RETENTION MATERIAL. THEY COME
TO OUR CENTER THE WAITING LINE
IS ABOUT AN HOUR AND TEN
MINUTES. AND EXTENDS FOR
SEVERAL BLOCKS- WE HAVE WE
SERVICE ABOUT THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND CUSTOMERS- ARE BATES
BECAUSE ALL OF THE REDEMPTION
CENTERS IN THE GREATER BAY AREA
HAVE PRETTY MUCH THAT SHUT DOWN
AND THERE ARE ONLY ABOUT EIGHT
TO TEN OF US LEFT. SERVING A
SIGNIFICANT A POPULATION. SHOW
THAT A HUGE IMPACT IN THIS IS
BECAUSE THE REDEMPTION CENTER
THAT YOU KNOW. THROUGHOUT THE
STATE MANY OF THEM CRITICALLY
IN IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA HAVE
GONE BELLY UP. AT THE ONLY
REASON THAT WE DIDN'T GO BELLY
UP IS BECAUSE WE OWN FIVE
ACRES. AND WE'RE ABLE TO KEEP
OUR HEAD ABOVE WATER. WE'VE
SEEN A SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON
COATED WITH REGARD TO OUR
RESIDENTIAL RECYCLING- WE ARE
EXPERIENCING ABOUT 35240%
CONTAMINATION. AND THE
RESIDENTIAL RECYCLING PROGRAM
WE'RE SEEING A LOT OF FACE MASK
COMING ACROSS OUR STORYLINE.
WHICH WIND UP AT THE END OF
YOUR LINE WE NEVER TOUCH THAT
MATERIAL. ON THE INITIAL STAGES
BETWEEN MARCH IN LATE APRIL.
OUR INDUSTRY WAS NOT TOUCHING
ANYTHING ON THE SHORELINE ARE
DRIVERS WERE NOT EXITING THEIR
TRUCKS. BECAUSE WE WERE ALL
BEING TOLD THAT POTENTIAL THE
CALL DID WAS TRAVELING ON
PLASTICS AND CARDBOARD AND
PAPER. SO WE ARE WE WERE NOT
TOUCHING THAT MATERIAL AT ALL
AGAIN ONCE THE DEER WAS LIFTED
WE ARE NOW SORTING MATERIAL
AND- PEOPLE FEEL SAFER. A
SOCIAL DISAGREEMENT THE BIG
PART OF OUR BUSINESS R. THREE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE
CUSTOMERS TO COME TO THE BUY
BACK. WE HAD TO BUY A LOT OF-
E. P. FOR THOSE CUSTOMERS MANY
OF THEM ARE HOMELESS MANY OF
THEM COMING ON BICYCLES-
PUSHING SHOPPING CARTS AND THEY
DON'T HAVE THAT. WE HAD ONE
THAT. IN THAT AS WELL AS HAND
WASHING. WE ACTUALLY HAVE TO.
UPLOAD A PARTY ON THE PROPERTY
ONE OF FOUR OF THE TABLE PEOPLE
AND THEY'RE HEAVILY USED BY THE
GENERAL PUBLIC BECAUSE THEY'RE
HAVING TO WAIT IN LINE FOR SO
LONG. OUR DRIVERS- HAVE
PROTOCOLS WITH REGARD TO HOW
THE INTERFACE WITH THE
CUSTOMERS. AND HOW THEY OF TALK
WITH CUSTOMERS EVERYBODY'S WORK
VERY BASS BASS. AND DRIVERS
ALSO CARRY EXTRA FACEMASK IN
CASE RESIDENTS COME OUT THEY
WANT TO SPEAK TO THEM AND THEY
DON'T HAVE THE FACE MASK- WE
RUN ABOUT IT WELL WE RUN
FIFTEEN SEVEN TRUCKS SEVENTEEN
TRUCKS PER DAY. OUT OF OUR
OPERATIONS AND- I THINK THE
LAST THING I WANT TO SAY IN
CLOSING IS THAT I SAW IN THE-
REPERTORY MATERIALS. HE HE- AT
THIRTY NINE CENTS A POUND IF WE
COULD GET THIRTY NINE CENTS A
POUND WE COULD PROBABLY SURVIVE
AND CONTINUE DOING THE
RECYCLING OPERATION THE ONLY
THING THAT KEEPS US. GOING IN
THERE
VIDAK: MENTOR IS BE HANDLING
FEES THAT ARE PAID FOR US
THROUGH EVERY CONTAINER THAT WE
HAVE TO COME TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THE CURRENT CRISIS
SPURS PLASTIC SODA BOTTLES IT
IS SIX SEVEN A POUND IT GONNA
BLOW A. FOUR CENT A POUND. THE
CURRENT PRICE FOR CAN THAT WE
GET IS AROUND FIFTY CENTS POUND.
THE CARD PRICE FOR MAKES PAY
WHICH IS THE SIGNIFICANT OUR OF
OUR RESIDENTIAL MIXES TWENTY
FIVE DOLLARS A TONNE. AND THE
CURRENT PRICE FOR CARDBOARD IS
NINETY FIVE DOLLARS A TONNE.
ALL OF THAT MATERIAL PRETTY
MUCH IS SHIPPED OFF SHORE. WE
IMPORTED COMMITTEE TO OPPRESS
THE STATE GOVERNOR AND THE
LEGISLATURE TO PRESS THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. THE NEW
YORK NEWLY ELECTED PRESIDENT TO
SIGN ON TO THE BATTLE
CONVENTION THERE IS ONE HUNDRED
EIGHTY EIGHT COUNTRIES THAT ARE
PART OF THAT CONVENTION. WE
NEED TO BE A PART OF THAT
OTHERWISE POTENTIALLY ARE MIXED
PLASTICS WILL HAVE NOWHERE TO
GO. AND IT WILL BE REJECTED BY
THE SIGNATORIES OF THE BASIL
CONVENTION- THAT CONCLUDES MY
PRESENTATION THANK YOU SO MUCH.
OKAY THANK YOU A LOT OF FOOD
FOR THOUGHT HERE- WHO WOULD
LIKE TO BEGIN QUESTIONING. I'LL
START WITH- A START WITH WHAT
WILL GO TO THE TOP SO WE'LL GET
SUSAN ON THE- SUSAN COLLINS ON
THE SCREEN THAT WE CAN. ASK YOU
QUESTIONS WE CAN GO DOWN. SO
CAN WE GET. HOW CAN WE JUST ARE
STOCKING YEAH I WANTED TO TALK
TO YOU ABOUT- THE STATISTICS
YOU TALKED ABOUT ALUMINUM I
FOUND THAT VERY. VACILLATING
AND I HAVE KNOWN THAT FOR
EXAMPLE IN THE IN THE BEER
MARKET WHICH I I'M I'M A-
CONSUMER AND THEN NOT ASHAMED
OF THAT. I KNOW THAT FOR YEARS
A WOMAN IT WAS FROWNED UPON AND
IT WAS ALL ABOUT THE CLASS BUT
EVEN BEFORE- THAT WE SAW A SHIP
FILLED SPENT BY THE CRAP.
BREWERIES ARE GOING TO
ALUMINUM- FOR FRANKLY WAS IT
WAS CHEAPER- THERE CONSUMERS
DIDN'T MIND IT AND SO IT WAS
KIND OF A WIN WIN. SO I GUESS
THE QUESTION IS IF WE KNOW THAT
THAT THERE'S SOME- ITEMS WHICH
ARE ARE. HAVE MORE WORK IN THIS
KIND OF TALK ABOUT LAST SPEAKER
AS WELL MR BY A- SOME PRODUCTS
HAVE MORE OF A VALUE. IN IN THE
RECYCLING MARKET SHOULD SHOULD
CALIFORNIA BE DOING ANYTHING TO
PUT OUR THUMB ON THE SCALE TO.
AND YOU KNOW INCENTIVIZE FOR
EXAMPLE OBVIOUSLY BEER IS NOT.
PRODUCED IN PLASTIC BOTTLES.
BUT OTHER PRODUCTS ARE SO
SHOULD WE BE THINKING ABOUT-
INCENTIVIZING AN- YOU KNOW.
SETTING POLICY TO PUSH A
CERTAIN DIRECTION WHICH WE
KNOW. PRODUCTS HAVE HAVE MORE
UPSIDE OF BEING RECYCLED. WELL
AS GREAT QUESTION AND- I'LL
ADDRESS THE ALUMINUM SITUATION
A LITTLE BIT FIRST TO ADD A
LITTLE MORE TO THE CONTEXT YOU
WERE GIVING. AND AS YOU SAID
BOTTLES USED TO BE PREFERRED
ESPECIALLY BY CRAFT BREWERS.
AND- TWO THINGS HAVE HAPPENED
ONE THERE'S JUST BEEN A GRADUAL
ACCEPTANCE OF A HAT ALUMINUM
CANS BY THE CRAFT BEVERAGE
CONSUMER. BUT THEN IN ADDITION
TO THAT DAY HE HAD TO SCRAMBLE
SO MUCH TO CREATE A WAY TO AND
GET THEIR MARKET OUT INTO THE
MARKET PLACE. AND WITH THE
CORONA VIRUS PANDEMIC AND- DAY
STARTED USING CANS BECAUSE THAT
FEELING LINES ARE ESIER FOR
THEM TO INSTALL ON THE
FACILITIES SO IN ADDITION TO
THAT THERE'S A GREATER USE OF
ALUMINUM BECAUSE THAT HARD
SELTERS HAVE BECOME SO POPULAR
LIKE WHITE CLAW AND THOSE ARE
SOLD. IN ALUMINUM CANS SO THOSE
ARE THE THINGS THAT WE'RE
SEEING AS A PERMANENT OR SEMI
PERMANENT CHANGE- BUT IN TERMS
OF INCENTIVIZING- IT CREATING
INCENTIVES OR CREATING
PENALTIES THERE THERE. YOU KNOW
THE TWO SIDES OF THE COIN-
ABSOLUTELY WE CAN DO THAT AND
THAT IS DONE YEAH- WORLDWIDE.
THE TERM OF ART IS ECO
MODULATION FEES WE HAVE CERTAIN
FEES ALREADY THAT EXISTS IN THE
BEVERAGE CONTAINER PROGRAM IN
CALIFORNIA. AND ALL OF THE
MANUFACTURERS HAVE TO PAY FEES
INTO THE SYSTEM AND THAT HARDER
AND MORE EXPENSIVE MATERIALS TO
RECYCLE HAVE TO PAY MORE THAN
THE ONES THAT ARE IN THE
MATERIALS THAT ARE WORTH MORE
OR EASIER TO RECYCLE. M. BUT
WE'RE NOT DOING ENOUGH THERE-
THERE'S BEEN SOME REALLY RICH
CONVERSATIONS IN A STATE WIDE
RECYCLING COMMISSION ABOUT THE
NUANCES EVEN WITHIN P. ET
PLASTIC THERE'S GREEN PLASTIC
VERSUS CLEAR PLASTIC AND THOSE
ARE TWO COMPLETELY DIFFERENT
WORLDS- SO. WE CAN WE CAN
IDENTIFY WHERE THERE ARE
BARRIERS TO RECYCLING AND WE
CAN SET THE PENALTIES AND SAYS
HONEST TO GET THE RESULTS WE-
OKAY. YOU HAVE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS FOR THE SPEAKER.
MISTER CHANG. I JUST WANT TO GO
BACK TO YOUR CHART YOU HAVE
THAT- DIAGRAM SHOWING THE LOS
BETWEEN PTA GLASS AND THERE WAS
QUITE A BIG DIFFERENTIAL
BETWEEN PAINTING GLASS COULD
YOU- JUST WALK US THROUGH WHAT
THE DIFFERENCE. YOU MIGHT BE
I'M NOT SURE THERE'S TWO
DIFFERENT SIDES THAT COULD BE
IT COULD BE THAT I'M THE- SLIDE
NUMBER THREE THE CUMULATIVE
SHORTFALLS TO THE REDEMPTION
CENTERS. AND WHERE THERE IS
THERE ARE TWO LINES AND ONE OF
THEM WAS LABELED PT AND THE
OTHER ONE GLASS DOT ONE YEAH
AND- IF THAT'S THE CASE THAT
PARTICULAR CHART WAS ON THE
UNDERPAYMENTS TO THE REDEMPTION
CENTERS. AND MOST OF THE UNDER
PAYMENTS ARE A RESULT OF THE
GAP BETWEEN PT PRICES AND
EXPECTED PT PRICES- GLASSES A
MUCH SMALLER PLAYER AND THAT SO
THAT'S NOT THE RIGHT CHART I
CAN ANSWER THE QUESTION ON THE
CORRECT CHARTED A DOT THAT IS
RETURNS TO BE SO BASICALLY WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING IS. THAT IS IT
BECAUSE- GLASS IS A VERY SMALL
AMOUNT OF SO WE STREAM RELATIVE
TO PT. OR IS IT THAT. CLASS
PRICES. HAVE HELD UP RELATIVE
TO. THEIR THEIR THEIR RECYCLING
VALUE AND THEN INTO THE PT'S
PRICING HASN'T REALLY. HELD UP
WE HEARD SUPERVISOR- VALERIE
KIND OF TALK ABOUT IF THE PT
PRICES ACTUALLY WHAT. WAS NOTED
IN IN IN THE REPORT THAT THEY
IN FACT WOULD BE WOULD BE FINE.
THE ANSWER IS BOTH YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT ON BOTH
FRONTS- GLASS IS A SMALLER
PORTION THE NUMBER OF UNITS YOU
KNOW THE PERCENTAGE OF UNITS
THAT ARE GLASSES IS WELL UNDER
THIRD. PT IS THE DOMINANT
CATEGORY IN THE BEVERAGE
CONTAINER PROGRAM MORE THAN 50%
OF THE UNITS SOLD OR PT SO THAT
FIRST THING IS RIGHT THERE'S
MORE PT IN THE SYSTEM BUT THEN
THE P. ET PRICES ARE SO MUCH
HIGHER LIKE LAST CELLS FOR. IN
THE RANGE OF ZERO DOLLARS A TEN
TO TWENTY DOLLARS A TONNE
WORRIES PT IS IN THE HUNDREDS
OF DOLLARS PER TON. AND TO THE
DECLINES IN PT HAVE BEEN MORE-
MUCH MUCH GREATER PERCENTAGE
DECLINES IN THE PT PRICES SO
ALL OF THOSE THINGS THREE
THINGS MULTIPLIED TOGETHER
MEANS THAT PT HAS THIS REALLY
DOMINANT A FACT AND
UNDERPAYMENTS RELATED TO PT IS
REALLY THE DOMINANT EFFECT ON-
THE REDEMPTION CENTERS. GREAT
THANK YOU. OKAY THANK YOU- YES.
YEAH WE ONE SECOND I JUST
WANTED TO- I DID MAKE
ANNOUNCEMENTS EARLIER AND I'M
NOT SURE ALL THE PUBLIC WAS
HERE. WE DO HAVE- RULES FOR A
CLUB IN NINETEEN AND THIS
PANDEMIC OF ONE OF AND ONE OF
THEM IS YOU MUST WEAR A MASK AT
ALL TIMES AND SO. NOT CERTAIN
IF THE INDIVIDUAL- BUT DIDN'T
GET THAT MESSAGE OR- WASN'T
AWARE THAT BUT I WANTED TO MAKE
SURE THAT YOU KNOW WE- HAVE
ROLES HERE AND WE WANT TO OF
COURSE- FOLLOW THEM AND LEAD BY
EXAMPLE HERE IN OUR STATE
CAPITOL- SO WITH THAT WE HAVE
ASSEMBLY WOMAN- FRIEDMAN HAS A
QUESTION FOR THIS PANELISTS AND
THEN. SOME A MEMBER EGGMAN-
FROM HER DISTRICT ALSO WANTS TO
ENGAGE WITH SUSAN COLLINS THANK
YOU. HI THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY- I WAS ABLE TO
GO TO OREGON AND- OBSERVED
THERE. REALLY IMPRESSIVE BOTTLE
REDEMPTION PROGRAM WHICH IS YOU
KNOW- THAT'S PRETTY AMAZING AND
I COULD CERTAINLY SEE. HOW IT
WOULD BE VERY- HELPFUL AND
CONVENIENT TO CONSUMERS AND I
SAY THAT IS SOMEBODY THAT
LITERALLY HAS ABOUT EIGHT BOXES
BIG BOXES OF GLASS RIGHT NOW
SITTING ON MY PATIO EXCEPT TO
TRY TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO GET
IT. TO REDEMPTION CENTER
BECAUSE I KNOW IF I PUT MY
TRASH IT'LL TURN INTO
CONTAMINATION AND I WANT TO DO
THE RIGHT THING. SO I HAVE A
COUPLE QUESTIONS FIRST I WANTED
TO HEAR YOUR THOUGHTS ABOUT
THAT PARTICULAR PROGRAM WHAT DO
YOU THINK THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
WE SHOULD LOOK AT SERIOUSLY IN
CALIFORNIA OR JOINING THEIR
PROGRAM. AND SECONDLY I KNOW
THAT THE BOTTLE BILL IS VERY
COMPLICATED BUT IF THERE'S ANY
SIMPLE FIXES YOU YOU WOULD THAT
YOU SAVE YOURSELF GOSH THIS
WOULD BE SO EASY WHY DON'T THE
JUST DO THIS OR THAT. IF YOU
HAD ANY. THOUGHTS ABOUT YOU
KNOW. EASY FOR THINGS WE COULD
DO TO MAKE IT WORK BETTER
THAT'S MY FRIEND THAT I HAVE A
FEW OTHER QUESTIONS. GREAT SO A
GREAT QUESTION ABOUT OR AGAIN-
I CAN'T SAY ENOUGH GOOD THINGS
ABOUT THE PROGRAM IN OREGON. IT
IT OFFERS SO MANY CONVENIENCES
TO CONSUMERS THROUGH THE
VARIOUS WAYS THAT YOU CAN
RETURN CONTAINERS TO THE- TO
THE STORES OR THROUGH THEIR
BACKDROP PROGRAM. OR THROUGH
THE REDEMPTION CENTERS THAT
THEY'VE BUILT THEY'VE- DONE THE
RIGHT THING WITH INCREASING THE
DEPOSIT VALUE FROM FIVE CENTS
TO TEN CENTS. AND WHEN THEY DID
THAT THEIR REDEMPTION RATE
INCREASED FROM 64% 286% TO THE
SITE 22% INCREASE IN THE
RETENTION RATE. AND THAT'S IT
THAT'S A WORLD CLASS CONCEPT
THAT THEY'VE IMPLEMENTED- DO SO
THERE'S SO MANY THINGS ABOUT IT
THEY'VE ALSO EXPANDED TO
DIFFERENT MATERIAL TIRED. YES
DIFFERENT MATERIAL TYPES AND
IFFERENT COVERAGE TYPES. AND
THEY'RE DISCUSSING THE
POSSIBILITY OF EXPANDING ALSO
TO AND WINE AND SPIRITS
ESPECIALLY SINCE. I MENTIONED
THOSE HARD SELTZER CONTAINERS
DOES SEEM TO BE COMING THROUGH
OUR SYSTEMS ANYWAY- SO. OREGON
IS GREAT AND THERE'S A LOT TO
LEARN FROM IT IT'S AND IT'S ONE
OF AT LEAST THE TOP TWO
PROGRAMS IN THE UNITED STATES
IF NOT THE BEST ONE RIGHT NOW.
ON ON A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
LEVELS. AND I THINK I'VE GOT
MYSELF OFF TRACK- I KNOW THAT
THE SECOND QUESTION THAT YOU
ASKED WAS ABOUT AN EASY FIXES.
HI I'M AFRAID NOT AND IF THERE
WERE EASY FIXES THAT COULD HAVE
BEEN MADE TO THE CONTAINER
DEPOSIT LAW HERE IN CALIFORNIA
THEY PROBABLY ALREADY WOULD
HAVE AND SORRY TO BE YOU KNOW
TO GIVE A DISAPPOINTING ANSWER.
AND IT THE PROGRAM IT NEEDS
WHOLESALE CHANGES AND THERE ARE
A NUMBER OF THINGS THAT ARE
WRONG WITH THE PROGRAM THAT ARE
REALLY REALLY LARGE ISSUES THAT
REALLY NEED TO BE TACKLED
THAT'S GREAT THAT'S ACTUALLY A
VERY HOPEFUL RESPONSE AND IT IT
WILL HELP TO GUIDE. I THINK THE
WORK OF THE COMMITTEE AND HOW
WE LOOK AT VARIOUS OTHER PIECES
OF LEGISLATION. I'M SO. THIS
AGREES QUESTIONS I'M GONNA ASK
FOR ANYBODY WHO WANTS TO ANSWER
SO. IF YOU THINK THIS ISN'T THE
RIGHT QUESTION IF YOU JUST PASS
AND MAYBE SOMEONE ELSE. ON THE
PANEL WANT TO ANSWER IT. SO WE
DEFINITELY HAVE ISSUES WITH
CONTAMINATION IN THE WASTE
STREAM- AND- I'M WONDERING.
WHAT YOU THINK WE SHOULD BE
LOOKING AT TO REDUCE AT THAT
LEVEL OF CONTAMINATION- I KNOW
THAT YOU KNOW IT IT IS THAT IS
THE- PROBLEM REALLY. AT THE
BEEN LEVEL SHOULD WE BE GIVING
PEOPLE FOR BINS TO SORT THEIR
TRASH. OR SHOULD WE BE TRYING
TO FOCUS MORE ON REDUCING THE
DIFFERENT TYPES OF MATERIAL
THAT ARE IN THE RE STREAM. IF
YOU HAD YOUR DRUTHERS OR IS IT
BOTH- WHAT WHAT DO YOU THINK WE
SHOULD BE DOING ABOUT
CONTAMINATION. HOW DID YOU HEAR
THE QUESTION I WOULD BE THERE
ARE- I HEARD QUITE THIS IS
RICHARD FROM TRY SAID
RECYCLING. GREAT I CAN I FEEL
THAT QUESTION YES GO AHEAD-
THANK YOU THERE ARE IN ALAMEDA
COUNTY THERE ARE TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY EIGHT THOUSAND SCHOOL
CHILDREN K. THROUGH TWELVE. OUR
EXPERIENCE IN THE FIELD IS
THOSE ARE AMBASSADORS OF HOW TO
SAVE THE PLANET. IT WEEK DEAR
SOMETHING TOWARD OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND CAN SOMEHOW GET
INTO THE CLASSROOM THAT'S WHAT
WE'VE BEEN THE MOST SUCCESSFUL.
THE CHILDREN ARE THE ONES THAT
TEACH THE PARENTS HOW TO
RECYCLE THAT'S HOW WE STARTED
THE PROGRAM. IN THE TRI CITIES
FREMONT NEWARK UNION CITY AND
HAYWARD. INITIALLY MORE PICKED
UP RECYCLING BACK IN THE EIGHTY
THAT WAS THE MOST. INVASIVE WAY
TO GET INTO THE HOUSEHOLD- THE
CHILDREN AND I THINK WE'VE LOST
THAT CONTINUITY BECAUSE OUR
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND SO
INUNDATED WITH WORK OUR
TEACHERS ARE ALSO OVERWHELMED.
WITH DEMANDS ON TESTING BUT
THAT IS THE BEST METHODOLOGY
THAT WE'VE EXPERIENCED LET ME
SAY ONE MORE THING ON THE
DEPOSIT. FROM A NICKEL TO A
DIME. I AGREE WITH CALL. BUT
HERE A VERY- AT THE I. WE ARE
PAYING OUT ON AVERAGE- PR WEEK
FIVE DAYS A WEEK BASED ON
CURRENT MARKET PRICES. IN CASH
TO OUR CUSTOMER FLOW BECAUSE
WE'RE SO INUNDATED WITH
CUSTOMERS. IN EXCESS OF ONE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
WEEK IN CASH. AND THAT THAT
ABOUT FIVE CENTS PER CONTAINER.
IF WE DOUBLE THAT TO A DEADLINE
OUR CASH FLOW WILL HAVE TO GO
TO NEARLY TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS. PER WEEK. THERE IS A
PROBLEM WITH CAL RECYCLES
PAYMENT. WITH THE GUARDS WHO
ARE RECEIVING OUR HANDLING FEES
AND REIMBURSEMENTS. SO WE HAVE
TO VERY CAREFULLY DO THE
CALCULATION ABOUT WHO CAN
HANDLE THAT KIND OF CASH FLOW
THROUGH THE BUSINESS AGAIN STAY
IN BUSINESS. WE HAVE TO SOMEHOW
PROP UP THE BUSINESSES AND
WE'RE ASKING YOU TO RATE THE
REDEMPTION VALUE FROM THE
NICKEL TO A DIME. HOWEVER WE
FULLY SUPPORT. NOT ONLY
INCREASE UNIT TO A DYING BUT
ALSO INCREASING. IT AND WINE
BOTTLES. THANK YOU YOU
MENTIONED- CASH FLOW DOES
ANYBODY HAVE AN IDEA OF THE
AVERAGE. BUT COST TO RATEPAYERS
THE AVERAGE REPAIR PER WEEK
WHAT THEY'RE PAYING. IN FEES TO
MITIGATE PLASTIC POLLUTION ARE
BOTTLED RECYCLING AND
EVERYTHING ELSE. ANYONE WANT TO
GET ALMOST GIVING US. THIS IS
VERONICA PARDO THE RESEARCHER
CURRY COALITION YOU KNOW I'M I
THINK I WOULD DIRECT YOU TO A
COUPLE DIFFERENT REPORTS THAT
HAVE COME OUT- EVEN FROM CAL
RECYCLE THERE'S A RECENT REPORT
RIGHT NOW SYSTEM SB THIRTEEN
THE THREE IMPLEMENTATION BUT
MORE GENERALLY SPEAKING. THE
CONVERSATIONS THAT AS WE'VE
BEEN SAYING AND YOU'VE ALREADY
HEARD IS THAT WE ARE SEEING
CONTAMINATION INCREASE AT THE
RESIDENTIAL LEVEL BASED ON THE
GENERATION OF THIS MATERIAL
GOING INTO THE VAN AND YES WE
DO NEED TO EDUCATE AND
UNDERSTAND THAT THE MATERIALS
THAT ARE GOING INTO THE BLUE
BAND AND WE DO HAVE SOME
INCREDIBLE WORK HAPPENING RIGHT
NOW THE COMMISSION LEVEL. LARA
FOR ON TODAY- I BELIEVE IS ON
THE LINE AND IS SERVING AS A
COMMISSIONER WHAT IT AND SO IS
RICHARD BY ANY- ON THIS ON THIS
VERY WORKS ALERT IF YOU COULD.
PLEASE JUMP IN. YEAH YEAH
UNFORTUNATELY THIS WAR FRONT
AND FORTUNATELY I DON'T- HAVE
ANY INFORMATION FOR YOU AT THE
TIME ABOUT WHAT THE- COST IS TO
RATE PAYERS. ABOUT IT YOU KNOW
TO DEAL WITH PLASTIC POLLUTION-
YOU KNOW WE CAN TRY TO. FOLLOW
UP WITH OUR MEMBERS AND TRY TO
FIGURE THAT OUT I DID I'M SORRY
NICOLE. I WANT TO BURKE I WANT
TO CLARIFY I'M NOT TALKING
ABOUT PLASTIC POLLUTION. IN
TERMS OF PEOPLE BEING OUT.
HAVING TO PICK BACKS UP OFF THE
STREET. I'M TALKING ABOUT WHAT
ARE WE PAYING. APPROXIMATELY TO
DEAL WITH EITHER TRYING TO
RECYCLE PLASTIC OR DEAL WITH IN
OUR LANDFILL. IS THERE ANY WAY
TH. I GUESS IT WOULD BE YOU
KNOW IT'S GOING TO BE DIFFICULT
BUT IT SEEMS TO ME. THAT THE
SOMEHOW THE COST OF THIS
PARTICULAR PRODUCT AND IT IS A
PRODUCT THAT'S BEING SOLD. TO
CONSUMERS AND PUT INTO OUR
ENVIRONMENT. BUT THERE NEEDS TO
BE A WAY OF MONETIZING. THE
COST THAT RATE PAYERS. AND
TAXPAYERS ARE PAYING FOR THIS.
BECAUSE EVERY TIME. WE IN THE
LEGISLATURE. TRY TO PASS A BILL
DEALING WITH PLASTIC INCLUDING
LAST YEAR'S CIRCULAR ECONOMY
BILLS. SB FIFTY FOUR IN AB TEN
EIGHTY. WHAT WE HEAR BACK FROM
INDUSTRY AND FROM- THE CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE AND OTHERS IS ALL
ABOUT COST WHAT THIS WOULD COST
TO CONSUMERS. AND WE DON'T SEEM
TO HAVE READILY ANY DATA ON THE
OTHER SIDE TO SHOW. THE
FINANCIAL COST. OF DEALING WITH
THE POLLUTION YES BUT ALSO
WITH. JUST DISPOSING OF THE
MATERIAL. SO I DON'T EXPECT YOU
ALL TO ANSWER BUT I THINK THAT
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE START TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT THOSE COSTS ARE
TO EVERY SINGLE PERSON IN THE
STATE WHETHER THEY HAVE THE
ABILITY. TO PAY OR NOT WHETHER
THEY'RE PURCHASING PRODUCTS OR
NOT. BECAUSE THERE IS A
TREMENDOUS COST OF THE COST OF
THE CITIES AS WELL. YES I
COMPLETELY AGREE WITH YOU AND I
AND I DON'T HAVE A CONCRETE
NUMBER OUT BUT YOU KNOW WE HAVE
SEEN AN INCREASE IN RATES. I
KNOW WE TALKED EARLIER ABOUT-
THE CLOSURE OF MARKETS FOR
THREE THREE SEVEN PLASTICS
RIGHT THESE. THESE LOW GRADE
CLASS THAT THEY DON'T REALLY
HAVE- MUCH RECYCLING VALUE. WE
KNOW THAT WHEN THOSE MARKETS
CLOSED OFF RATE INCREASED FOR
CONSUMERS AND GENERATORS
RECYCLING- COSTS THAT SHOULD
SAY INCREASE. AROUND THE STATE
AS A RESULT OF THAT SO I THINK.
YOU KNOW THE ISSUE NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED FARTHER UPSTREAM
RIGHT WE DON'T THERE IS NO
MARKET THE THREE THREE SEVEN
CLASSICS WHY IS THAT- MAYBE WE
SHOULD FOCUS ON MOVING AWAY
FROM THOSE CLASSICS AND THAT IS
IN PART OF MONICA MENTIONED.
WHAT THE CONNECTION THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EGGMAN SET UP
TO THE BILL LAST YEAR IS
DEALING- AND THAT'S FROM THE
COMMISSION. IN THE RICHER BY A
IS ON THAT COMMISSION WITH
WHILE ALSO TRYING TO IDENTIFY.
WHAT THE MATERIAL WHAT PRODUCT
ARE TRULY RECYCLABLE WHAT'S
WHAT ARE ACTUALLY BEING
RECYCLED IN CALIFORNIA
STATEWIDE A LOT OF THAT IS
DEPENDENT ON- WHAT THE MARKETS
ARE. FOR THAT AND WHETHER THEY
CAN BE REUSED AND CAN BE
RECYCLED INTO NEW PRODUCT. AND
THEN TRYING TO SHIFT AWAY FROM
THOSE PRODUCTS THAT DON'T.
HAVE- TELL YOU. I KNOW THAT
YEAH KNOW THAT'S- AND ACTUALLY-
SAY THAT THERE IS A CORAL. WITH
THE WITH THE MATERIALS AND
COSTS FOR CONSUMERS IS. A
REALLY INTERESTING HERE AND
SOMETHING THAT I'D LOVE TO HEAR
MORE ABOUT AT SOME POINT. AND I
WILL GO BACK YOU YOU REFERRED
TO MS ADMINS COMMENTS US
SENATOR EGGMAN SOON TO BE
SENATOR EGGMAN COMMENTS. AND I
ABSOLUTELY AGREE WITH HER THIS
IS NOT ABOUT BLAMING-
INDIVIDUALS- REPAIRS CONSUMERS
IN FACT. I ACTUALLY THINK THAT
WE SPENT YEARS BLAMING THEM FOR
PLASTIC POLLUTION FOR. LACK OF
RECYCLING FOR CONTAMINATION NOW
AND NONE OF THAT'S THEIR FAULT
THEY'RE RECYCLING BECAUSE THEY
WANT TO DO THE RIGHT THING YOU
KNOW THE THAT THEY THROW
EVERYTHING IN THE BIN EVEN
THAT'S IF IT'S NOT RECYCLABLE
SPEECH SHOWS THAT THEY REALLY
WANT. TO BE GOOD STEWARDS AND
THEY WANT TO MAKE SURE THEY
WANT THESE PRODUCTS TO BE
RECYCLED. AND THE TRUTH IS
THERE NOT AND THE ONES WHO ARE.
PAYING THE BURDEN OF THAT ARE
THE EXACT SAME PEOPLE THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE TRYING TO DO
THE RIGHT THING. ARE PAYING
MORE THAN UTILITY BILL. THEY'RE
BEING BLAMED FOR PLASTIC
POLLUTION. AND I DON'T THINK
THAT IT'S AN ACCIDENT I THINK
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT THAT'S-
KIND OF BEEN DONE. OVER THE
YEARS SAID TO THEM. AND WE YOU
KNOW WE NEED TO BE THE ONES TO.
TO SORT OF STOP THAT AND
RECLAIM THAT AND PUT THE BURDEN
FINANCIAL BURDEN AND BLAME
BURDEN WHERE IT BELONGS WHICH
IS ON THE PLASTICS INDUSTRY IN
THESE MANUFACTURERS. NOW THAT'S
NOT TO SAY THAT A LOT OF THEM
AREN'T REALLY DOING THE RIGHT
THING AND I KNOW WE'RE GOING TO
HEAR FROM THE STRAWBERRY PEOPLE
A LITTLE LATER AND THEY'VE BEEN
DOING INCREDIBLE WORK AND
THERE'S A LOT OF COMPANIES THAT
ARE. TAKING SOURCE PRODUCTION
VERY SERIOUSLY AND WE SHOULD.
YOU KNOW IT KNOWLEDGE AND
CELEBRATE THAT TO ENCOURAGE
THEM- AND SUPPORT THEIR EFFORTS
TO SO. BUT I DO THINK THAT WE
NEED TO UNDERSTAND YOU KNOW
KIND OF AS A SOCIETY- WHAT THE
IMPACTS ARE WHICH IS WHY. WE'RE
HAVING THIS HEARING SO THANK
YOU MR MCCARTY. THANK YOU. I
KNOW THAT IT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
EGGMAN. REMOTELY WANT TO ASK A
QUESTION NOW AS WELL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND TO GO BACK TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY-
QUESTION. VERY SIMPLE CONCRETE
IF YOU'RE WORRIED CRAPPIE ARE
CONSUMER OF WHAT IS THE MOST
RESPONSIBLE WAY TO CONSUME HERE
RIGHT NOW IS A GLASS IS IT IS
IT I CAN. OR IS IT A CAKE. JUST
TO BE HELPFUL. M. AND MANY CAKE
WHICH SAM BREWERIES DO PROVE IT
PROVIDE AND I KNOW PEOPLE WHO
ALSO MAKE THEIR OWN BEER AND
ALL OF THOSE THINGS ARE WAYS TO
REDUCE AND THE USE OF
DISPOSABLE SINGLE USE.
PACKAGING. SO OKAY WRITER WITH
THE HYDRO FLASK. YEAH AND YOU
KNOW IT IT I'LL JUST GIVE A
COUPLE MORE EXAMPLES IN OUR OWN
HOME WE DON'T USE THEM BOTTLED
WATER AND I HAVEN'T USED
BOTTLED WATER FOR TEN YEARS NOW
AND I'VE BEEN JUST FINE. AND WE
HAVE A SODASTREAM MACHINE SO
THAT SPARKLING WATER WE CAN
MAKE THAT AT HOME AND WE CAN
FLAVORED OURSELVES AND WE CAN
BY- OUR MILK IN REFILLABLE
BOTTLES FROM STRAUS CREAMERY WE
TAKE THOSE BACK TO THE STORE
EVERY TIME WE GO SHOPPING SO
THERE'S A LOT OF WAYSTO AVOID.
AND SINGLE USE PACKAGING. THANK
YOU. OKAY HI I HAVE A QUESTION
I WANT TO ASK FOR RUNNING THEM
PART OF. WE OF COURSE COULD
HAVE ANOTHER HEARING TODAY ON
ORGANICS WHICH WE HAVE HAD WITH
THIS. SELECT COMMITTEE AND WITH
THE NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE
AS WELL I JUST IT IT WASN'T
REALLY TOUCHED ON TODAY BUT IT
YOU KNOW IT'S CERTAINLY AN
ISSUE THAT WE'RE INTERESTED IN
THIS ONE IF YOU CAN. EXPAND
UPON THAT HOW WE'RE DOING WITH
ORGANICS AND MORE AS FAR AND
MORE IN THE LAST YEAR WHAT'S
HAPPENED WITH OUR ORGANIC.
RECYCLING EFFORTS HERE
CALIFORNIA AND FOOD WASTE
PACIFIC LEE. AND- COBIT.
NINETEEN WELL THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY YEAH
AND AS I MENTIONED WE DID
PRODUCE A WHITE PAPER THAT HAVE-SOME OF THESE DETAILS AND MOST
OF IT IS DERIVED FROM THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD CAN RECYCL
ANOTHER AGENCY DOCUMENTS SO
THERE WAS A RECENT
INFRASTRUCTURE REPORT PROVIDED
BY CAL RECYCLE IT KIND OF GOES
INTO MORE DETAIL ABOUT SOME OF
THIS DEVELOPMENT BUT WELL YOU
ARE SEEING IS THE SLOW
DEVELOPMENT ON THE GROUND AND
SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT WE'RE
FACING THE REGULATORY ISSUES-
ARE ARE ARE VERY DIFFICULT WHEN
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT ESPECIALLY
IF YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT NON
ATTAINMENT AREAS IN CALIFORNIA.
WHERE WE HAVE TO MEET VERY
STRICT- EMISSION REQUIREMENTS
WHEN YOU'RE BUILDING EVEN A
COMPOST FACILITY YOU KNOW IT'S
VERY EASY FOR US TO THINK OF
COMPOST IS THIS WONDERFUL GREEN
INFRASTRUCTURE AND IT REALLY IS
BUT WITHOUT INFRASTRUCTURE
COMES ITS OWN EMISSIONS AND
ISSUES ANY TIME YOU'RE GOING TO
BUILD INFRASTRUCTURE NEW SOURCE
EMISSION CALIFORNIA YOU'RE
GONNA HAVE REGULATORY
LIMITATIONS AND ISSUES IN NOT
SO REALLY IT'S SLOW RIGHT NOW
IT'S SLOW AND THAT'S WHY WE'RE-
ASKING AND- ASKING YOU ALL TO
REALLY LOOK AT THIS FROM A
HOLISTIC PERSPECTIVE AND TO
UNDERSTAND THAT ESPECIALLY IN
THE REFUSE INDUSTRY. WE ARE
TRYING TO MANAGE THIS MATERIAL
THE ORGANIC WAY SO WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT IS FOR MORE AT IF
THE BEVERAGE CONTAINER WALL
VERY IMPORTANT PROGRAM IS A
MILLION TIMES A YEAR WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT TWENTY SIX TWENTY
SEVEN MILLION TONS OF ORGANIC
WASTE THAT IS EMITTING METHANE
IN OUR LANDFILLS THIS IS JUST A
HUGE ENORMOUS LEFT- THAT IS
REALLY IMPORTANT FOR CALIFORNIA
TO MEET OUR CLIMATE RDUCTION
GOALS SO I WISH I HAD MORE OF
YOU KNOW POSITIVE NEWS THAT. IN
BILL OF THE INFRASTRUCTURES
GETTING YOU KNOW GETTING OFF
THE GROUND BUT IT'S NOT AND OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE SUPPOSED TO BE
MEETING THESE OBLIGATIONS
JANUARY ONE TWENTY TWENTY TWO
MEANING ALL ORGANICS ARE
COLLECTED FROM BOTH.
RESIDENTIAL COMMERCIAL
GENERATORS. I HOPE THAT WAS
HELPFUL. YEAH SO IT IS A BE
LIKE WE'RE TALK ABOUT RECYCLING
WORSE. AND MY HOUSE AS WELL WE
ERR ON THE SIDE OF CAUTION BLUE
BAND AND IN OUR HEAD IT'S
RECYCLED SO. IN TWENTY TWENTY
TWO ARE GOING TO HAVE THE
ORGANICS BEEN FILLED UP AND
THEN NOT HAVE A PROPER PLACE
TO. DISPOSE OF IT. EXACTLY IS
VERY IMPORTANT THAT THAT
MATERIAL GO I MEAN WE USE A
SANITARY LANDFILL FOR A REASON
RIGHT I MEAN AND I UNDERSTAND
LANDFILLS WE DON'T WANT METHANE
EMITTING THAT WE HAVE THESE
LANDFILLS ARE MANAGEMENT. IT'S
HOW WE MANAGE THIS MATERIAL
RIGHT AND SO FOR GONNA MOVE IT
OUT OF THE LANDFILL- WE NEED TO
HAVE A PLACE TO PUT IT AND THAT
IS IT EITHER A COMPOST FACILITY
OR ANAEROBIC DIGESTION FACILITY
IF YOU WANT TO GET INTO MORE
FEEDSTOCKS WE CAN TALK ABOUT
THAT. IT GOES TO CHIP AND
GRINDIN BIOMASS AND ANIMAL FEED
AND ALL KINDS OF DIFFERENT
APPLICATIONS BUT THE PRIMARY
MECHANISMS ARE COMPOSTING
ANAEROBIC DIGESTION. AND
COMPOSTING OBVIOUSLY IS MORE
YOU KIND OF THINK ABOUT MORE IN
THE AGRICULTURAL AREAS RIGHT-
OPEN WIND ROSE AS YOU START TO
GET URBAN ENVIRONMENTS AGAIN
WITH THE EMISSION ISSUES YOU'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO DO MORE-
ENCLOSED INFRASTRUCTURE. THE
ADVANTAGE MOST ADVANCED BEST IN
CLASS TECHNOLOGY WHICH REALLY
DOES COST MORE THIS IS NOT JUST
YOU KNOW PUTTING SOME ORGANIC
MATERIAL IN IN A WHOLE AND
HOPING IT ALL GOES WELL THESE
ARE REALLY JUST ADVANCED
TECHNOLOGIES TO MANAGE AS
MATERIAL PRODUCES REALLY.
IMPORTANT COMPOST OR IN THE
CASE OF BIOGAS AAEROBIC
DIGESTION WHICH IS MORE
EXPENSIVE THAN COMPOST- AND SO
WE DO NEED TO MAKE THOSE
INVESTMENTS IN THOSE INITIAL
CRITICAL INVESTMENTS. THAT ARE
GOING TO PLAY OUT OVER THE LONG
TERM. OKAY THANK YOU ANY.
QUESTIONS FOR THESE. I DID ALSO
WANT TO RECOGNIZE THAT RICHARD
BY EIGHT NOT ONLY IS WITH THE-
THE TRICE CD TRY SAID COMMUNITY
RECYCLING BUT IS AN ELECTED
OFFICIAL LIKE LIKE US
APPEARANCE COUNTY SUPERVISOR IN
ALAMEDA COUNTY SO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PUBLIC SERVICE MR BY ANY-
WITH THAT WE WILL NOW PROCEED
TO THE THIRD PANEL. AS FAR AS
IMPACTS ON MARKETS AND WE WILL
START WITH PETER KELLER VICE
PRESIDENT RECYCLING AND
SUSTAINABILITY AT REPUBLIC
SERVICES. OKAY MISTER KELLER IS
IN THE AUDIENCE TODAY. COME ON
UP. CERTAINLY WE SEE REPUBLIC
HELLO ALL AROUND OUR
COMMUNITIES HERE AND SACRAMENTO
COUNTY AS WELL. GREAT- SHARES
MCCARTY- FRIEDMAN SOME OF OUR
MEMBERS THINGS- EGGMAN GARCIA
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BE HERE TODAY- JUST STEP BY WAY
OF BACKGROUND REPUBLIC SERVICES
HAS SEVENTY NINE RECYCLING
FACILITIES IN THE US WE HAVE
SIX IN CALIFORNIA- WE HAVE
THIRTEEN COMPOST FACILITIES SIX
OF WHICH ARE IN CALIFORNIA. AND
WE HAVE TO FOOD WASTE PRE
PROCESSING FACILITIES BOTH OF
WHICH ARE IN CALIFORNIA SO A
LITTLE BIT OF THE LAY OF THE
LAND RELATIVE TO OUR RECYCLING-
ASSETS I THOUGHT TODAY I WOULD
JUST COVER ALL HIGH LEVEL- SOME
COVERT RELATED IMPACTS AND
THAT'S REALLY WHAT WE'RE HERE
TO DAY TO TALK ABOUT- GIVE YOU
SOME INSIGHTS ON OPERATIONAL
BEST PRACTICES- TALK A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT NEAR TERM OUTLOOK-
AND THEN- SOME CALIFORNIA
SPECIFIC. CONSIDERATIONS
CRISTINA SLIDE. SO WHAT'S GOING
ON IN THIS LINE. THERE'S LOTS
GOING ON IN TWENTY TWENTY SO
RELATIVE TO- THE PANDEMIC YOU
KNOW OBVIOUSLY IN Q. ONE WE
WERE HIGHLY FOCUSED ON
LOCKDOWNS- WHAT THAT MEANT FOR
A BUSINESS WHAT THAT WHAT THAT
MEANT FOR OUR ASSETS WITH THAT
MEANT FOR OUR PEOPLE. AS WE
MOVED INTO Q. TWO WE WERE HYPER
FOCUSED ON OUR EMPLOYEES
SAFETY- MAKING SURE THAT WE
WERE DOING THINGS WITH OUR
ASSETS TO PROTECT OUR
EMPLOYEES- YOU KNOW AS A
RELATED TO CHECK IN CHECK OUT
I'M JUST STRETCHING OUT SHIP
STRETCHING OUT BREAK AREAS. HI
AND THE LIKE AND THEN OBVIOUSLY
IN Q. TWO AND I'LL SHARE THIS
WITH THE- IN A IN AN UPCOMING
SLIDE BIG CHANGES IN COMMERCIAL
TO RESIDENTIAL VOLUMES BIG
CHANGES AND MAX- AS WE MOVED IN
THE Q. THREE YOU KNOW TRYING TO
DEAL WITH RE OPENING AND WHAT
THAT MEANT FOR A BUSINESS. HAS
CERTAIN AREAS OF THE COUNTRY-
BEGAN RE OPEN AND- HEARING
QUEUE FOR YOU KNOW SURGING CASE
COUNTS CONTINUATION OF WORK
FROM HOME CONTINUATION OF
REMOTE LEARNING SO JUST TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT WHAT THAT LOOKS
LIKE FOR THE REST OF THIS YEAR
GOING INTO NEXT YEAR. ON THE
RECYCLING SIDE YOU KNOW
CONTINUE TO TRACK INVESTMENTS-
IN DOMESTIC RECYCLING CAPACITY
WE'VE HEARD SOME PEOPLE TALK
ABOUT THAT ALREADY THIS MORNING
THAT INVESTMENTS OCCURRING HERE
IN THE US WHICH. IS A GREAT
THING- YOU. AGAIN DEALING WITH
THAT BIG. RESIDENTIAL
COMMERCIAL VOLUMES- INCREASE WE
SAW INCREASED DEMAND- FOR
CERTAIN GRADES OF MATERIALS AND
I CAN. I CAN SHARE THAT- DETAIL
WITH YOU A LITTLE BIT LATER-
AND THEN YOU KNOW AGAIN MIXED
SIGNALS ARE GOING INTO NEXT
YEAR SO. FIGURING OUT HOW TO
MANAGE- THE BUSINESS- IN THE
FACE OF UNCERTAINTY.
CHRISTENING SO JUST A FEW
EXAMPLES OF BEST PRACTICES- YOU
CAN SEE A PHYSICAL BARRIER
THERE TO THE LEFT- THAT'S
PRETTY TYPICAL OF WHAT WE DID.
IN THE EARLY DAYS AT ALL OF OUR
RECYCLING FACILITIES- WEATHER'S
PLEXIGLASS PLEXIGLASS. I SHOWER
CURTAINS OR OTHER TYPES OF
PHYSICAL BARRIERS WHERE WE
COULD NOT MAINTAIN A SIX FOOT
SEPARATION. AND THEN IN THIS-
IN THE RECYCLING LINE OF
BUSINESS YOU KNOW GENERALLY WE
WILL TAKE BREAKS ALL SAME TIME-
IT'S NOT UNCOMMON TO HAVE
THIRTY FORTY FIFTY PEOPLE
WORKING ON ONE OF THESE
LOCATIONS ON A SINGLE SHIFT. SO
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE CAN
CREATE SOME ADDITIONAL SPACE
FOR OUR EMPLOYEES- THE TENT ON
THE RIGHT IS AN EXAMPLE OF THAT.
MAX ON. SO JUST A SIMPLE
GRAPHIC- BIG BIG SWINGS IN
VOLUME- ADDITIONALLY- COMING
OUT LATE MARCH AND EARLY APRIL
AGAIN THIS IS NATIONWIDE SAW AS
MUCH AS A 30% DECREASE I IN OUR
COMMERCIAL LINES AND A
COMMERCIAL BUSINESS AND WE SAW
AS MUCH AS A 25230% INCREASE IN
RESIDENTIAL BY HIM. AND YOU
KNOW SOME DISCUSSION ABOUT HOW
CONTRACTS ARE. CONSTRUCTED-
MOST COMMERCIAL RATEPAYERS PAY
BY THE YARD WHERE THEY PAY BY
THE SERVICE- YOU KNOW WHETHER
IT'S THREE TIMES A WEEK- EVERY
DAY MOST ALMOST PAY BY THE
MONTH SO AS- VOLUMES SHIPPED.
BY AND AS WE KIND OF APPROACH
SOME NEW NORMAL- CONTINUATION
OF WORK FROM HOME. THEY WILL
PUT ADDITIONAL PRESSURE OVER
TIME ON ON THOSE HOMEOWNER
RATES. I'M EXCITED. SO JUST A
LITTLE BETTER TREND ANALYSIS
HERE- THE GRAPHIC TO THE UPPER
RIGHT IS RESIDENTIAL VOLUMES
AGAIN YOU CAN SEE THAT PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT UPTICK- MARCH AND
APRIL OFF OF THE BASELINE-
WE'VE SEEN THAT TREND DOWN AND
THAT'S THE BLUE LINE- THE L.
THE YELLOW LINE IS KIND OF OUR
FORWARD LOOKING- PROJECTION
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO SEE-
FLEXIBLE WORK SCHEDULES REMOTE
LEARNING WORK FROM HOME- SOME
OF THAT WILL NEVER GET BACK TO
NORMAL. ARE CONVERSELY ON THE
COMMERCIAL SIDE- STEEP DECLINE-
AND AGAIN YOU SEE A TAIL OUT IN
TWO TWENTY TWENTY ONE SOME OF
THE SOME OF THE INDUSTRY THAT
WE THINK WILL COME BACK THE
SLOWEST. OBVIOUSLY HOSPITALITY-
LEISURE- THOSE TYPES OF SPACES
SO. OUR NEXT LOVE. SOME PRETTY
BIG SHIFTS ARE IN MATERIAL MIX-
SO YOU KNOW I MENTION THE
VOLUME SHIFTING FROM COMMERCIAL
OVER TO RESIDENTIAL BUT YOU
THINK ABOUT AT HOME CONSUMPTIVE
BEHAVIOR- BIG INCREASE IN SMALL
CARDBOARD BOXES- IN THE
RESIDENTIAL STREAM WE CALL THAT
THE AMAZON EFFECT- BUT DON'T
WANT TO EXCLUDE OTHER
E-COMMERCE. WORSE IN RECORD
AMOUNTS OF PT ALUMINUM AND
GLASS- THAT'S ALL THAT THAT
HOME CONSUMPTION. THAT OTHERS
HAVE ALREADY TALKED ABOUT- ON
THE COMMERCIAL SIDE. BIG DROP
OFF IN THAT LARGE CARDBOARD
THAT WE'VE BEEN ACCUSTOMED TO-
RETAIL DISTRIBUTION WAREHOUSING-
AND OBVIOUSLY- NOT ALL
COMMERCIAL SECTORS HAVE BEEN
HURT THE SAME SO GROCERY AND
BIG BOX HOME IMPROVEMENT
ACTUALLY I'VE HAD A REALLY GOOD
YEAR DURING THE PANDEMIC SO-
MOST OF OUR COMMERCIAL LINES
OFF- SOME OF ITS UP. IN AN
INDUSTRIAL WHICH THE MOST OF
YOU WOULD CALL ROLL OFF- MOST
OF THE PERMANENT BUSINESS WAS
NOT IMPACTED- IN STATES
INCLUDING CALIFORNIA THAT
CLOSED DOWN CONSTRUCTION.
OBVIOUSLY THOSE ROLL OFF
CONTAINERS- IN THE EARLY DAYS
WERE IMPACTED PRETTY
SIGNIFICANTLY. BUT WE'VE SEEN
MOST OF THAT ACTIVITY COME BACK.
AN EXCELLENT. SO A LOT OF
DETAIL HERE- WE'VE ALREADY HAD
SOME DISCUSSION ABOUT CHINA-
HISTORICALLY- CHINA IMPORTED
ABOUT TWENTY MILLION TONNES OF
MATERIAL MOST THAT'S FIBER
BASED OR OR PAPER BASED- FROM
NORTH AMERICA- HERE- AT THE
BEGINNING OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE
WE FULLY EXPECT THEM TO STEP
OUT OF THE MARKET- THERE'S
INVESTMENT OCCURRING IN THE U.
S. THE MAP THERE AS- AN EXAMPLE
OF LARGE. PAPER MILL
INVESTMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN
ANNOUNCED BUT AS YOU CAN SEE BY
WHERE THOSE OBJECTIVES
GEOGRAPHICALLY LOCATED THEY'RE
GOING TO BE A CHALLENGE FOR
CALIFORNIA TO PARTICIPATE IN
THOSE NEW PROJECTS. SOME DATA
HERE ON COMMODITY VALUES- I
JUST WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THE
IMPORTANCE OF CRB CURBSIDE
PAYMENTS- YOU CAN SEE AND Q.
ONE. AS A COMPANY OUR COMMODITY
VALUES WERE EIGHTY SIX DOLLARS-
CALIFORNIA SITES ONE HUNDRED
THIRTY SEVEN- IN AND YEAR TO
DATE NINETY EIGHT AND THAT'S
INDICATIVE OF AN IMPROVING
COMMODITY MARKET- THROUGHOUT
THE YEAR. IN THE CALIFORNIA
SIDE SOARED HIGH FIFTY TWO SO-
ABOUT A 55260% PREMIUM- FOR
COMMODITIES- IN THE US. THE
DATA THE YEAR OVER YEAR BEHIND
IT OVER TO THE RIGHT- ARE
RECYCLING IN DOWNTOWNS ARE DOWN
SIX AND A HALF PERCENT. BUT ROC
SEIZE UP FIFTEEN. OUR PAPERS
DOWN ALMOST FORTY. THAT'S ALL
THAT OFFICE PAPER IT'S ALL IT'S
ALL. BLACKMAILERS NOT BRICK AND
MORTAR NOT SENDING. OUR
CATALOGS THIS YEAR. MAYBE A
LITTLE BIT SHOWN UP NOW BUT
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR A LOT LESS
MAILERS. A LITTLE BIT OF AN
ANOMALY FOR US BUT I'M
CERTAINLY FROM WHAT WE JUST
HEARD FROM. FROM SOME OTHERS
BUT- OUR ALUMINUM IS
ESSENTIALLY FLAT. YEAR OVER
YEAR. BUT OUR P. EATING GLASS
WROTE 25% ALL RIGHT AND THEN
LASTLY- RECYCLES THEY WAS THIS
PAST WEEKEND I WE DID A SURVEY
AND- NINE MAJOR CITIES LA WAS
ONE OF THEM. ABOUT YOU CAN SEE
HERE. SOME OF THE OPPORTUNITIES
AND SOME FOLKS OF ALL THE
MENTIONED. THESE THEMES TODAY-
LACK OF SPACE- CONFUSION ON
WHAT CAN BE RECYCLED I AM AND
THE CONFIDENCE YOU KNOW FOLKS
NOT BELIEVING THAT THEIR
RECYCLABLES ARE ACTUALLY
GETTING RECYCLED SO YOU KNOW
YOU SHOULDN'T TAKE OUR SURVEY
IS THE END ALL BE ALL BUT- WHAT
ARE SOME OF THE THINGS THAT YOU
ALL COULD DO FROM A PUBLIC
POLICY STANDPOINT. A MINIMUM
CONTENT THIS IS HUGELY
IMPORTANT SO SOME DISCUSSION
TODAY ON THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BY TEN UP WE SHOULD YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THAT LAST YEAR-
HARMONIZED LIST OF ACCEPTABLE
RECYCLABLES- I KNOW THERE'S A
COMMISSION WORKING ON THAT. HI
AS WE SPEAK SO THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT AND THEN.
A FOCUS ON ANY MARKET
INFRASTRUCTURE. THOSE ARE THE
THREE PRIMARY THINGS THAT. TO
REALLY DRIVE SUCCESS AND
RECYCLE MORE. SO THAT WAS THE
END MY PRESENTATION OF THE
GROUND FOR QUESTIONS. OKAY
THANK YOU VERY FIRST YOU CAN
YOU CAN STAY RIGHT THERE FOR A
SECOND MISTER KELLER ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TANK. THANKS SO MUCH
JUST QUICK QUESTIONS I KNOW
THAT ARMY. WE GET A RENEWED OUR
CASE TO PROGRAM WHICH IS-
INCENTIVE PROGRAM FOR COMPANIES
TO INVEST IN YOU KNOW GREEN
TECHNOLOGY- MY UNDERSTANDING IS
DIFFERENT BASED COMPANIES WERE
USING THOSE- USING THAT PROGRAM
I JUST WONDERING IF FOR PUBLIC
WAS- LOOKING AT THAT PROGRAM TO
DO INVESTMENTS IN CALIFORNIA.
CAN YOU REPEAT WHAT THE NAME OF
THE PROGRAM IT'S TO KEEP TE
PROGRAM IT'S LIKE A- TAX CREDIT
PROGRAM AND OF THE TREASURE'S
OFFICE I'M I'M FAMILIAR WITH IT
OKAY YEAH BECAUSE YOU'RE
BECAUSE YOU'RE A LOT WHEN WE
WERE IN RENEWING IT YOUR
LOBBYIST CAME TO MY OFFICE AND
SPECIFICALLY- TALKED ABOUT.
SOME OF THE DIFFERENT
IMPROVEMENTS YOU WERE- DOING AT
FACILITIES ALL AROUND THE STATE
AND I GUESS MY QUESTION IS- YOU
KNOW MY COMMENT BACK THEN WAS
JUST TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE
INVESTMENTS WERE ACTUALLY
OCCURRING. IN THAT OBVIOUSLY
THEY KNEW THEY WERE GOING TO
ASK HER ONLY IF WE BRING YOU
KNOW WE'RE RENEWING OR
INCREASING THE SCOPE OF THE
PROGRAM. I CAN TELL YOU- THAT
WE CONTINUE TO MAKE INVESTMENTS
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. AND TO THE
EXTENT SOME OF THOSE PROGRAMS
ARE AVAILABLE WE'LL LOOK INTO
THOSE. CAN YOU MAYBE MAYBE YOU
COULD EXPAND ON WHAT INVESTMENT
YOU'RE MAKING IN CALIFORNIA-
CERTAINLY ARE FOCUSED ON
ORGANICS INVESTMENTS. SO
EXPANDING- SOME COMPOST
CAPABILITIES CAPACITY- IN SO
CAL- AGAIN UP HERE- WELL IN THE
BAY AREA. EXPANDING OUR FOOD
WASTE CAPABILITIES- PLAN ON
MAKING A SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT
AND- RECYCLING- PROCESSING
CAPACITY- IN THE BAY AREA NEXT
YEAR AS WELL. PERFECT THANK YOU.
BUT I HAVE A QUESTION FOR YOU
WHILE YOU'RE UP THERE AT YOU
KNOW THAT THE TRENDS IN THE
LAST NINE MONTHS AT FRANKLY
INTERESTING BUT ALSO
FASCINATING TO PROMOTE YOU KNOW
SOCIOLOGY PERSPECTIVE WHAT
PEOPLE ARE HAVING TO DEAL WITH.
JUST WONDERING OVERALL
CERTAINLY HAVE HAD INCREASES IN
SOME AND DECREASES IN OTHERS
OVERALL HOW IS THAT IMPACTED
YOU KNOW THE FINANCIAL
STABILITY OF REPUBLICAN AT SOME
OF THE OTHER LARGE WASTE
HAULERS IN CALIFORNIA WELL
COMING INTO THIS YEAR- SOME OF
THE COMMODITY VALUES WERE AT
HISTORIC LOWS- AND WE SAW THAT
TREND CONTINUE INTO Q. ONE- PRE
YOU KNOW PRE COVERT PRE
LOCKDOWNS- SOME SOME
CONSTRAINTS ON. ON THE
COMMODITY MARKETS- SINCE SINCE
THE PANDEMIC- YEAH THE
VALUATION HAS IMPROVED- AND
WHILE WE'RE GETTING LESS
INBOUND VOLUME- THE OVERALL-
ECONOMICS OF RECYCLING HAVE
IMPROVED- IN TWENTY TWENTY- YOU
KNOW I GUESS I WOULD SHARE THIS
IN THIS MIGHT BE A SHOCK TO
SOME FOLKS IN THE ROOM BUT- YOU
KNOW THE MAJORITY OF. CURBSIDE
RECYCLING IN THE U. **** FIBER
BASED SO POSSIBLY 75% OF WHAT
WE MAKE AND SELL THIS CARDBOARD
MIXED PAPER OTHER FORMS OF
FIBER BASED PACKAGING. A LOT OF
TALK THIS MORNING ABOUT PLASTIC
PLASTIC IS ABOUT 8% OF WHAT WE
RECEIVE IN WHAT WE SELL. FIVE
SIX REPRESENTS ABOUT 40% OF OUR
COMMODITY VALUES. SO IT'S YOU
KNOW. IT'S DISPROPORTIONATELY
VALUABLE AND WE'RE TRYING TO
FIGURE UT HOW TO GET MORE OF
THAT RATHER THAN LESS ABOUT SO-
OVERALL TO ANSWER THE QUESTION-
OVERALL THE CHANGES IN VOLUME
AND MIX. HAVE BEEN HELPFUL THIS
YEAR. OKAY THANK YOU. OKAY
LET'S GO ON TO OUR NEXT SPEAKER
THAT'S CHASING YOUNG CEO OF
ALLEN COMPANY. PLEASE HOLD ON
FOR. WELL IN COMPANY- AND IT'S
GOING TO BE A QUICK
INTRODUCTION ALLEN COMPANY IS-
HAS BEEN IN THE RECYCLING
BUSINESS SINCE NINETEEN SIXTY
THREE WE OPERATE FACILITIES
BETWEEN FRESNO AND SAN DIEGO
ELEVEN OF THEM. WE HAVE- WE DO
CRV BY BACK CRV PROCESSING
CURBSIDE PROCESSING TRANSFER
STATION- WE ARE ALSO COMMERCIAL
RECYCLERS INDUSTRIAL RECYCLERS-
WE HANDLE SCRAP METAL PAPER
PLASTIC GLASS. OUR ALSO DIRECT
OVERSEAS EXPORTERS AND HAVE
BEEN FOR THE PAST FORTY FIVE
YEARS. I WANT TO TALK A LITTLE
BIT OF I'M I'M GOING TO DIVE
INTO THE MARKETS A LITTLE. MORE
IN DEPTH YOU KNOW. THE MARKETS
ARE STILL SUPPLY SUPPLY AND
DEMAND BASED MARKET. SO THERE'S
DIFFERENT IMPACTS ON ALL THE
COMMODITIES BASED ON CODE SO IF
YOU HAVE. SUPPLY BASE YOU HAVE
THE OF. YOU KNOW OR YOU HAVE
EXTRA DEMAND OR LACK OF SUPPLY
WHICH IS CAUSING- YOU KNOW ON
THE MARKET TO CHANGE. THE PAPER
MARKETS FOR INSTANCE- THEY
SPIKED CORRUGATED SIR OCC
SPIKED IN THE FIRST TWO MONTHS
OF- THE PANDEMIC FOR THREE
MONTHS OF THE PANDEMIC-
PRIMARILY BECAUSE THE ESSENTIAL
BUSINESSES DONATED BOXES TO
SHIP THEIR GOODS. BUT THEY DID
NOT HAVE THE OF. BUT THERE WAS
NO SUPPLY BECAUSE THE
COMMERCIAL BUSINESSES WERE ALL
SHATTERED. FOR THE STAY HOME
ORDERS WHICH BECAUSE THE
BECAUSE THE A LACK OF SUPPLY
INCREASE IN PRICING. SAME THING
FOR THE TISSUE BUSINESS THE
TISSUE BUSINESSES YOU KNOW IT
IT IS PRIMARILY RECYCLED OR
MADE OUT OF RECYCLED PAPER.
WHEN THEY SHUT DOWN THE OFFICES
THERE WASN'T ANY SUPPLY RECYCLE
PAPER BECAUSE THE PRICING TO GO
UP. ALLEN TISSUE CAUGHT UP TO
ITSELF THE PRICING CAME BACK
TO. THE PLASTIC MARKET FELL
DRAMATICALLY IN THE. IN THE
FIRST FOUR MONTHS OF THE
PANDEMIC. OVER 40% FOR PT WHICH
IS THE BIGGEST COMMODITY THAT
WE HANDLE- AND THE MAIN REASON
IT FAILS BECAUSE OF THE LOW OIL
PRICE. THE OIL PRICE YOU KNOW
WHEN OIL GETS TO BE A NEGATIVE
PRICE WAS FOR A HALF A DAY OR A
DAY IT. WAS TRADING AT A
NEGATIVE. AT YOU CAN JUST SEE
THAT THE THAT'S THE SUBSTITUTE
FOR RECYCLE PLASTIC IS THE
VIRGIN PLASTIC SO- SO IT
BECAUSE THE PLASTIC MARKETS TO
CRATER. THEY HAVE RECOVERED
SOME SENSE IN THE LAST MONTH OR
TWO MOST OF THAT RECOVERY- IN
MY ESTIMATION IS DUE TO THE- IS
DUE TO THE- MINIMUM CONTENT.
THAT WAS PASSED BY THE
LEGISLATION THAT WAS PASSED
THAT HAD A POSITIVE IMPACT ON
THE MARKETS. FROM THE CLASS
PRICES REMAINED UNCHANGED AND
IT LARGELY REMAINS UNCHANGED
YEAR OVER YEAR- HAVE THE MAIN
REASON IT NEVER REALLY CHANGES
IS BECAUSE IT'S- IT'S- VIRGIN
SUBSTITUTE IS- SAND. WHICH
DOESN'T HAVE VERY MUCH VALUE SO-
THE VOLUMES FOR GLASS WERE OFF
VOTE AROUND 5% AND THAT'S
PRIMARILY WITH THE RESTAURANTS
AND BARS BEING CLOSE. ALUMINUM
FELL. FOR THE FIRST THREE
MONTHS OF THE PANDEMIC- IT WAS
MORE OF A- NATION WIDE FALLING
ALUMINUM THERE WAS A SHORTAGE
AND ALUMINUM CANS BUT THERE WAS
A NATIONWIDE FALLING ALUMINUM
PRICING PRIMARILY TO THE AUTO
INDUSTRY SLOWING DOWN THEY
CONSUME A LOT OF RECYCLING.
AND- IT HAS RECOVERED SOME. IN
THE LAST TWO OR THREE MONTHS SO
IT'S KID LOOKS LIKE IT'S
CONTINUING TO RECOVER. I'M I
WANTED TO DELVE INTO THE EXPORT
MARKETS JUST A LITTLE BIT I
KNOW THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF TALK
ABOUT HIM- AND THERE'S BEEN A
LOT OF CHANGES IN THE EXPORT
MARKET OVER THE PAST. YOU KNOW.
YOU'RE ALREADY KNOWS ABOUT
CHINA SHUTTING OFF RECYCLABLES.
THAT'S A HUGE HUGE MARKET FOR
US AND- A LOT OF THE OTHER
FOREIGN MARKETS HAVE PICKED UP
VOLUME AND CREATED PROCESSING
TO HELP. CONSUME THE PRODUCT
THAT WOULD GO TO CHINA FOR THE
FINISHED PRODUCT SO. THEY'RE
MAKING THE BOXES IS STILL THERE
JUST BEING MADE A DIFFERENT
COUNTRY- AS YOU GO COUNTRY BY
COUNTRY YOU KNOW KOREA HAD
MAJOR IMPACTS YOU KNOW THEY HAD
A LOCKDOWN FROM MARCH THROUGH
JUNE. BECAUSE HUGE SUPPLY
DEMAND SWINGS AND- DIFFICULT
FOR THEM- THEY WERE AT IT
BECAUSE PART OF THE SPIKE IN-
OCC PRICE WAS DUE TO THAT. IN
CHINA OF COURSE THEY SHUT
OFFERS. BUT THEY ARE HAD WHAT
DOWN ORDER. INDIA AXE CLOSE
REPORT FOR FORTY FIVE DAYS.
BECAUSE OF PANDEMIC. THEY
DIDN'T HAVE ANY X. RAM FOR
FIVE. V. SHUT DOWN THERE.
BECAUSE THE TOO MUCH OF ALL
COMING IN THE COUNTRY WEREN'T
ABLE TO HANDLE THE VOLUME-
THAILAND. SURPRISINGLY
INCREASED CONSUMPTION AND IS
PUTTING CAPACITY TO HELP- OVER
THE LOSS IN CHINA- INDONESIA
HAD STRICT LOCKDOWN- ORDERS AND
THEY HAD A FREEZE ON IMPORTS
FOR ABOUT FORTY DAYS- SO THE
EACH MARKET IS INDIVIDUAL AND
THE COMMODITIES THAT WE THE
OWNER ARE TRADED WORLDWIDE. AND
I JUST WANTED YOU KNOW IMPOSE
ON YOU THAT IT'S THAT YOU KNOW
CALIFORNIA CAN DO SOME THINGS
TO HELP THE MARKETS BUT-
THEY'RE ALSO THERE'S A
WORLDWIDE FACTORS THAT
CALIFORNIA CAN'T REALLY- IT'LL
CHANGE- THE LAST THING I WANTED
TO TOUCH ON IS- THE PORTS IN
CALIFORNIA. THERE'S A BIG
CONGESTION AT THE PORTS THE
LAST TWO MONTHS AS THE ECONOMY
HAS STARTED O RECOVER. AND
IMPORTS OF STARTED TO SURGE
THERE'S A THERE'S BEEN THE
PORCH AT A CRITICAL POINT TO
MAKING IT VERY DIFFICULT FOR
EXPORTS TO GET THROUGH THE
PORTS. AND- YOU KNOW THAT'S
CAUSING MARKETS TO BE VERY-
DISRUPTED THAT'S ALL AND IF YOU
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS I'M HERE
THANK YOU I BELIEVE THAT WE
WILL- GO TO THE QUESTIONS AT
THE END OF THE PANEL. WE HAVE
THE NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
WELCOME WE CAN SEE YOU. RIGHT
THE NEW YORK TIMES CALLING AND
I THINK IT'S MARTIN ARE YOU ON
PHONE. YEAH I'M ON THE PHONE
THANK YOU. OKAY WE CAN HEAR YOU
RECEIVE ONE READY- THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR- TAKING ON THIS TOPIC
AMPLE INVITING ME TO- PRESENT
TO YOU TODAY- I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR AT THE ECOLOGY CENTER
IN BERKELEY. WE ARE A SMALL
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION THAT
STARTED THE FIRST CURBSIDE
RECYCLING PROGRAM IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY THREE AND WE CONTINUE.
TO PROVIDE THAT SERVICE THE
CITY BERKELEY UNDER CONTRACT-
WE HAVE ALWAYS BEEN AN
ENVIRONMENTAL ORGANIZATION AND
THE GOALS OF THE BOOK OF
RECYCLING FOR US HAVE ALREADY-
THEN TO SAVE NATURAL RESOURCES
AND TO CLEAN UP THE ENVIRONMENT.
AND TO CONFRONT OUR OUR WASTE
AND CONSUMERISM- AND- YOU KNOW
I'M LIKE MOST OF THE WASTE
INDUSTRY THAT NOW DOES
RECYCLING WE DON'T OPERATE
LANDFILLS OR INCINERATORS- NOW
WE DON'T HAVE COMPOST CONTRACTS
FOR GARBAGE CONTRACT WITH CITY
OF BERKELEY ACTUALLY ONE OF THE
FEW CITIES IN THE STATE THAT
HAVE RUN THOSE SERVICES SO. I'M
JUST TO GIVE YOU A LITTLE
CONTEXT ON THE ORGANIZATION AND
OUR ORIENTATION TO RECYCLING
WHICH IS BENT TO- REALLY TRYING
TO RECYCLE TO THE HIGHEST AND
BEST USE- AND TO KEEP CLOSE
WITH RECYCLING. I HAVE DARK
GOLD STANDARD AND AT THIS
POINT- RECYCLING YOU KNOW
REALLY WENT DECEMBER PHASE. AND
THAT NINETY TO EIGHTY NINE
THIRTY NINE AM IN CALIFORNIA
ANOTHER LARGE THE COUNTRY AND
MADE RECYCLING COMMONPLACE
ACROSS THE GLOBE BUT IN
EXPANDING AND GROWING- YOU KNOW
MOSTLY WHAT THAT NOW LARGE
GARBAGE COMPANY TAKING ON
RECYCLING BECAUSE OF. CITIES OR
STATE REQUIREMENTS YOU DO SO-
THEY APPLIED INDUSTRIAL-
COLLECTION OPERATIONS AND COST
SAVING MEASURES INCONVENIENCE
MEASURES TO REALLY- SPREAD
RECYCLING FARMLAND SO WE HAD
TREMENDOUS GROWTH ALONG. WITH
THAT- CAME- GRADING OF A LOT OF
THAT COMMODITIES IN THE- AND-
ON A COAST WITH ABLE TO THAT
QUITE. THANK YOU FOR. AND-
THANK TO REALLY- DO EXPLORE AND
THE MODEL MAY. KALAU SO EXPORT.
YEAH BECAUSE CALIFORNIADIVERSE.
NO ARE GOAL IN EIGHTY NINTH
NINE TO BE REDUCE WEIGHT TO
LANDFILL- OF THE ITEMS
CONSEQUENCES OF THAT BEEN EXT A
LOT OF WEIGHT. OTHER COUNTRIES.
AND NOT. TO IN CLASSIC- YEAH A
LOT OF PLASTIC THAT HAVE BEEN
ADDED. TO EXACT PROGRAMS ARE
THE STATE. HELLO REALLY DON'T
HAVE ANY MARKETS OR HAVE VERY
LIMITED MARK YOU CAN EXPLORE IN
A LOT OF- BENEDICT HAVE MY
ALONG WITH YOU KNOW SOME SHOWS
THAT MIGHT HAVE MARKET KNOW NOT
AND YET BUT ONE OF DOWNTURN- I-
ALONG AT A BRIEF TRAILER FOR
MANY TRAILER- BUT STILL CLASS
WHICH IS THAT THE LENGTH DOC.
THAT REALLY TELL THE STORY-
FROM WELLHEAD ALL THE WAY TO-
DO THIS BUT BUT AT A TRAGIC
STORY CALIFORNIA HAS. A SPECIAL
PART IN CALIFORNIA REMAIN THE-
MY ORDER UP PLASTIC- AND- MUCH
OF THAT BEING ATKINS. HAMBURGER
AT REALLY DON'T HAVE GOOD MARK.
I THINK OF CALIFORNIA AS AN
ENVIRONMENTAL LEADER I'VE GROWN
UP IN BERKELEY HAVE BEEN A PART
OF THIS MOVEMENT FOR MANY
DECADES- AND THEN I SEE ALL THE
ADVANCEMENT WE'VE MADE THEM-
ORGANIC. AND THE WINE INDUSTRY
YOU KNOW PRODUCING SOME OF THE
BEST- CRY JERRY CAL THAT TAX
THE BEST- MARIJUANA BEST ONE
THE BACK- PRODUCE- AND WILL IN
A CAR ON WE HAVEN'T. I'M FOR.
AND YET AND CYCLE AND- WHAT
KIND OF- SOME CASES LAXATIVE
WORK. AND SO I WOULD TO SEE I
RESPECTFULLY- YEAH BEYOND THAT
LEVEL OF BEING MALL THE BUDGET.
NOTED THAT RESPECT WHAT THE YOU
CAN GET ON THE PLANE AND OUT OF
TOWN. ALL ALONG WAY FROM. ON
THE MARK CRASHING CHINA WILL.
DRIVEN INTO IN QUALITY- BUT
STILL YOU CAN IN CALIFORNIA AND
OKAY ON QUALITY- HELLO BEEN A
PRE THING. BUT I THINK HOW CAN
BERKELEY- WE NEVER TO THANK OF
THE- GATHER WE HAVE A DOORS
PROGRAM THAT REQUIRE RENDON TO
SEPARATE COUNTY BOTTLES APRIL
BUT- I'M THIS. REDUCE CAN. AND
S. INCREASES. OF THE MATERIAL.
HE WANTED TO BE BURIED- THINK
ABOUT QUALITY. PARTICULARLY FOR
X. THANK YOU SEE FROM. COMING
OUT THE AB FIFTEEN EIGHTY THREE
EIGHTY CONDITION. THAT BY CAN-
I FINALLY CRAZY CHIP THE COURT
DOES- HOW YOU GET A. AND AND-
SUPPORT- TO PROVIDE LIKE YOU
CAR. REGARDING LOOKING COMING
INTO SOME KIND OF A LINE
BARRIER I JUST RECOGNIZE THAT
YOU DON'T WANT TO EXPLORE.
WORST OVER THE YEARS TO COLLECT
MORE AND MORE DIFFERENT KINDS
OF PLASTICS- AND- AND USUALLY
HAD MARKETS WITHIN CHINA WHERE
WE HAD DIRECT LINE OF SIGHT FOR
THE FIFTY HAVE TIME FACTOR DO.
I'M A BIG FOR A MARKETED- BUT
IT IS IMPORTANT TO US THAT WE
WANT- CONTRIBUTING TO DUMPING
OF BURNING ARE CONTAMINATING
THE ENVIRONMENT. UNDER CYCLE
CLASSIC- THOSE MARKETS CLOSED
CLOSED PRETTY DOWN FOR QUICKLY
AND THE TWENTY THIRD ORCHESTRA
ON THE PRODUCTS CHINA COULDN'T
QUITE AND- THEN YOU KNOW
BECOMING PRETTY- A JOURNAL-
TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY. I'M GREAT
WE BEEN TAKING THE LOVE NANBAN
FIVE ONE TIME ABOUT IT
EVERYTHING THAT MICHAEL THE
RECYCLE BIN PLASTIC IT IS NOT
OF. SO PVG AND ITS BOTTLES ARE
REALLY ONLY THING THAT HAVE THE
LAB IN MY AT THIS TIME AND-
REALLY TO SEE DOES MUCH MORE
CLOSE WITH AND GOING BOTTOM TO
BOTTLE AND THEN THE FIRST ON.
STANDARD THAT PASSED LAST YEAR-
A REALLY CRITICAL YOU CREATING
MARK BUT BY BOB AND- NOT JUST
YOU KNOW MAKING SOME OTHER
DURABLE GOODS THAT EVENTUALLY
GOING TO END UP IN THE- BUT I'M
MARKING- FOR THAT NON BY CLAM
ARE YOUR GOT THIS MINUTES
COMMUTE YOU OCT PLEASE WRAP UP
THE TEST. THANK YOU. INCREASE
IN THE DEPOSIT THAT WOULD PUT
US ON PAR I AM VERY QUICKLY
WITH MORGAN AND I THINK THAT A
LOT OF CHALLENGES AND PROBLEMS
ORGAN SYSTEM. FOR RECYCLERS- I
USUALLY TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION.
HOW DID FOR THE PAST A LOT.
OKAY WHO'S THE- SECOND. OKAY
THANK YOU I WE HAVE RICK
TOMLINSON PRESIDENT OF THE CAL
STRAWBERRY COMMISSION. WELL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE THIS COMMITTEE WITH AN
UPDATE ON THE ACTIVITY THAT
BERRY FARMERS ARE UNDERTAKING
AND REGARDS TO PACKAGING. IN
NOW- YOUR TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN ON ALL THESE GLOBAL
POLICY CHANGES OCCURRED- THAT
CAUGHT OUR ATTENTION AND WE HAD
SOME MEMBERS OF THE INDUSTRY
YOU KNOW PROACTIVELY REACHING
OUT TRYING TO BETTER UNDERSTAND
WHAT WHAT THESE IMPACTS MY LOOK
LIKE. WE STARTED COLLABORATING
AND REACHING OUT WITH- PEOPLE
THERE ARE OBVIOUSLY THE FOLKS
THAT MAKE OUR PAKAGES ARE
WANTED TO TALK TO THEM- THAT
LED US TO TALK TO THEM THE
MERCHANT AND- THE WHOLE.
RECYCLING STREAM TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND WHAT WAS GOING ON
AND SLOWLY ALL THAT CAME
TOGETHER. AND ULTIMATELY- THAT
LET US TO OUR FEBRUARY OF THIS
YEAR- MAKING A PLEDGE-
THROUGHOUT THE VERY SUPPLY
CHAIN IN THE ENTIRE WESTERN
HEMISPHERE NORTH AMERICA SOUTH
AMERICA. ONLINE UPDATING THE
CLAM SHELL PACKAGING THAT WE
CURRENTLY USE. IT IT- AND ALL
THAT SPEAK ABOUT A MINUTE BUT
FIRST JUST YEAH I IN REGARDS
TO- THAT EFFORT AND WHO'S
INVOLVED. SO THE- THE FIRST
SLIDE AND I'M NOT SURE IF
YOU'RE ABLE TO SEE A SLIGHT I'M
NOT YEAH I DO SEE A SLIDE. YES
WE DO OKAY SO THE FIRST LIGHT
IS- A SAMPLE OF THE- TRADE
ASSOCIATIONS DIFFERENT
ORGANIZATIONS THAT WE'RE ABLE
TO PULL TOGETHER AND- TO
REALLY- COORDINATE ACROSS ALL
THESE DIFFERENT STATES AND
COUNTRIES AND REGIONS YEAH
BECAUSE UNLIKE- YOU KNOW THINGS
THAT YOU THAT YOU MIGHT-
TYPICALLY THINK OF COMING FROM
A FACTORY LINE RIGHT THESE.
BERRIES ARE BEING PACKAGED-
THAT APPLE FARM SO WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THOUSANDS OF
FARMS ACROSS ALL THESE
DIFFERENT STATES AND REGIONS
AND REALLY NEEDING TO
COORDINATE- THE DIFFERENT TYPES
OF WAY THAT- BERRIES ARE
PACKAGE JUSTIN BERRY PICKING UP
STRAWBERRIES ARE PACKAGED-
DIFFERENTLY- THAN BLUEBERRIES
AND PACKAGED DIFFERENTLY THAN
RASPBERRY SO- JUST ALL THOSE
LITTLE DETAILS ARE WORKING
THROUGH ALL THAT- BUT WE WERE
WE WERE SUCCESSFUL IN GETTING
THE COMMITMENT OF THE ENTIRE
SUPPLY CHAIN- THAT COMES INTO
NORTH AMERICA. AND IS
PREDOMINATELY- SUPPLIED OUT OF
NORTH AMERICA WITH A SOME
IMPORTS FROM SOUTH AMERICA.
YEAH SO- SO FOR IF I COULD TO
AND NOW TURN SLIDE. YEAH- THE
CURRENT CLAM SHELL SO. FOR JUST
OVER TWENTY YEARS WE'VE BEEN
USING THE PLASTIC CLAM CHOWDER
CLAM SHELL IN IN STRAWBERRIES
AND- IN THE OTHER BIRDS AS WELL
AND YEAH WE REALLY BENEFITTED
FROM THE RECYCLING GOING ON IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA BECAUSE
THAT CLAM SHELL- HAS TYPICALLY
CONTAIN THE MOST AMOUNT OF
CALIFORNIA RECYCLE CONTENT OF
ANY FOOD PACKAGE IN THE UNITED
STATES. AND SO FOR MANY YEARS-
WE THOUGHT HEY WE'RE DOING A
PRETTY GOOD JOB BUT OF COURSE
IT'S NOT YOU KNOW AFTER WE'VE
RECYCLED THE BOTTLES INTO THE
CLAM SHELL THEN WHERE DOES THE
CLAM SHELL GO AND SO WE
RECOGNIZE THAT'S THAT'S A
PROBLEM THAT HAS TO BE SOLVED.
SO THE FIRST THING YOU KNOW WHO
WE STARTED LIKE I DESCRIBED-
COORDINATING WITH OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS AND IN DIFFERENT
PARTS OF THE COUNTRY AS WELL AS
OTHER INDUSTRIES IN THE
RECYCLING SUPPLY CHAIN. WE
STARTED TESTING- ALTERNATIVE
PRODUCTS ALTERNATE MATERIALS
FIBER CARDBOARD YEAH- THE IMAGE
THAT YOU SEE ON THE RIGHT IS-
CARDBOARD AT. CALLED TRAYS- AND
THEN WITHIN THAT ARE CARDBOARD
CLAM SHELLS INSTEAD OF PLASTIC
CLAM SHELLS. OUT ITS COLLAPSE
THERE BECAUSE WHAT HAPPENED IS
THE MOISTURE IN THE BERRIES WAS
ABSORBED BY THE CARDBOARD CLAM
SHELL. THAT THEN TRANSFERRED IT
INTO THE TRAY THAT THAT
PROVIDES THE STRUCTURE SO THAT
YOU KNOW THE FREE DOESN'T GET
SQUISHED AND YOU CAN SEE IF IT
COLLAPSED. AL BUT I'LL SAY THAT
PICTURE IS IN OUR VIEW AN
EXAMPLE OF SUCCESS IN THE SENSE
OF PROGRESS YEAH BECAUSE WE'RE
STILL WORKING WITH FIBER RIGHT
SO I'M GONNA TELL YOU WHAT
WE'RE DOING. IN TERMS OF
PLASTIC BUT OUR WORK IN FIBER
AND IT'S NOT JUST OUR WORK THE
WORK OF MANY PACKAGING
COMPANIES IN IN FIBER IS STILL
GOING ON SO- SO WE LOOK AT LIKE
SAID THAT AS AN EXAMPLE OF A
PROGRESS AND- AND I WOULD
EXPECT TO SEE. NICHE%
OPPORTUNITIES- WOULDN'T AMOUNT
TO A AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
TRANSFORMATIONAL CHANGE.
BECAUSE THAT PLASTIC SHELL-
ACHIEVE SO MANY OTHER-
STANDARDS AND I IN PARTICULAR
IF WE THINK OF FOOD SAFETY ALSO
IF WE THINK OF FOOD WASTE- THE
CLAM SHELL BECAUSE IT'S NOT
ABSORBING THE MOISTURE OUT WE
GET A LONGER SHELF LIFE IN THE
FRUIT M. AND SO WE REDUCED OF
THE FOOD WASTE. ALSO BECAUSE
IT'S VERY VERY LIGHT YOU TALKED
ABOUT WASTE REDUCTION I MEAN
YOU KNOW THESE CLAM SHELLS HAVE
BEEN OPTIMIZED TO DOWN TO THE
GRAHAM- IN TERMS OF. ACHIEVING
THE LEAST AMOUNT OF PLASTIC TO
DO ITS JOB. ANDPART OF THAT
ALSO IS TO BE LIGHT WEIGHT SO
THAT FOR SHIPPING IT REDUCES
ENERGY COSTS- FOR SHIPPING SO.
LOTS OF BENEFICIAL PURPOSES TO
THAT CURRENT CLAM SHELL. BUT IN
ORDER TO IMPROVE IT- THE ONE
BARRIER THAT WE IMMEDIATELY
SIZE THAT WE USE OUR PAPER AND-
ON THE LABEL. AND WHILE THERE
CAN BE RECYCLED IT IT
DEFINITELY CAUSES A CHALLENGE
AND CAN GUM UP THE SYSTEM THERE
AND- IT WITH THE RECYCLERS AS
THEY TRY AND WASH OUT OFTEN THE
GLUE. AND SO THE- THE STANDARD-
THAT WE FOUND- WAS TO SWITCH TO
A B. O. P. P. LABEL- SAME TYPE
A LABEL THAT YOU SEE ON THOSE-
BEVERAGE BOTTLES- THAT'S ALSO
MADE OUT OF PLASTIC SO THAT THE
LABEL CAN BE RECYCLED ITSELF AS
WELL. AND AND SO IN FEBRUARY WE
MADE THE COMMITMENT AS THE
INDUSTRY TO SWITCH A 100% OF
THE SUPPLY CHAIN TO THAT B. O.
P. P. LABEL. AND WE'RE TALKING
JUST A LITTLE TINY BIT OF
MATERIAL THERE BUT- IT WAS
SURPRISING. JUST AS A INDUSTRY
SWITCH- WE SAW THE- PRICE
GOUGING OCCURRING- 90% HIGHER
THAN WHAT IT SHOULD BE- IT
QUICKLY SETTLED OUT IN PART
BECAUSE THERE'S A HEALTHY-
MARKETPLACE OF SUPPLIERS M.
BECAUSE- WE- PART OF OUR WHOLE
REASON FOR COORDINATING AS- THE
ENTIRE INDUSTRY IS TO TRY AND
CREATE ECONOMIES OF SCALE. AND
SO- THAT IS THEN YOU KNOW TO
OUR NEXT STEP AND THE ULTIMATE
STEP WHICH IS- GETTING OUR OWN
CLAM SHELLS BACK. AND SO- I'M
I'M PLEASED TO SAY THAT THE
FIRST PURCHASE. FOR THERMOFORM
CLEAN WASH LAKE WHICH IS WHAT
YOU GET WHEN YOU RECYCLE
CLAMSHELL- IT HAS OCCURRED IN
IN TWENTY TWENTY- WE STILL HAVE
A LONG WAY TO GO WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT VERY SMALL AMOUNT BUT-
BUT IT IS STARTING. AND AND THE
FIRST THING THAT WE'VE OBSERVED
IN THAT PROCESS IS THAT-
BECAUSE THERE'S NOT BEEN A
MARKET PLACE PREVIOUSLY-
THEY'RE JUST A VERY LIMITED
NUMBER OF CLAM SHELLS ARE
CURRENTLY BEING RECYCLED- IN
SOME. REGIONS IN THE STATE THEY
ARE BUT NOT ALL. AND SO- THAT'S
THAT'S OUR NEXT STEP IS TO. NOT
ONLY JUST MAKE THE PURCHASES
BUT TO WORK WITH THE RECYCLING
SUPPLY CHAIN TO- ENCOURAGE
CONSUMERS TO RECYCLE AS WELL AS
AT THE CURBSIDE PROGRAMS TO
COLLECT THOSE CLAM SHELLS SO
THAT WE CAN GET HIM INTO THAT
RECYCLING PIPELINE SO WE CAN
BUY THAT FROM A FORM CLEAN WASH
LIKE. SO THAT IS WHERE WE'RE AT
IN. CALIFORNIA STRAWBERRIES IN
THEM AND THE BERRY INDUSTRY FOR
NORTH AMERICA AND YEAH. PLEASED
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT
YOU MIGHT HAVE OKAY THANK YOU
HAVE A SERIES OF QUESTIONS HERE
BUT I DO WANT TO GO BACK. TO
THE FIRST SPEAKER MISTER KELLER
CAN YOU COME BACK UP HERE WE
HAVE ASSEMBLY WOMAN. GARCIA
FROM HER DISTRICT. WHO WANTS
TO- TALKED ABOUT SOME ISSUES
THANK YOU. SO SHE JUST STARTS
TALKING YEAH YEAH. SO THEY
START OVER YES GO AHEAD
CRISTINA. YEAH I THINK YOU AND
I SEE THIS QUESTION COULD MAYBE
BE FOR ANY OF THE PANELISTS-
ARE THAT YOU HAVE ON THE
SECTION JUST WONDERING ABOUT
THE INCREASED USE OF PESONAL
PROTECTIVE- PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT AND THE PLASTIC THAT
WE SEE IN THAT AND HOW THAT'S
IT WE HAVE ANY DATA ABOUT. THAT
IN OUR WASTE STREAM ON AND HOW
WE'RE MANAGING THAT. I DON'T
HAVE ANY SPECIFIC DATA- WEEK WE
HAVE SEEN AN UPTICK IN. I THINK
WE HEARD SOME OTHERS SPEAKERS
SAY THE SAME THING WE HAVE SEEN
AN UPTICK IN- MASKS AND
GARMENTS AND GLOVES ARE SHOWING
UP IN A RECYCLING FACILITIES
WHICH IS TROUBLING- THAT'S
CONTAMINATION FOR US THERE ARE
NOT. AND MARKETS FOR THOSE
TYPES OF MATERIALS- BUT YOU
KNOW I WOULD EXPECT THAT. AND-
WE SEE ADDITIONAL UPTICK- IN
OUR IN A STUDY STREAMS AS WELL-
AND THEN I YOU KNOW I CAN ONLY
IMAGINE YOU KNOW WHAT THE
HOSPITALS AND SOME OF THE OTHER
INSTITUTIONS ARE DEALING WITH.
THE THAT THEY'RE UTILIZING BUT-
NOT AND THAT NO SPECIFIC DATE-
THERE THERE'S PROBABLY- SO.
THAT WE CAN DIG UP IN TERMS OF
P. P. E. PRODUCTION AND SALES-
THAT- WE COULD PROBABLY- YOU
KNOW DO SOME MATH AROUND- WHAT
THAT MEANS FOR A GENERATION OF
WASTE. DO YOU THINK WE SHOULD
HAVE SORT OF A PLAN FOR THAT
OR- YOU CAN SHOW CAMPAIGN ARE.
SHE WILL BE BEING PROACTIVE.
IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE'VE
LOOKED AT- AT THE PAST IN THE
PAST- ON THE YOU KNOW OUR
THEY'RE VIABLE AND MARKETS FOR
THOSE TYPES OF MATERIALS- YOU
KNOW A MASK- YOU KNOWSEVERAL
DIFFERENT TYPES OF MATERIALS SO
MULTI MATERIAL ASSEMBLY FOR
GARMENTS YOU USUALLY HAVE SOME
WOVEN NON WOVEN- MULTIPLE TYPES
OF RESIN SO THE RECYCLING THOSE
MATERIALS. CAN BE PARTICULARLY
CHALLENGING YOU KNOW THE OTHER
THING THAT'S CHALLENGING IN IN
A LOT OF RECYCLING MARKET
PLACES PARTICULARLY IF YOU'RE
DEALING WITH EXPORT MARKETS-
ANY ANY. FORM OF MATERIAL THAT
COULD BE CONSIDERED MEDICAL
WASTE- IS PARTICULARLY
PROBLEMATIC FOR- ACCEPTANCE OF
MATERIALS- AND COULD LEAD TO
THE REJECTIONS OF ENTIRE LOADS.
I THINK THE UNITED I THINK
THOSE MATERIALS ARE BEST
MANAGED IN THE GARBAGE. ACTITUD
MARTIN AT THE ECOLOGY AND I
WOULD JUST SAY- VERY SIMILARLY
WE'VE SEEN SOME IN OUR
RECYCLING PROGRAM- WE THINK THE
MESSAGE IS PRETTY CLEAR OUT
THERE THAT THESE ARE- TO BE PUT
IN THE GARBAGE AND NOT MOST
LIKELY. BUT WE HAVE SEEN SOME-
IF WE WERE TO TAKE A PROACTIVE
APPROACH TO THEM I WOULD SAY
REALLY FOCUSING ON REVIEWS- AND
RE USABLE FOR THE AVERAGE
CONSUMER- THE END AVERAGE
RESIDENTS HAVE A REUSABLE MASK.
IS IMPORTANT AS OPPOSED TO A
DISPOSABLE AND BE ABLE TO YOU
KNOW UNDERSTAND WHAT WASHING
AND SANITIZING ANYTHING OF THE
PERPETRATORS AND THEN FOR THE
MEDICAL INDUSTRY I'M REALLY YOU
KNOW THEY COULD BE DOING A LOT
OF REVIEWS ON WASHING- REUSABLE
ABOUT SUPPOSED TO THE
DISPOSABLE MODEL THAT OUR
MEDICAL. SYSTEM AND IS BASED ON
CURRENTLY- AND FINALLY I WOULD
JUST SAY FROM THE LEGISLATIVE
PERSPECTIVE- REQUIRING MINIMUM
CONTENT- RECYCLE CONTACT FOR
SOME OF THOSE PLASTIC PRODUCTS
THAT ARE DISPOSABLE I WOULD BE
A WAY TOO EARLY- HELP IMPROVE
THE MARKET- FOR RECYCLED. I
TELL. ARE THERE A MODELS ANYWAY.
ON I'M PP AND- RECYCLABILITY OR
AT COULD LOOK AT TO LEARN FROM.
MATURE HELP WITH THE HARM- THAT
DAY DONE A LOT OF WORK
REASONABLE THAN- AND- HOSPITAL
ON AND MEDICAL- AND I DO HAVE
SOME MODEL- I'M NOT SURE ABOUT
NATIONAL CERTAINLY IN THE
NATIONAL SCALE AND I CAN
PROVIDE SOME- CONTACT
INFORMATION FOR THEM AND YOU'RE
INTERESTED. ARE YOU PLEASE
BECAUSE AND OF MY I LOOK THOSE
ALL MY BY THING YOU. OKAY THANK
YOU. QUESTIONS FOR THIS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN
ACTUALLY I DON'T HAVE A
QUESTION I JUST WANTED TO MAKE
A COMMENT ABOUT- FROM THE
WITNESS FROM THE STRAWBERRY
COMMISSION THAT IT'S REALLY
WONDERFUL TO SEE- A GROUP YOU
DON'T INDUSTRY GROUP REALLY
GOING OUT OF THEIR WAY TO TRY
TO BE A GOOD STEWARD FOR THEIR
PRODUCT- VERY APPRECIATED I
WILL CERTAINLY FEEL GOOD BUYING
MY STRAWBERRIES. THANK YOU YEAH.
THANK YOU AND- I DID ASK
QUESTIONS EARLIER FOR MISTER
KELLER AT YOU KNOW ONE THING I
JUST I FIND IT REALLY
INTERESTING AND OUT ASSEMBLY
WOMAN FRIEDMAN I WOULD. TALK
ABOUT SOFT LINE WE HAD A
HEARING. ON MONDAY ABOUT-
PLASTIC WASTE AND IF YOU LOOK
AT THE AMOUNTS. OF OF WASTE
THAT HAS A NEGATIVE IMPACTS OF
NEGATIVE EXTERNALITY ON OUR
SOCIETY IT'S NOT FRANKLY PAPER
AND CARDBOARD- THOSE AND I DO
GETTING IN THE RIVER WATER
STREAM PROBABLY. BIODEGRADABLE
ANYWAY. AFTER A CERTAIN PERIOD
OF TIME- YOU KNOW- GLASS AND
CANS NOT THEIRS IS JUST
PLASTICS SO I FIND IT.
FASCINATING THAT. IT'S PROBABLY
95% OF THE ISSUES WE TALK ABOUT
AS FAR AS OUR WASTE STREAM
IMPACTS TO SOCIETY OUR- PUBLIC
HEALTH. OUR ENVIRONMENT OUR
WILDLIFE. BUT IT'S ONLY 8% OF
THE STUFF THAT WE- PUT OUT IN
THE DAN'S INTAKE TO EITHER
RECYCLING FACILITIES. OR
LANDFILLS AND SO AGAIN. THIS
GETS BACK TO THE ISSUE IS WERE.
FIGHTING AND STRUGGLING TO WHAT
TYPE OF CANS AND RINSING OUT
AND YOU KNOW MY KIDS ARE.
CHICKEN THE PEANUT BUTTER
CONTAINER FOR MULTIPLE DAYS OF
WATER TO GET A PERFECTLY. CLEAN
TO GET IN THE BIN BUT LIKE. YOU
KNOW. IT IT MAYBE WE SHOULD
TURN IT BACK ON IT ON ITS IS AS%
REALLY- TALK OF THE PRODUCERS
AND- WE'RE DOING OUR BEST AS
ASSEMBLY WOMAN EGGMAN SAID AS
CONSUMERS TRYING TO TRYING TO
RECYCLE AND EVEN DURING THESE
TOUGH TIMES AND- THIS IS THIS
BASADI BEEN TOLD OVER AND OVER
THROUGH IN THE BLUE BAND YOU'RE
ALL GOOD YOU CAN RECYCLE THESE
PRODUCTS RUGGED DON'T WORRY
ABOUT BUYING WATER BOTTLES AS
OPPOSED TO HYDRO FLASK BECAUSE
THEY CAN ALL BE I'LL BE
RECYCLED AND SO. WE KNOW THAT
THAT'S THAT NOT NOT TRUE AND
SO- YOU KNOW I APPRECIATE THE
IN THE INDUSTRY IN AMERICA'S
YOU KNOW DOING WHAT WHAT WHAT
THEY CAN'T DO BUT AGAIN THIS IS
PART OF A BIGGER PICTURE THAT
WE NEED TO FOCUS ON- AND THE
BEGINNINGS OF THESE- AT THESE
PRODUCTS TO GET INTO SOCIETY
AND OUR VOICESTREAM AND
EVERYTHING ELSE SO- I DON'T
HAVE ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS. FOR
YOU ALL- AT. ONE SEVEN MEMBER
EGGMAN A QUESTION. THANK YOU-
AND I JUST WANT TO SAY
SOMETHING TO A WRECK FROM THE
STRAWBERRY ASSOCIATION I ALSO.
AS A CHAIR AG I APPRECIATE WHEN
THE PANDEMIC FIRST HIT THERE
WERE SOME OF THE FIRST PEOPLE-
TO REALLY PUT IN A BUNCH OF
PROTECTIVE MEASURES AND DO A
VERY COMPREHENSIVE. A PLAN FOR
THEIR AGRICULTURE WORKERS- AND
REALLY KIND OF SET THE- THE
MODEL AND THE STANDARD FOR THE-
INDUSTRY I THINK. FOR THE
AGRICULTURE INDUSTRY SO I JUST
WANT TO BE ABLE TO RECOGNIZE
THAT IN THE- WORST OF THEM WITH
ALL THE ALL KINDS OF PROBLEMS
IT'S JUST REALLY GOOD TO SEE AN
INDUSTRY BEING PROACTIVE NOT.
ONLY ON THE- RECYCLING FRONT
BUT ALSO IN TAKING GOOD CARE OF
YOUR EMPLOYEES THANK YOU FOR
THAT. OKAY THANK YOU ANOTHER
COMMENT FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
WE WILL NOW GO TO PUBLIC
COMMENTS ASSEMBLY WE HAVE
SPEAKERS IN THE AUDIENCE AS
WELL AS PEOPLE ARE POTENTIALLY
ON THE- THAILAND. SYSTEM DO WE
HAVE ANYBODY ON THAT DO WE KNOW.
YEAH OPERATOR DO WE HAVE TO DO
WE HAVE ANYBODY. ON THE PHONE
HE WOULD LIKE TO PARTICIPATE.
AT&T OPERATOR. THANK YOU LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
MAKE A COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THE TIME. THE
PROJECT BE A MOMENT WHILE WE
PROVIDE THE LINE NUMBER OKAY
THANK YOU. LOSSES YOU CAN. OKAY
WHY WE'RE GIVING UP THE PEOPLE
CALLING IN YOU CAN ASK THE
PUBLIC WANTED TIME TO PLEASE
COME UP. PLEASE KEEP YOUR
COMMENTS TO TWO MINUTES OR LESS
TWO MINUTES I WILL REMIND YOU
WHEN YOUR TIME. IS WRAPPING UP.
OKAY PLEASE PLEASE BEGIN THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING. AFTERNOON
RATHER. I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW
WHAT IS IT LIKE WORKING FOR
SATAN. WHAT IS IT LIKE WHAT IS
THE JOB REQUIREMENTS. I WOULD
THINK ONE OF THEM WOULD BE TO
HAVE A SEARED CONSCIENCE. ALL
THIS TALK ABOUT RECYCLING
ALUMINUM AND PLASTIC. IS THERE
SHORTAGE FOR ALUMINUM IN
VACCINES MAYBE. RICKOVER
NINETEEN VACCINE ABOUT SPRAYING
THE SKIES THERE SHORTAGE. FOR
ALUMINUM. ABOUT PLASTIC FOR
VACCINES. WHERE WE SO CONCERNED
ABOUT ALL THIS RIGHT NOW CAN
YOU RECYCLE ALL THE DEADLINES
THAT ARE ABOUT TO HAPPEN NEXT
YEAR. CAN RECYCLE THE LIVES OF
THE CHILDREN THAT YOU GUYS ARE
GONNA BE RESPONSIBLE FOR. I
THINK THE PRESS BACKED IS GONNA
PREPARE YOU BEFORE YOU STEP IN
FRONT OF YOUR GUIDE. IT YOU'RE
GOING TO SAY AND THAT'S RIGHT.
WHAT IS GONNA BE A DAY WHEN YOU
MEET YOUR MAKER. IN YOUR SOUL
WON'T BE RECYCLED BE RECYCLED.
RECYCLE RECYCLE RIGHT. SO DO
YOU GUYS CARE ABOUT THE
CHILDREN I MEAN WHAT WHAT IS IT
LIKE TO HAVE A SEARED
CONSCIENCE. DO YOU GUYS HAVE
ANY SYMPATHY ANY EMPATHY. THE
SERB PRINCIPLES. YOU GOTTA JUST
FAKE IT RIGHT YOU GOT TO
PRETEND YOU GOT IT YOU GOT IT
PRETEND. THAT YOU GUYS CTUALLY
CARE ABOUT SOCIETY RIGHT YOU
GOT IT YOU GOT YOUR ETHICS-
JOHN TOMPKINS YOU KNOW YOU GOT
YOU GOT IT. YOU GOT TO MAKE
THIS ETHICS FRAMEWORK. MAKE IT
LOOK LIKE YOU GUYS REALLY CARE
ABOUT SOCIETY AND THAT THE
VACCINE IS ETHICAL. ARE YOU
GUYS ARE YOU I MEAN. YOU GUYS
YOU GUYS JUST GOT A FAKE
EVERYTHING RIGHT YOU GUYS HAVE
NO SENSE OF MORALITY AND
BECAUSE YOU GUYS ARE WORKING
FOR SATAN YEAH. YOU GUYS JUST
GOT TO CREATE RAN SECOND SO WE
GOT THIS VACCINATION PLAN WE
GOT THE CDC PLAYBOOK. ALL THIS
IS AGAIN EXPOSED OKAY. GET THIS
IN FRONT OF THE CAMERA RIGHT.
PEOPLE ARE LOSING CONFIDENCE IN
YOU AND YOUR VACCINE PROGRAM IS
GONNA FAIL YOUR TIMES OUT IT'S
GONNA FAIL ALL RIGHT KEVIN
TIMES OUT THANK YOU KNOW YOU
GUYS SHOULD HAVE A LOT MORE
PEOPLE. UP THERE THANK YOU IT'S-
TIMES THAT THANK YOU. YOU YEAH
HE WORKING FOR SAYING WELL THAT
YEAH NOW THIS WILL BUILDINGS
GOING DOWN OKAY. SAXICOLA GUY
ANYWAY SO. I DON'T CARE I'M.
THE WHOLE THING IS A JOKE YEAH
NOT GONNA GET THIS EITHER
REMEMBER. BUT HE COULD YOU
PLEASE DE BACK FIRST WE WANT TO
PROTECT. EVERYBODY YEAH WE DO.
BEING. EXACTLY. OKAY HANG TIGHT.
C. WELL. AND REALIZE THAT
SIGNED UP FOR THIS. YEAH THIS
IS MY FIRST YEAH. YEAH. MANY
OKAY PLEASE COME UP I'LL START
THE TIMER WHEN YOU START TO
SPEAK AGAIN YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES TWO MINUTES. I WAS
ACTUALLY NOT GOING TO SPEAK
TODAY BECAUSE THIS TOPIC OF
RECYCLING IS NOT REALLY MY
WHEEL HOUSE OF COURSE LIKE
EVERYONE I DEFINITELY VALUE THE
NATURAL WORLD AND WANT TO CLEAN
OR CLEAN WATER CLEAN AIR AND I
DO WHAT I CAN TO REDUCE AND
REUSE THINGS TO THE BEST OF MY
ABILITY. I JUST LISTENED TO ALL
OF YOU AND THE SUPPOSED EXPERTS
AD NAUSEUM FOR HOURS SUCH THAT
I CHANGE MY MIND AND DECIDED TO
SPEAK REALLY WHEN I HEARD IT
SAID IN THIS VERY HEARING THAT
PEOPLE WANT A MORE RECYCLED WE
ARE RESPONSIBLE STE RECYCLING
SYSTEM. THAT WAS THE MOMENT
WHEN I REALIZED I COULD NOT
KEEP QUIET AND FRANKLY I REALLY
HAVE NO WORDS TO EXPRESS HOW
TONE DEAF YOU ALL ARE EXCUSE ME
BUT WHAT KIND OF DELUSION ALL
PLANET ARE YOU LIVING IN. THIS
TALK OF WINE BOTTLES BEER
PACKAGING SELTZER PACKAGING
REFILLABLE STRAUS CREAMERY
BOTTLES SPECIALIZED GIGS CLAM
SHELLS THIS ENTIRE HEARING
PROVED TO ME WHAT A PROTECTED
UNTOUCHABLE WORLD YOU ARE
LIVING IN THE WORLD OF THE
ECONOMICALLY PRIVILEGED SMUG
SANCTIMONIOUS LIBERAL ELITIST
LEFT. YOUR LIVES ARE LITERALLY
NOTHING LIKE MOST CALIFORNIANS
AND THE NONSENSE OF THIS
HEARING IS MORE OF A WINDOW
INTO THE CORRUPTION AND APATHY
OF THIS LEGISLATURE I HAVE BEEN
ATTENDING HEARING AFTER HEARING
IN THIS BUILDING ABOUT VARIOUS
COVERT TOPICS IN THE LAST FEW
WEEKS. AND WHAT I'VE LEARNED IS
THAT PEOPLE ARE NOT ABLE TO
ACCESS FOOD AND ARE GOING
HUNGRY THEY'RE UNEMPLOYED THEY
ARE LOSING THEIR BUSINESSES IN
THEIR HOMES AND THAT TEENAGERS
AND FOSTER CHILDREN ARE KILLING
THEMSELVES. DUE TO ISOLATION.
AND THIS RESPONSIBILITY RESTS
SQUARELY ON YOU THE LEGISLATURE
I HAVEN'T WATCH THIS GOVERNING
BODY CREATE POLICY AFTER POLICY
OVER DECADES THAT HAS COST
CALIFORNIA TO BE IN THE
POSITION THAT IT'S IN. WELL YOU
CONTINUALLY COLLECT YOUR
PROTECTED SECURE GOVERNMENT
SALARIES. WE DO. LEGAL
UNCONSTITUTIONAL. CALIFORNIA IS
THE HIGHEST RATES OF
UNEMPLOYMENT SINCE THE GREAT
DEPRESSION. AND THE CORRUPTION
OF THE EDT HAS HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE UNABLE TO
ACCESS THEIR UNEMPLOYMENT.
CHECKS THANK YOU. AB SCHOOL FOR
THEIR THANK YOU TIME IS THAT.
AND SHE. YEAH THANK YOU. YOU
CAN STEP BACK FOR ONE SEC. OKAY
PLEASE COME UP. AGAIN YOU HAVE
TWO MINUTES. TWO MINUTES. HI I
WOULD LOVE IF YOU GUYS WOULD
ACTUALLY TURN THE HEAT ON
EVENTUALLY IN THIS ROOM BEFORE
WE ALL FREEZE. AND SECONDLY I
WOULD ALMOST LOVE IT IF YOU
GUYS WOULD STOP BLAMING
EVERYTHING ON BECAUSE OF IT YOU
TOO MCCARTY. BECAUSE IT'S LIKE
EVERY FIVE SECONDS IT'S HOW
TERRIBLE ALL LIFE IS I WONDER
HOW TERRIBLE YOURS IS. ANYWAY
IT WAS AN INSULT TO PORTRAY
THAT WE THE PEOPLE WE DON'T
UNDERSTAND RECYCLING CAN THIS
DOIG THIS THING WAS BETWEEN
LOW AND GRAY IS THAT EVEN A
THING MCCARTY. EVERYTHING IS
PACKAGED INTO PLASTIC OR
ALUMINUM. SOLO'S CATCHER
BOTTLES MILK JUGS STRAWS
EVERYTHING IS IN PLASTIC
CONTAINERS THE MAYONNAISE THE
X. THE BREAD. SO YOU ARE
CREATING THE PROBLEM. START
USING PAPERS GLASS YOU KNOW IF
THE COMMUNIST COULD DO IT. WE
CAN DO IT WE ALMOST COMPANIES
ANYWAY. SHARKS DOWN SO. AGAIN
IF IT IS TWENTY TWENTY. WE CAN
USE THOSE GLASSES WE CAN USE
THE PAPER IT IS NOT SEVENTEEN
SEVENTY SIX WORK FOR YOUR MONEY.
AND STOP BEGGING FOR IT INSTEAD
THIS IS NOTHING BUT BAGGING. SO
I WAS GOING TO SAY THAT. YOU
KNOW YOU DON'T NEED TO DUMB
THINGS DOWN TO THE PEOPLE BUT
I'LL DUMB IT DOWN TO YOU. TITLE
EIGHTEEN U. S. CODE. ONE ZERO
THREE EIGHT FALSE INFORMATION
AND HOAXES. RELATING TO
BIOLOGICAL HAZARDS. AND TO
CONDUCTING HOAXES. THE HOPE IS
THAT THERE IS A NO EMERGENCY.
THIS LAW IS ENFORCED BY THE FBI
AND THE HOMELAND SECURITY. AND
IT'S PUNISHABLE WITH LIFE IN
PRISON DO YOU TO MCCARTY AND
TEAL ARE AS WELL THANK YOU TIME
IS THAT. YOU'RE WELCOME THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. OKAY.
CAN YOU CAN YOU CAN YOU WAIT ON
HIS WAY ONE SET. ALL RIGHT SO
WHAT WOULD BE THE BEST WAY TO
SYMBOLIZE LYING LIKE MAYBE SOME
CAUTION TAPE WITH THE WORDS
WHOA THERE SOME SERIOUS LYING
UP AHEAD BE CAREFUL. OR ROAD
BUMP WARNING DON'T SPEAK TOO
FAST YOU'LL MISS THE FITTING.
HOW ABOUT WAIT A MINUTE YOU'RE
UNKNOWINGLY ORFOR ALL OF YOU
UP HERE. KNOWINGLY
PARTICIPATING IN A TREMENDOUS
GLOBAL SCANDAL. I'LL KEEP
THINKING ON IT BUT IN THE
MEANTIME LET'S FOR THE FIRST
TIME TODAY ACTUALLY BE HONEST.
THE ONLY RECYCLING THAT'S
HAPPENING. WHERE THAT'S
HAPPENED TODAY IS THE SAME YEAH
SO WE'VE HAD SINCE MARCH
FEARMONGERING PROPAGANDA THE
DELIBERATE OF PULLING ITEMS
FROM STORE SHELVES AND CALLING
IT PANIC BUYING BY US. AND
ASSEMBLY MEN IN THESE CHAMBERS
BARELY PAYING ANY ATTENTION
DURING MEETINGS. THE WIND ISN'T
ONLY CARRYING THOSE NASTY MASKS
INTO THE LANDFILL THERE'S
CHASSIS IS MANY DIRTY SECRETS
ABOUT OUR ELECTED OFFICIAL
CIRCULATING TO. LIKE HOW KEVIN
MCCARTY VOTING YES ON SB ONE
FORTY FIVE TO EXEMPTS CERTAIN
PERSONS CONVICTED OF CERTAIN
OFFENSES INVOLVING MINORS FROM
MANDATORY SEX OFFENDER
REGISTRATION. MAYBE MAYBE WE
COULD DELEGATE SOME RECYCLED
PAPER TO CREATING EDUCATIONAL
PAMPHLETS ON THE EFFECTS OF
ELECTING PETA FILES INTO OUR
GOVERNMENT. BUT YOU THERE'S
MORE IN DEBTS FROM NOTHING
THERE'S FROM KOBE NINETEEN. RT
PLEASE MAKE SURE THAT LARA AND
STILL TAKING AND THEY GET A
COPY OF THAT TO. OKAY THANK YOU
AYE I BELIEVE WE HAVE A FEW
PEOPLE ON THE LINE WISHING TO
PARTICIPATE IS THAT ACCURATE
OPERATOR. YEAH OKAY THANK YOU
WE WILL GO TO LINE OKAY WE WILL
CUT THE LINE SEVENTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO THANK YOU THIS
IS DENNIS ALL THE ON THE ON
BEHALF OF THE PLASTIC RECYCLING
CORPORATION CALIFORNIA HI I'M
GONNA MIX TO TESTIMONY FROM
MONDAY AS WELL WE'RE IN Q. AND
GOT CUT OFF ON MONDAY SO- NEVER
EVEN TOUCHED BY SOMEONE TALK
ABOUT BOTH ISSUES. WHAT THINK
THE PLASTIC RECYCLING
CORPORATION CALIFORNIA IS A
INDUSTRY SPONSORED VOLUNTARY
STEWARDSHIP PROGRAM THAT HAS
BEEN AROUND FOR OVER THIRTY
YEARS. IT WE HAVE. THE GOAL IS
TO GET EVERY SINGLE BEVERAGE
BOTTLE IN CALIFORNIA. PTP
RECYCLED AND I THINK OUR POINT
OF OUR COMMENTS TODAY ARE ALL
PLASTICS ARE NOT CREATED EQUAL.
AND THEN THE RECYCLING SYSTEM
FOR PTT HAS BEEN DEVELOPED TOOK
THE BOTTLE BILL WHICH WAS
PASSED AND THE- EXCEPTIONAL JOB
PRIOR TO KOBE. OF COLLECTING
MATERIALS IN A FACT THE PRCC
HANDLED MUGS ABOUT FORTY THE
BUCKLEY 40% OF THE P. E. T. OF
SCRAP MATERIAL COLLECTED IN
CALIFORNIA. AND WE HAVE SUPPLY
CONTRACT WITH- WE KLEBER'S AND
RECYCLERS THAT ARE TURNING INTO
THE NEXT. LEVEL PRODUCTS WHICH
INCLUDE FROM CLAM SHELL BE
HEARD THAT THE THAT THE-
STARBIRD COMMISSION IS DEALING
WITH IT ALL THE WAY TO FOSTER.
BONTA YEAH THE PRTC TO- OWN
ADDRESSED TO. AND WILL KEEP TO
WORK ON THIS AS WE APPROACH THE
SEVEN THREE BETTER TRY BEEN A
CARPET WE'RE- IT SURE THAT WE
HAVE AS A ENTITY DON'T SENSE
CODE. THE SYSTEM HAS REALLY OUT
QUITE A BIT IT'S THIS GUY- AND
THERE IS A- WORKING LOWER
RESPECT RATE HAS INCREASED THE
AVERAGE FOR. THERE MAY BE WHAT
TO IN THE AND MODERN. THESE TO
BE THAT EFFICIENCY BUT ALL IF.
THE FIFTH LAST YEAR WORKED WITH
THE HERE REP. TO TRY TO GET
TEMP FUNDING WHICH YOU THINK
SHOULD BE. EXTENDED FROM THE
UNREDEEMED PLAN TO HELP BOLSTER
THE SYSTEM AS WELL AS WE LOOK
TOWARDS THIS YEAR FOR
MODERNIZING THE SYSTEM AND
EXPANDING OPTIONS LIKE THE BAG
DROP REVERSE VENDING MACHINES.
BUT ALSO ADDRESSING ISSUES.
SUCH AS THE HIGH DENNIS ARE
GONNA WRAP IT UP AND- NO
PROBLEM- THE PAYMENT SYSTEM AS
WELL SO LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU PLUS SECOND
CORPORATIONS IS READY TO WORK
WE APPRECIATE YOUR TIME BUT WE
NEED TO STABILIZE THE CURRENT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU AND JUST- I
KNOW SOME PEOPLE JUST ARE
TUNING IN. GIVE ME THAT NUMBER
ONCE AGAIN. IT IS ONE EIGHT
SEVEN. SIX TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE.
AGAIN. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX
NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN
THE ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE
ONE. FIFTY FOUR TWO OH TWO. ONE
THREE ONE FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO
TWO. OPERATOR WE HAVEN'T MALES
MALIGN. IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
MAKE A COMMENT THE PROMPTER ONE
AND THEN ZERO. THERE ARE NO
FURTHER COMMENT OKAY WE'RE
GONNA WAIT WHAT WE DO FOR A FEW
SECONDS BECAUSE I KNOW SOME
SOME INDIVIDUALS ARE TRYING TO
GET THE NUMBER. OKAY WE DO HAVE
TO QUEUING UP IT'LL BE A MOMENT
WHILE WE PROVIDE THE LINE
NUMBER NO PROBLEM.
WE WILL GO
TO LINE NUMBER NINETEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS WENDY
I'M JUST CALLING IN THE
CONSTITUENT AND OUR CARDS TO
SEND AND- I JUST WANTED TO MAKE
A COMMENT THAT I'VE BEEN A
RESIDENT IN OTHER JURISDICTIONS
LIKE THE STATE OF CONNECTICUT.
AND IT IS FAR AS THEIR BEVERAGE
RECYCLING. ARE PROCESS WORKED
IS MUCH MORE CONVENIENT BECAUSE
THEY HAVE THE SELF SERVE-
RECYCLING MACHINES UP THE LOCAL
GROCERY STORES AND I DON'T KNOW
IF THAT SOMETHING THAT WAS
CONSIDERED IN CALIFORNIA OR THE
BACKEND- PROCESSING OF THE
RECYCLABLES TOO DIFFICULT IN
THAT INSTANCE OR PERHAPS THE
GROCERS ASSOCIATION DIDN'T WANT
TO BE INVOLVED IN THE- RETURNS
BUT- THAT WAS CERTAINLY EASIER
AS A AS A CONSUMER. CHIU JUST
TAKE MY YOU KNOW CANCEL LIVE OR
BOTTLE THAT I CONSUME THAT WE
CAN RETURN OF MAS AT THE
GROCERY STORE AND- PUT THE
MONEY TOWARDS MY GROCERY BILL
DOWN THAT'S MY COMMENT AND-
THANKS FOR THE HEARING. THANK
YOU. NEXT WE WILL GO TO LINE
NUMBER TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES MY NAME IS JEFF DONLEVY
WITH MEANS RESOURCES IN HAYWARD
LIKE TO THANK THE ASSEMBLY FOR.
PUTTING UP WITH ALL THE PUBLIC
COMMENTS YOU GUYS DO A GREAT
JOB- THE PRIOR SPEAKERS YOU'VE
HAD- I HAVE TOUCHED ON SOME KEY
POINTS. SUSAN COLLINS JASON
YOUNG MARTIN BARK RICHARD BY A
TENANTS FROM PRCC ALL HAD VERY
KEY POINTS THAT I COULD QUOTE.
THE BOTTLE BILL NEEDS TO BE
FIXED- MAJOR OVERHAUL AND
THERE'S TWO KEY PLAYERS
INCLUDING ALLEN COMPANY MEANS-
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS THAT WANT TO
HELP. CONSUMERS GET THEIR
DEPOSIT BACK- AS DENNIS ABI ON
YOU MENTIONED THE FUND HAS
GROWN BY OVER A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS. INTHE LAST YEAR TO
COPE WITH IT AND OTHER ISSUES
AND THAT'S MONEY THAT CONSUMERS
ARE NOT SPENDING IN THE LOCAL
ECONOMY- A HUGE REASON IS WE
HAVE AREAS WITHOUT RECYCLING
CENTERS. IN A WAY THAT
RECYCLING CENTERS GET PAID IT
DOESN'T WORK IN SOME AREAS THE
BAY AREA AND ONE OF THE MOST
UNDERSERVED AREAS. WHERE
RECYCLING CENTERS HEADLINES
FROM EIGHT AM TO FIVE PM AND
THEY'RE BARELY MAKING IT BY- SO
WE NEED A MAJOR OVERHAUL OF THE
PROGRAM THE GROCERS WANT TO
HELP BUT THEY NEED TO BE PAID.
IT'S A BIG PART IN THE PROGRAM
RIGHT NOW WHERE IF PEOPLE TAKE
CONTAINERS BACK TO THE STORES
GROCERS DON'T GET PAID FOR
THEIR EFFORTS. I KNOW THERE'S A
LOT THAT WANT TO HELP WITH
THAT- BUT RIGHT NOW THE WAY THE
PAYMENTS WORK THEY JUST DON'T
GET PAID FOR HELPING OUT- BUT
THERE ARE OTHER INNOVATIVE
PROGRAMS INCLUDING THE BURST
MACHINES. BACKDROP GRAMS OF ARE
YOU DEMOCRATS. ALL THOSE CAN
HAPPEN IN CALIFORNIA YOU CAN
HAVE A MUCH BETTER PROGRAM. WE
JUST NEED A MAJOR OVERHAUL AND-
MING'S RECYCLING- AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS WERE WERE READY TO
HELP WITH. THIS PROGRAM. THANK
YOU THANK YOU THE- THERE ARE NO
FOR COMMENTS. GIVEN THE NUMBER
WE'RE GONNA WIN ONE MORE-
FEMURS FEWER MINUTES ANOTHER
ENDED BEEN REACHING OUT TO US
TRYING TO GET ON THE LINE. HE
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
MAKE A COMMENT THE PROMPTER ONE
AND THEN ZERO. ONE EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN RIGHT WE DID HAVE
ONE JUST QUEUE UP IT'LL BE A
MOMENT WHILE WE PROVIDE THE
LINE NUMBER K.
WE WILL GO TO
LIE NUMBER TWENTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. REPUBLICAN CHAIR
MADAM CHAIR PUBLIC STREET- I
REPRESENT THREE MAJORITY OF
THE- LARGE PRIMARY RECYCLERS
AND I WANTED TO ONE THANKS VERY
MUCH FOR THE HEARING THERE WAS
A LOT OF REALLY GOOD
INFORMATION- THE EDUCATION
ABOUT THE BANDS WOULD BE REALLY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE I WILL GET
DIRTY BAIL- THE RECLAIMER
YOU'RE STUCK WITH TRYING TO.
TAKE THE BAD PORTIONS TO THE
LANDFILL I'D ALSO SAY PLEASE
STEP IN ON THE CAL RECYCLE A
BUDGET CYCLE- BECAUSE WE NEED
TO MAKE SURE TO CARRY CYCLE
CONTINUES TO HAVE THE RIGHT
PEOPLE- WORKING WITH OUR%
RECLAIMER IS TO MAKE SURE WE
CAN DO LOOP TO LOOP ARE CLOSED
LOOP. WHICH MAKE BOTTLE TO
BOTTLE AND I JUST A COMMAND YOU
GUYS WOULD DO A GREAT JOB AND
HOPEFULLY CARBON LIGHT INDORAMA
AND MY OTHER CLIENTS CAN
QUICKLY COULD CREATE. BETTER
HEARING YEAH. THANK YOU. THERE
ARE NO FURTHER COMMENT. NO
FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU WITH
THAT WE WILL ADJOURN THIS
HEARING THANK YOU.